Bist du nicht so interessiert an deiner Lieblingskanzlerin?
Ich bin nicht so interessiert. Ich habe gestern ein paar Clips gesehen,
sie ließ sich interviewen von Anne Will und wurde dort auch befragt zur Ukraine-Politik
und dann hat sie nochmal gesagt, dass sie den richtigen Kurs gefahren ist.
Und ich fand die Begründung, die sie dann geliefert hat, gar nicht so schlecht
und fand das eigentlich auch eine sehr differenzierte Antwort, die sie gegeben hat.
Und deshalb, weil sie sagte, es erscheint jetzt so, als sei das alles falsch gewesen.
Aber es war tatsächlich auch der Versuch, weiterhin in einem Dialog zu stehen.
Es war der Versuch, nicht nur Deutschland wirtschaftlich gut darzustellen,
sondern wirklich auch auf diplomatischem Wege zu versuchen, Eskalation zu verhindern.
Und wir können ja festhalten, möglicherweise wäre es viel früher eskaliert.
Hätte man andere Dinge dann auch noch tun müssen? Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Das ist etwas, was sie dann auch schuldig bleibt in ihrer Antwort.
Aber jetzt, wie das stattgefunden hat in der deutschen Medienwelt,
die Kanzlerin also nach dem Einmarsch Putins völlig zu verdammen,
halte ich für falsch und ich bin ja bekanntermaßen kein Merkel-Fan.
Was ich auch noch mitbekommen habe, war zweitens, dass sie sich nun ausgesprochen
hat für eine Lockerung der Schuldenbremse, denn jetzt sei die Zeit und die Krisen
so groß und dann denke ich mir.
Sie hatte jetzt 16 Jahre Zeit gehabt und sie hat viele Krisen erlebt.
Sie hat über eine Million Menschen mehr 2015 erlebt.
Das ist die Phase, wir haben es bei Philippa Siegel-Klöckner nachgelesen,
in der ihr Finanzminister Schäuble sagt, jetzt aber mal Austeritätspolitik,
jetzt aber mal ganz kräftig die Schuldenbremse einhalten.
Sie hat Corona erlebt, hat mit Macron diese gemeinschaftliche Verschuldung ermöglicht,
hätte dort wunderbar, wo man eh so eine Eintracht im Bundestag hatte,
es gab ja in dem Sinne gar nicht mehr eine kritische Stimme zur Merkel-Politik,
außer jetzt irgendwie von der AfD oder was,
hätte man also wunderbar die Möglichkeit gehabt zu sagen, angesichts dieser
Krise müssen wir jetzt die Schuldenbremse reformieren.
Das hat sie alles liegen lassen, wir haben nur über Inzidenzen und all den Kram
gesprochen und jetzt aber 2024 da zu sitzen und sagen, jetzt müssen wir das
mal machen, finde ich zwar richtig, das zu sagen, aber ich finde sie auch ein bisschen feige.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt nur das Buch so weit gelesen, wie es für uns interessant
schien und nicht die Talks von ihr verfolgt bei Anne Wille.
Dennoch höre ich daraus, der große Tenor unserer Zeit ist Zäsuren erkennen,
denn wenn wir jetzt über, was hat Merkel 2009, 2012,
2014 zu Putin und Ukraine gesagt, Putin kommt ja sehr oft vor,
ist ja irgendwie der meistgenannte Name oder was, ich habe irgendeine Auswertung
gesehen, 180 mal wird Putin genannt,
kein Wunder, er kommt ja auch quasi 100 Jahre lang vor.
Gerade in ihrer politischen Geschichte.
Aber wir müssen doch klar markieren, 22. Februar 2022 ist eine Zäsur.
Wir müssen also die Zeit danach anders bewerten als die Zeit davor.
Merkel macht das selbst im Buch auch. Es gibt nicht ein Kapitel zu ihrer Kanzlerschaft,
sondern vor und nach 2015.
Außerdem hat sie sich dagegen entschieden, zwei Bände zu schreiben,
weil sie befürchtete, wenn ich zwei Bände schreibe, wird nur der zweite gelesen
Und der erste, mein Leben in der DDR, wird ausgeblendet.
Ich allerdings habe diesen Teil ausgeblendet. Ich bin also mitten rein ins Buch
gesprungen und wollte nicht nochmal hören, mit welchem Trabi sie oder die Mutter wo rumgefahren ist.
Und ich möchte grundsätzlich jetzt Leseempfehlungen geben für Journalisten, die dieses Buch lesen.
Denn ich habe Podcasts gehört, in denen mir Journalisten erklären,
dass sie damals auch dabei waren bei der Zeit.
Als Zuschauer, Berichterstatter, auch im Flugzeug, wie auch immer.
Und jetzt mir erklären, was hat Merkel ins Buch reingeschrieben und was nicht.
Und ja, wenn man die Zeit als Journalist verpasst, ein Gegenbuch zu schreiben,
also jetzt punktgenau ein fertiges Buch zu haben als Schwarzbuch,
Schwarz-Gelb, GroKo, was auch immer, um sozusagen einen Kontrapunkt zu setzen
für Journalisten, die ja ansonsten gerne auf Kontroverse gehen,
die also dann feststellen,
ja wir laden mal Merkel ein fürs Gespräch, aber auch ihren publizistischen Widersacher.
Es gibt keinen publizistischen Widersacher.
Also erklären mir Journalisten gerade, in dem Merkel-Buch steht ja nur drin,
was die Merkel selbst da reingeschrieben hat und gar nicht, was andere da noch reinschreiben müssen.
Ja, so ist es halt, wenn man sich nicht hinsetzt und ein Buch schreibt zum Thema.
Gut, aber wir warten ja auch weiter auf die Aufklärung von Herr Feldenkirchen
und wie sie alle heißen, da wird da mal was passiert. so.
Autobiografie heißt das ja.
Genau, es heißt Autobiografie, ja, wir brauchen jetzt halt auch noch eine Biografie
und ich würde sagen, jetzt lass mal die Merkel Merkel sein, mir geht es um die
Amtszeit ja, dieser ganze gefühlige Teil und so und ich möchte gerne mal.
Dann kommt man schnell von 700.
Auf 100 Seiten.
Ich wünsche mir ein Buch, das mir jetzt nicht nochmal sagt, da hätte Merkel
aber mit Minsk und Steinmeier und so weiter ja, das ist alles,
was wäre wenn, mir ginge es jetzt darum mal zu sagen, die ökonomische Bilanz
von Merkel sieht wie folgt aus.
Genau, und da muss man jetzt sagen, ein Buch hat ein Autor, der schreibt etwas
in dieses Buch hinein und dann gibt es Leser, die lesen etwas aus dem Buch heraus
und es muss nicht deckungsgleich sein.
Ein Autor der 700 Seiten, das ist wie jetzt dieses neue Podcast-Paradigma,
lass mal ein Politiker drei Stunden da reden, dann kommt da mehr bei rum, als er wollte.
Die Talking Points sind dann irgendwann aufgebraucht. So, und so muss dieses
Buch jetzt gelesen werden, weshalb ich,
Ich vorschlagen möchte, auf Zäsuren zu achten. Ich werde die Zäsuren jetzt nennen.
Zum einen, kann man sich ja dafür interessieren, die persönliche Zäsur, sie kommt ins Amt.
Selten war man, glaube ich, so nah dran. Es ist ein sehr impressionistischer Text.
Sie erklärt uns, welche Arien sie im Kopf hatte und in welche Oper sie eigentlich
wollte, als der Anruf kam. Wir müssen jetzt die Banken retten und so weiter und so fort.
Also wir erfahren auch für uns eigentlich sehr viel Interessantes.
Was hat es mit, es ist ja immer noch ein Mensch, der die Entscheidung treffen
muss. Und das ist auch ein großes Problem.
Noch treffen Menschen die Entscheidung. Das heißt, wir haben in diesem Buch
eine Dokumentation über 16 Jahre deutsche Kanzlerschaft, die ungefähr wie folgt
funktioniert. Und da sind Details jetzt wirklich egal.
Eine Partei entscheidet sich für ein Programm, klebt dann einen Namen dran.
Auf einem Parteitag bewährt sich das, wir haben einen Kandidaten.
Dieser Kandidat wird gewählt, Merkel sitzt da, ganz ruhiger Moment.
Sie nimmt ihre Ernennungsurkunde entgegen, kann diesen Moment schon gar nicht
mehr erinnern, weil alles so verschwommen.
So, wir haben dann also eine Bundesregierung, die erste Frau regiert,
sie kriegt diese Gratulation, sie schreibt Programme.
Seitenweise schreibt sie in diesem Text, wie ihre Routinen aussahen.
Sie hat sich also mit der Baumann hingesetzt und hat alle Organisationen,
Institutionen und Personen genannt, die immer abgefrühstückt werden müssen mit
Kanzlertermin, egal was die Welt gerade breithält.
Und dann wird einfach seitenlang werden diese Organisationen genannt.
Es kommt auch ihre Maske zum Beispiel drin vor.
Der Kanzler hat ja eine Dienstwohnung im Kanzleramt.
Sie brauchte die nicht, weil sie wohnte ja gleich um die Ecke.
Also hat sie ihre Visagistin diese Wohnung gegeben, damit sie immer gut aussehen
kann. Also solche Sachen werden das schon.
Sehr gut.
Also ihre Kanzlerschaft beginnt, die Partei steht parat, sie ist Parteichefin,
Fraktionsvorchefs hat sie soweit geklärt, Kauder und so weiter,
alle kommen davor, es werden Programme entwickelt.
Es gibt Kabinettsbeschlüsse, das Parlament verhält sich dazu,
es finden EU-Gipfel statt und so weiter und so fort.
Also wir haben eine 16-Jährige, wie funktioniert eigentlich demokratische Politik?
Und wir müssen verstehen, das war es jetzt.
So funktioniert es jetzt nicht mehr. Wir sind jetzt im Donald-Trump-Zeitalter.
Es finden keine Gipfel mehr statt, bei denen vorher irgendwelche Beschlussvorlagen
ausgetauscht werden und man dann so, ah ja, ist ja schön, jetzt müssen wir mal
noch mit dem Zypras so ein bisschen reden und dann wird das schon.
Also wir haben hier ein Dokument, das eine Zäsur einläutet, weil es die letzte
Kanzlerschaft zeigte, in der noch immer nur in Zweierbündnissen,
immer nur mit die WHO funktioniert,
es kommt eine Pandemie, ja gut, dann hören wir mal kurz auf die anderen,
was die so sagen, dann kommen irgendwelche Experten, dann regelt man das und so weiter und so fort.
Diese Zeit ist jetzt vorbei und das macht dieses Buch sehr deutlich.
Es ist sozusagen das letzte Aufblühen. Wir entscheiden uns nochmal für eine
Frau als Kanzlerin, die dann auch sagt, also nach mir diese komische Dreierampel, Männer.
So ja, genau, Männer. Das Kriterium ist jetzt nicht mehr, naja,
da wurden irgendwelche falsche Beschlussvorlagen vorgelegt oder die eine Partei
waren nicht kompatibel, sondern Männer.
Das ist der Kommentar der Zeit.
Aber ist das ein sinnvoller Kommentar?
Das ist ein sehr sinnvoller Kommentar, weil jetzt müssen die Journalisten selber mitdenken.
Sie können jetzt nicht einfach pfadabhängig, so hat es bei Merkel funktioniert,
mal gucken, was der nächste Kanzler macht, sondern nein, diese Pfadabhängigkeit
wird jetzt unterbrochen.
Es ist eine Zäsur, ab jetzt neu denken.
Dieses Buch erklärt uns nochmal, wie es war.
Es ist das Zäsurbuch und wir haben das ja jetzt gerade gesehen.
Robert Pausch hat es in der Zeit nochmal sehr ausführlich uns niedergeschrieben und recherchiert,
wie Christian Lindner mit seinen Koalitionspartnern umgegangen ist,
ist tatsächlich ein deutliches Zeichen für die Zäsur, die du uns da eben gezeigt hast.
Und natürlich wäre die Reaktion naheliegend zu sagen, Männer und in diesem Fall waren es Männer.
Ich würde aber auch hier sagen, es ist eher Mann. Es war Christian Lindner, der das getan hat.
Es war nicht das Problem von Olaf Scholz oder das Problem von Robert Habeck.
Und ich würde aber auch generell davon absehen wollen, dass man jetzt plötzlich
so tut, als sei das ein Problem, das zwischen Männern entstehen könnte und das
bei Frauen nicht in dieser Weise existiert.
Wir haben nun jetzt sehr viele schlimme Frauen, die regieren.
Ich nenne nur mal Meloni.
Die ist ja auch ein Mann.
Und man kann das nämlich nicht so weiterführen.
Das wird sehr gern gemacht. Im Spiegel war jetzt auch nochmal zu Trump,
war so eine ganz merkwürdige Analyse da zu lesen,
dass er alles nur den Männern, die die Frauen nicht mögen, zu verdanken,
dass Trump jetzt so viele Stimmen hatte.
Das stimmt dann nicht, wenn man sich die Zahlen genauer ansieht.
Das wäre ja ein Erklärungsmodell, wenn es mit den Daten übereinstimmen würde,
könnte man sagen, ja, es scheint so zu sein.
Es ist aber nicht so und deswegen glaube ich, kommt man sowieso mit diesem Vorwurf Männer nicht so weit.
Sondern ich glaube, dass wir eine Zäsur erleben, die so aussieht,
dass wir diese normalen Abläufe als solche infrage gestellt bekommen und auch
die Institutionen als solche infrage gestellt werden.
Und dass die Reaktionen darauf, wenn die Institutionen infrage gestellt werden,
oft so aussehen, dass man sagt, wir müssen die Institutionen stärken.
Diese Stärkung der Institutionen führt dann häufig dazu.
Dass es noch politisierter wird, dass plötzlich Institutionen zum Feind erklärt
werden, die vorher nie politisiert worden sind und wir an einen Punkt geraten,
wo also normale Abläufe immer weniger stattfinden.
Und das sehe ich absolut so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das was mit Männern zu tun hat, sondern ich glaube,
dass das eine Entwicklung ist, die losgetreten wurde von Trump und anderen.
Man kann jetzt aber auch sagen, es gab ja vor Trump schon so jemanden wie Berlusconi.
Aber da Trump das Spiel nochmal sehr viel weiter getrieben hat,
sehen wir jetzt, wie sehr viele sich daran orientieren.
Besonders können wir das ja beobachten bei zwei Parteien in Deutschland,
einmal bei der CDU und bei der FDP, die AfD sowieso immer schon,
aber da können wir es jetzt ganz deutlich erleben.
Und da sehen wir also einen neuen Modus Vivendi und das ist tatsächlich besorgniserregend
und da wünschte man sich, man hätte noch Leute, die sich an Pläne halten und
morgen muss ich mit folgenden Leuten sprechen.
Und wenn ich denen mein Wort gebe, dann gilt es auch nicht wie bei Christian Lindner.
Ich sage dir jetzt in diesem Moment was, geh zur Tür heraus und verkünde dann etwas völlig anderes.
Okay, zwei Sachen dazu, bevor ich auf Merkels Buch zurückkomme.
Die Nostalgie finde ich gut, aber genau die Pfadabhängigkeit.
Also es wäre doch schön, wenn nochmal Pläne eingehalten würden.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen jetzt eine Anpassungsleistung für die Zeit nach der
Gutenberg-Parenthese.
Ich habe darüber 2016 geschrieben, irgendwann kam das Druckzeitalter,
plötzlich konnte man für unspezifiziertes Publikum schreiben,
Satzungen, Verträge, wie auch immer. Und diese Zeit ist vorbei.
Ich habe das im Buch damals beschrieben als, um die Gesellschaft mit Nahrungsmitteln
zu versorgen, brauchte man 97% der produktiven Biomasse auf dem Feld.
Und die haben sich einfach zugerufen. Es regnet heute, wir machen es morgen.
Also eine ganz spontane Entscheidung, die komplett der Umwelt unterworfen ist.
Kein Plan im Sinne von, ah ja, nee, doch, wir halten den Plan heute durch.
Was brauchen wir dafür? Eine Fabrik, die uns einen Mähdrescher baut.
Der Mähdrescher braucht ein Dach.
Ich habe eine Heizung im Führerstand und fahre auch im Regen über das Feld.
Ja, wir fallen nicht zurück in eine Zeit vor Technik. Nur wir kommen jetzt in
eine KI-Zeit aller Technik, in der der Mensch gar nicht mehr so die zentrale
Rolle spielt, sondern wir sozusagen auch unsere uns unterworfene technische Umwelt
zielprogrammieren können, ohne ihnen Schritt für Schritt sagen zu müssen,
was sie jetzt tun sollen, was der Name für Programm ist.
Wenn dann, Unterscheidung zu machen. So, wir brauchen also keine Programme,
sondern wir sagen den Maschinen einfach, was wir wollen und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert.
Und dieses Trial and Error Prinzip wird jetzt die Gesellschaft im Sturm erobern.
Schon allein, weil die Politiker in Europa, auch wenn sie es nochmal schaffen,
ein nächstes, und es wird wahrscheinlich wieder ein Dreierbündnis,
noch Programme zu entwerfen.
Sie wissen niemals, was auf Gipfeln
passiert, wenn dort chinesische oder amerikanische Mitstreiter sind.
Also es ist einfach völlig unklar. Der eine macht irgendwas mit Zöllen,
der andere ist wütend und dann war es das mit dem Programm.
Dieser Klausewitz-Spruch, der Plan für einen Krieg ist so lange gut,
bis der Krieg beginnt. Danach ist einfach Nebel des Krieges,
gilt jetzt für die Politik allgemein.
Also es wird, was das angeht, dramatisch.
Ich will nicht zu nostalgisch sein, ich will nur sagen, diese normalen Abläufe
haben etwas für sich. Sie waren auch Schutzräume.
Nehmen wir jetzt beispielsweise den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen.
Dieser war immer auch politisch umkämpft. Was findet da statt?
Und deswegen wollte die CDU ja auch damals das Privatfernsehen haben,
damit auch die Kapitalseite stärker vertreten ist. Aber man hat nicht den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
als solchen infrage gestellt.
Bei Theatern war es auch immer umkämpft, was Budgets anbelangt.
Jetzt hören wir aber immer mehr von konservativen Stimmen. Ich werde heute einige
präsentieren. Warum überhaupt?
Können wir es nicht ganz abschaffen. Und da sehen wir also, dass diese normalen
Abläufe systematisch gestört werden, wo Disruption plötzlich überall Einzug hält.
Das hat auch Vorteile. Und wenn ich mir ansehe, wie beispielsweise über den
Ostkrieg berichtet wird in den großen Medienhäusern,
über den Krieg in der Ukraine oder jetzt über Scholz oder Pistorius,
diese Unsinnsdebatte, die wir da jetzt eine Woche lang hatten,
dann bin ich um jede Disruption froh.
Ich würde sogar den Leuten zurufen, ja, geht zu den Alternativen.
Ich bin froh, wenn diese Medienhäuser an Wirkmacht verlieren.
Ja, das will ich ganz klar sagen. Ich finde also durchaus Positives daran,
wenn es die Disruption gibt.
Nur sehe ich jetzt gerade, dass diese Disruption größtenteils in eine Richtung
geht, die es eher noch schlimmer macht, als es ohnehin schon ist.
Ich möchte das, was du sagst, dramatisieren, ohne Nostalgie zu verfallen,
weil du sagst, du siehst an dem Zeitalter der bewährten Programme und Pläne
Positives. Ich sehe da nur Positives.
Das Hashtag, unter dem dieses Zeitalter läuft, heißt Zivilisation.
Womit ich wirklich meine, wir verlassen jetzt ein bisschen das Zeitalter der Zivilisation.
Wir wissen noch nicht, wie weit. Die Deportationsprogramme in Amerika sind jetzt geschrieben.
Und mit geschrieben meine ich nicht, da ist ein Plan entworfen,
sondern wir sehen einfach, wer da als Persönlichkeit diesen Häusern vorgestellt wird.
Und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie diese Häuser, die natürlich noch fadabhängig
aus dieser zivilisatorischen Zeit kommen, darauf reagieren, dass die Befehle einfach anders lauten.
Und jetzt ist auch die Frage, wie weit kann man solche Befehle treiben?
Wir wissen, wie weit die Macht des Präsidenten geht.
Aber du biegst doch da nicht mit Optimismus hin.
Nein, gar nicht. Ich bin ganz pessimistisch und finde es auch ganz dramatisch,
weswegen ich sage, jetzt ist die Zeit auf Zäsuren zu achten.
Journalisten, die einfach glauben, wir ziehen jetzt die Zivilisation ein bisschen
weiter, der Präsident heißt, ah ja Trump, okay gut, dann heißt jetzt der Präsident Trump.
Ich gehe so weit zu sagen, es ist kein Präsident.
Also wenn ihr den Fernseher anmacht und dort heißt es, Präsident Trump hat,
würde ich sagen, na vielleicht falsches Denken. Ist er wirklich ein Präsident?
Also schon das erste Wort ist hier, finde ich, fragwürdig, denn wir müssen hier andere Worte wählen.
Wir können auch mal zurück in die Geschichte gehen, Kaiser, Diktatoren,
Könige, was auch immer, aber jetzt einfach zu sagen, er ist halt der nächste
Präsident, ist, wir hören gleich Clips,
die New York Times ist sehr besorgt und die New York Times ist die einzige Publikation,
bei der ich gerade, wenn ich sie lese, feststelle, die haben die Zäsur erkannt.
Die wissen genau, die juristischen, parlamentarischen und medialen Restriktionen
einer Präsidentschaft sind alle drei gleichzeitig ausgefallen.
Ja, ich bin etwas skeptisch, was diese Diagnose der New York Times anbelangt.
Die ist immer ein bisschen sehr alarmistisch.
Das war sie im Übrigen auch schon, als Trump zum ersten Mal gewählt wurde.
Und ich denke, wir werden eher eine große Normalisierung dessen erleben.
Denn es gibt auch gar nicht diese Proteste also erinnert du erinnerst dich an
Hollywood, an all diese Leute, wie sie öffentlich gegen Trump Stunk gemacht haben.
Jetzt höre ich schon wieder das partabhängige Denken, es sollte doch Proteste
geben, wenn die Sowjet gewählt wird findet nicht statt, weißt du warum?
Keiner weiß was passiert, keiner hat ein Programm dafür, Protest ist gerade
kein adäquates Programm, wieso sollte man jetzt auf die Straße gehen?
Nein, ich glaube man wird sich einfach damit arrangieren, man wird sagen,
ja Trump macht ein bisschen eine rassistische Politik, ein bisschen eine frauenfeindliche
Politik und dann irgendwann wird das intensiviert und dann sagt man,
oh, ist aber ein bisschen sehr frauenfeindlich jetzt gerade und dann geht es aber einfach so weiter.
Es gibt eine ganz große Anpassung daran und wir können das ja schon die ganze Zeit erleben.
Also guck dir an, wie Ursula von der Leyen reagiert auf Trump.
Guck dir an, wie hier in Deutschland darauf reagiert wird.
Ich will doch Folgendes sagen. Diese Normalisierung, die du siehst und die ich
auch sehe, Die passiert einfach.
Nur, wir müssen jetzt kognitiv schon, heute schon verstehen,
was wir nicht erst in vier Jahren einsehen können, diese Normalisierung ist
ein Abschied aus der Zivilisation, wie wir ihn kennen.
Das stimmt.
Es wird sehr viel dramatischer, als wir glauben. Wir denken immer,
Handmaid's Tale und so weiter, ah, da kommen die wieder mit diesen Vergleichen
und so. Also wir haben das besprochen, wie das Frauenbild ist.
Trump hat angesagt, ich möchte die Frauen beschützen, ob sie wollen oder nicht, so lautet sein Zitat.
Das wird weiter getrieben.
Man soll sich jetzt nochmal diese Bilder aus Kabul, Olympiamannschaften Kabul
vor 50 Jahren, Frauen mit wallendem Haar, kurzen Höschen, fahren zur Olympiade
und machen dort einen sportlichen Wettkampf. Und wir wissen,
wie es heute dort aussieht.
Wir wissen, wie es in Syrien aussieht und wir wissen, wie es vor 40 Jahren in Syrien aussah.
Das waren alles keine hochgradig religiösen Länder.
Nur, damals reichte es völlig, eine politische Ideologie zu haben, um das durchzusetzen.
Jetzt haben wir noch diese komische KI, die völlig sich dem ausliefert, der sie erschafft.
Und das größte Datensender der Welt hat derzeit Elon Musk mit seinem XAI.
Also das sind einfach wirklich sehr gefährliche Zeiten und ich finde es bescheuert,
diese ganzen Journalisten zu sehen, die mir dann erzählen, ah,
da hat aber Merkel das und das nicht ins Buch reingeschrieben.
Ich will mal folgendes aus dem Buch jetzt zusammenfassen, wie ich es verstanden habe.
Also diese erste Amtsentführung ist für uns, finde ich, interessant.
Das ist Impressionismus, der bringt uns weiter.
Nur danach geht es ja los mit einer Kapitelfolge, die wie folgt startet. Eurokrise.
Alexis Tsipras ist der neu gewählte Regierungschef in Griechenland.
Mit ihm begann die Krise nicht, sondern es fand eine demokratische Wahl statt,
bei der das Volk sagte, wir wählen jetzt diesen hart linken Typen,
der noch Varoufakis ins Finanzministerium bringt.
So, Merkel will also in die Oper, kriegt einen Anruf. hier funktioniert irgendwie
alles nicht, wir brauchen hier Kohle. Wie viel Kohle? 700 Milliarden.
Und Schäuble, ja, weil sonst die Märkte und so, wir sind hier, ne?
Also man sieht, an diesem Buch kann man lesen, wie sehr die Politik glaubte,
sie sei den Märkten unterworfen.
Sie erklärt dann auch, wie sie dazu kam, von marktkonformer Demokratie oder
demokratiekonformer Märkten und so weiter zu sprechen, entschuldigt sich dafür
nicht, sondern erklärt einfach nur, das war der Zeitgeist.
Und ich denke mir, wenn das der Zeitgeist war, ist es gefährlich,
weil wir damit aus unserem Gefüge eine Politik ausgetrieben haben und dem Markt unterworfen haben,
wie es hätte nicht sein müssen, wie wir auch heute sehen, ja,
am Ende ist die EZB eingesprungen, hat einfach die ganzen Staatsanleihen gekauft
und die ganzen Spreads sind halt einfach wieder zusammengeschrumpft und das war es.
Keine große Magie, sondern einfach politisches Handeln.
So, wenn Trump jetzt solche Überraschungen gelingt, ein Primat der Politik zu
behaupten, wo vorher hieß, nee, ist alternativlos, kann man gar nichts machen,
die Märkte regieren hier und so, So, dann wird es brenzlig, weil wir haben jetzt
von Isabella Weber schon diese antifaschistische Politik,
Wirtschaftspolitik, die einfach nur sagt, Preiskontrolle.
Es ist nicht wichtig, wie der DAX steht, es ist nicht wichtig,
wie irgendwas steht. Es ist einfach nur wichtig, was kostet im Supermarkt die Milch.
So, und dann funktioniert auch Demokratie, weil die Leute dann nicht komplett
überfordert sind und sich denken...
Also ökonomisch fühle ich hier gar keine Teilhabe. Wieso soll ich mich jetzt
politisch teilhabend fühlen?
Aber Trump ist doch da im Prinzip ähnlich, dass er am Ende derjenige ist,
der am längeren Hebel sitzt.
Und als solche versteht er sich auch. Deswegen ist es ja nicht so,
wie jetzt gerade, also ich finde eher die Rezeption ist falsch in Bezug auf
Elon Musk, dass gesagt wird, Musk regiert jetzt im Weißen Haus.
Ja, Musk hat natürlich großen Einfluss und macht den ja auch schon geltend,
wenn man sieht, welche Liberalisierung da bei Automobilität,
autonomes Fahren und so weiter kommen soll. Aber es ist ja so,
dass Trump derjenige ist, der entscheidet.
Wenn Trump im Februar sagt, das ist plötzlich nicht mehr der größte Unternehmer
der Welt, sondern der allerschlechteste Unternehmer der Welt,
so geht das ja bei Trump relativ schnell, dann ist Elon Musk raus und dann wird ein nächster geholt.
Das heißt, Trump, der primat des politischen,
also wenn man das primat des politischen so wie Trump versteht,
dann ist er immer derjenige, der entscheidet.
Es ist dann genau nicht das, was Merkel jetzt da erlebt hat,
dass sie sagt, ja marktkonforme Demokratie, ich muss mich jetzt den Märkten
anpassen, sondern Trump ist ja zum Beispiel mit seinen Zöllen offenbar bereit.
Gegen seine, nicht nur Konsumenten, also seine Wähler zu agieren,
sondern auch gegen seine Unternehmen, die natürlich auch wahnsinnig darunter
leiden könnten, wenn diese Zölle kommen.
Das ist ja nicht nur ein Protektionismus, der allen wohl tut,
sondern der auch viel Schlimmes in den USA anrichten kann.
Aber wenn Trump sagt, primates Politischen, ich mache das.
Wir können jetzt hier nur Vermutungen anstellen. Wir müssen jetzt abwarten,
was es bedeutet, dass Elon Musk...
Einen Internet-Service-Provider hat, der selbst dann noch funktioniert,
wenn Atomwaffen eingesetzt wurden, weil er einfach im Weltraum operiert.
Das sind keine Seekabel, die man durchschneiden kann, wie wir es jetzt mitgekriegt
haben. Das sind keine Funktürme, die man sprengen kann.
Wir wissen, die Nazis fuhren damals nach Danzig und haben erst mal das Radio
weggeschossen und so weiter.
Dieser Internet-Service-Provider, der komplett Musk unterliegt,
funktioniert selbst nach Atomkriegen, weil er einfach im Weltraum operiert.
Elon Musk hat das größte KI-Rechenzentrum der Welt. Das ist einfach Science von XAI.
Das ist natürlich physisch gebunden, also man könnte es zerstören,
aber das ist noch an die Erde gebunden.
Aber du würdest doch schon sagen, das Primat des Politischen liegt bei Trump.
Als Systemtheoretiker kann ich dir nur sagen, das Primat des politischen ist
immer eine Fantasie gewesen, weil es gibt gar keinen Primat.
Also es ist nicht nur, nicht die Politik hat keinen Primat, sondern wir haben
es einfach mit einer funktionalen Differenzierung zu tun, bei der Sachen sich
jetzt gegenseitig irritieren und wir aber nicht nur von vornherein nicht steuern können,
sondern wir auch erst nachträglich gesehen, welche Geschichte jetzt überhaupt geschrieben wurde.
Deswegen, wir wissen es einfach nicht, wer von beiden der Mächtigere ist.
Konkretes Beispiel, Joe Biden macht eine ziemlich radikale Anti-China-Politik,
setzt damit die Linie von Trump fort, Trump wird daran wieder anknüpfen.
Diese Anti-China-Politik schadet vor allem Apple, dem wichtigsten Konzern der USA.
Daran zeigt sich doch sehr deutlich, dass also nicht Apple das Weiße Haus regiert,
wie man eine Zeit lang glauben konnte, auch durch diese Clinton-Ära oder auch noch unter Obama.
Und es sind ja all diese vielen Bücher über Überwachungskapitalismus und all
das erschienen, die Macht der Konzerne und so, die das nahegelegt haben.
Ich würde aber sagen, dass wir jetzt heute mit diesem erstarkenden Patriotismus,
mit der Rückkehr des Nationalstaats im Sinne von, das ist jetzt aber das Wichtigste,
dass dieser geschützt ist und dessen Interessen vertreten werden,
dass genau das nicht mehr gilt.
Und das können wir auch für Deutschland gut sehen.
Wenn man jetzt der Industrie unterworfen wäre,
BASF und Co., dann würde die Energiepolitik ziemlich anders aussehen und auch
die Außenpolitik würde nicht so gestaltet werden, wie Baerbock das gerade tut.
Ein Beispiel, sozusagen niedergestaffelter, wo klar ist, so folgendreich ist
es nicht und es ist überschaubar. Ein Restaurant.
Der Koch sagt, ich bin der Wichtigste, denn ohne mich kriegen unsere Gäste nichts
zu essen. Es gäbe gar keinen Grund, dass wir eine Rechnung bezahlt kriegen.
Der Müllmann, der morgens kommt, sagt, also wenn ich den Müll nicht abhole,
kannst du gar nicht kochen. Ihr wäre alles verseucht mit Maten und so weiter.
Der Kellner so, ich bin hier der Allerwichtigste. Ohne mich käme das Essen gar
nicht zum Tisch. Du müsstest selber zum Tisch gehen.
So, jeder behauptet von sich, der Wichtigste zu sein.
Dieses Mächtespiel muss ausgespielt werden. Man kann theoretische Überlegungen
und Prognosen anstellen, aber es muss ausgespielt werden.
Ich glaube, hier ist der Punkt, wo ich eine Zäsur ziehen möchte.
Und zwar, ich werde dich ein bisschen provozieren jetzt. Ich habe es auch schon
mal irgendwo angedeutet.
Also Niklas Luhmann schreibt seine Systemtheorie zu einer Zeit,
als die Abläufe wunderbar funktionieren.
Da ist alte Bundesrepublik und es ist am Ende wurscht.
Der eine Helmut oder der andere Helmut aus der anderen Partei regiert.
Es gibt keinen fundamentalen Unterschied.
Es gibt keine Disruption dadurch.
Womit ich nicht sagen will, Helmut Schmidt und Helmut Kohl sind gleich,
aber ähnlich. Im Modus vivendi.
Hier aber, wenn wir jetzt über diesen neu auftretenden Nationalstaat reden,
der sagt, ab sofort nicht mehr mit China oder ab sofort dies,
ab sofort das, dann sind wir in einem Modus des Ausnahmezustands.
Und dann funktioniert auch der normale Restaurantbetrieb, sagen wir,
nicht mehr. Und ich glaube, an diesem Punkt sind wir zunehmend,
nicht bei allen Sachen, aber zunehmend.
Und da ist dann doch derjenige der Souverän, der darüber entscheidet,
über diesen Ausnahmezustand.
Und das kann nur der Mächtigste sein und das ist immer der Gewählte oder der Machthaber.
Das haben die Fürsten damals auch gedacht, bevor sie gesehen haben,
wie sie ökonomisch den Fokus ausgeliefert sind.
Aber da ist ja jetzt.
Da wurde ein ganzer Kaiser einfach ausradiert.
Aber die ökonomische Macht ist ja jetzt, also Trump hat ja mehr ökonomische
Macht als Elon Musk. Trump hat derzeit die Macht.
Aber mit dem Dollar als Weltwährung im Rücken kann natürlich Trump ganz anders
agieren, als jetzt Elon Musk, der am Ende doch noch auf den Pfennig gucken muss.
Ja, ich will erstmal sagen, ganz selbstbewusst, die Diskussion,
wie wir sie jetzt führen, das wird nämlich klar erkennbar sagen,
wir wissen gerade nicht weiter, bedeutet, das ist der eigentliche Modus,
in dem auch die Welt operiert.
Die Nachrichten abends gaukeln uns ganz anderes vor.
Der DAX hat sich bewegt, weil der Ölkurs, irgendwas ist in Amerika,
weil China und so weiter, also da werden so Kausalketten gemacht,
die nicht existieren. Ja.
Und zu dieser Primatgeschichte aus einer, also wir können das Primat immer beobachten,
aber die Beobachtung ist immer an eine Perspektive, an einen Beobachtungspunkt geknüpft.
Und von da aus sieht einfach jeder ein anderes Primat.
Der eine hat mehr eine theoretische Vorstellung, der andere hat Erfahrung aus
dem Krieg, der andere hat zivilisatorische, keine Ahnung, Gremienentscheidungen und weiß.
Aber ich will darauf hinweisen, wenn das alles nicht aufzulösen ist,
ist entscheidend, wer die größte Wumme in der Hand hat.
Was in Deutschland zum Beispiel bedeutet, wir schützen gerade oder wir versuchen
jetzt als letzten Bundestagsakt, bevor dann der neue Gewählte kommt,
das Bundesverfassungsgericht zu schützen.
Wieso? Das Bundesverfassungsgericht kann einfach nur Entscheidungen fällen,
hat aber selber keine Polizei, um sie durchzusetzen.
Warum ist also wichtig, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt?
Trumps Macht, die du gerade dargestellt hast.
Und die ich nachher auch nochmal betone. Hängt davon ab gerade,
dass ihm der Supreme Court diese Macht erteilt hat.
Nur der Supreme Court kann sich auch nicht durchsetzen. Der ist einfach darauf
angewiesen, dass halt ein pfadabhängiges, institutionelles, historisches Denken
einfach sagt, ah ja, Präsident Trump hat das gesagt, also machen wir es jetzt mal.
Wir wissen aber trotzdem nicht, was passiert, wenn Gavin Newsom entscheidet,
alle politischen Programme von Bundesebene, die ausfallen, ersetze ich durch Landeslinien.
Dafür brauche ich mehr Personal, ich brauche also mehr eigene neue Steuern und
dann zehn Jahre später stellt man fest, die sechstgrößte Volkswirtschaft der
Welt, Kalifornien, ist jetzt tatsächlich eigenständig geworden.
Sie braucht einfach nicht mehr Washington. So.
Oder eben Mississippi. Die Leute dort sind so verblendet und arm und wissen
nicht weiter und so von der Ökonomie abgekoppelt, dass sich jeder einfach nur
noch eine Waffe kauft und danach lebt man halt von Plünderung.
Da zieht man wie so eine Ritterschaft durch den Staat und hofft,
dass noch nicht drei andere Ritter schon in dieses Haus eingefallen sind.
Wir wissen einfach nicht, wohin es führt. Also es ist sozusagen alles möglich.
Ein bisschen muss man jetzt einfach Geschichte abwarten.
Aber, da wir eine geschriebene Geschichte haben, will ich nochmal einen,
Fokus auf dieses Merkel-Buch legen, wie jetzt eine Geschichte zu interpretieren
ist, was man sehen kann, wenn man nicht einfach nur, was hat Merkel da reingeschrieben,
sondern wenn man jetzt mal so ein bisschen den eigenen roten Faden,
die eigene Intelligenz da gewähren lässt.
Also, Tsipras wird gewählt. Das Volk in Griechenland sagte schon bei einer demokratischen
Wahl, diesen Troika-Kurs lehnen wir ab, wir wollen jetzt hier so eine Linke
und so weiter und Varoufakis, aber sie sind an den Euro gebunden,
unterworfen, Also einer ökonomischen Mehrheitsentscheidung, die nicht ihre eigene ist.
Und Tsipras sitzt am Tisch und Merkel beschreibt dann, wie sie sich wundert,
der sagt ja gar nichts mehr.
Wir verhandeln doch hier über das Schicksal Griechenlands und der Tsipras sitzt
als Regierungschef und Vertreter dieser Menschen da und schweigt einfach.
Dann entwickeln sie so einen tollen Plan. Die ZB sagt irgendwie,
ja, wir können das dann hier kaufen, keine Ahnung, das irgendwie stützen, whatever it takes.
Kennen wir ja soweit mit Draghi da in dieser Londoner Konferenz.
Tsipras fährt nach Hause und es gibt ein Telefonat mit Merkel.
Sie beschreibt es in dem Buch als das für sie aufrüttelndste,
schockierendste Telefonat, das sie je geführt hat.
Denn sie glaubt, sie hätte bei dem Gipfel ein super Programm entwickelt,
um Griechenland jetzt endgültig zu retten.
Sie fragt Tsipras, was hältst du von dem Plan? Er sagt, ich habe dazu keine Meinung.
Ich kann dir nur sagen, wir machen dazu einen Volksentscheid.
Wir sagen dem Volk, was Sache ist.
Und dann fragt ihn Merkel, und das ist das, was für sie das Telefonat so besonders
macht, was wirst du denn dem Volk empfehlen, wie sie abstimmen sollen?
Und sie im Hinterkopf, wir haben den geilsten Plan in der besten Gipfelsituation ever verhandelt.
Und Tsipras so, na ich werde dem Volk natürlich sagen, dass sie es ablehnen
sollen. Und sie ist völlig schockiert, außer sich.
Also nicht im Sinne von wütend, sondern sie versteht es einfach nicht. Hä?
Aber sie versteht es vermutlich bis heute nicht.
Oder? Wir haben doch in unserem 20-Sitzungs-, also 20-Regierungschefs-Saal so
eine tolle Idee entwickelt.
Und jetzt sagst du dem Volk, ich kann euch das nicht verkaufen und es ist auch
falsch, dass wir das machen.
Bitte stimmt dagegen. Wir wissen nicht genau, was danach passiert.
Austritt Griechenlands aus dem Euro, aus der EU, was auch immer.
So, also das ist Punkt 1, Euro-Krise. Mit diesen Szenen, mit dieser Szene.
Was für mich wieder bedeutet, Philippa Siegel-Glöckner, dieses Buch,
wo sie beschreibt, Da sitzen einfach Leute in einem Raum und entscheiden irgendwas.
Die Nacht war lang, einer hatte eine Idee, alle sagen ja, alle fahren nach Hause, Punkt.
Diese Entkopplung von diesem politischen Primat mit der tatsächlichen ökonomischen
Entwicklung inklusive dieses Diktums, Merkel sagt noch, das ist alternativlos.
Ist ein großer Fehler. Merkel weist dann selbst in dem Buch darauf hin,
diese Ansage zu sagen, das ist alternativlos, hat wahrscheinlich der AfD den Namen gegeben.
So, wir haben also diese Euro-Krise. Danach Ukraine 2014 oder währenddessen,
aber diese Nachwirkungen.
So, und dann kommt Migration 2015 und dann kommt plötzlich die Pandemie.
Und Merkel beschreibt diese große, große Herausforderung, gegen einen Feind
zu kämpfen, den man nicht kennt, den man nicht sieht, von dem man keine Ahnung
hat, Man hört irgendeinen Drosten-Podcast und wird darüber informiert.
Irgendwelche Leute lädt sie sich so ein und macht so 1 zu 1 Gespräche eine halbe
Stunde lang. Ah ja, jetzt habe ich es irgendwie verstanden.
Sie betont noch, wie sie in der Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sitzt und sagt,
ich als Naturwissenschaftlerin, als Physikerin wusste, was eine exponentielle
Entwicklung ist, aber alle anderen Leute im Raum nicht und das hat mich,
deswegen kamen wir nicht weiter.
So, man kämpft also plötzlich im eigenen Land gegen einen Feind, den man nicht sieht.
Und jetzt müssen wir, und das muss man jetzt aus diesem Buch herauslesen,
zurückbinden an die Euro-Krise.
Den Griechen wurde gesagt, ihr habt einen Feind, den ihr nicht seht.
Ihr seid hier eine Realität ausgeliefert, die ihr nicht versteht.
Aber ihr müsst jetzt akzeptieren, dass wir alles, was euch wichtig ist,
verkaufen, dass eure Kindersterblichkeit Faktor 3 steigt und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt, die Euro-Krise für Griechenland und die Pandemie für uns ist so ungefähr dasselbe.
Und das während der Euro-Krise, als Merkel meinte, das ist völlig alternativlos.
Die Troika hat gesagt, ihr müsst alle Häfen verkaufen und alle Kindergarten schließen.
Das müsst ihr jetzt machen. Es gibt keine Alternative.
Und die Deutschen noch so, ja klar, also diese faulen Griechen und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann zehn Jahre später kommt das sozusagen, oder fünf Jahre später,
kommt das sozusagen im Hauruck-Verfahren zurück und diese Alternativlosigkeit
hat schon eine politische Entsprechung mit der Alternative für Deutschland, die dann sagt,
also das, was mit Griechenland damals gemacht wurde, akzeptieren wir hier nicht.
Ein unsichtbarer Feind, seid ihr bescheuert, wir wollen hier Alternativen.
Und die Politik sagt wieder, es gibt keine Alternativen. Ihr müsst jetzt Lockdown
machen, bleibt zu Hause, lasst eure Kinder verelenden und so weiter und so fort.
Dieser Bogen aus der Euro-Krise zur Pandemie mit diesen Umwegen Migration,
da hat man noch so ein Rendezvous mit der Realität oder mit der Globalisierung,
wie Schäuble damals sagte, das steckt in diesem Buch drin und das muss man rauslesen.
Und wenn noch ein Journalist mir irgendwie sagt, ja, da hat sie aber das vergessen
zu schreiben und da hat sie aber keinen Fehler eingestanden oder was auch immer.
Nein, es geht jetzt hier um die Regierungszeit.
Die große Amtszeit. Man muss was damit machen.
Und das hilft dann auch gar nicht, wenn das nochmal so in einem Gespräch eingeordnet ist.
Also das ist ja auch ein Witz, dass sie jetzt mit Anne Will dort sitzt.
Anne Will hat ja, du erinnerst dich, damals noch dieses Merkel-Interview gemacht,
als wir in den weiß ich nicht wie vielten Lockdown sind. Und das war ja eigentlich
so ein Blankoscheck, den Anne Will dann Angela Merkel ausgestellt hat.
Mach was immer du willst.
Komischerweise sind noch ein paar Ministerpräsidenten gegen dich, aber alles ist richtig.
Also das waren ja so Interviews, bei denen man sagen würde, das ist so Kuschelpodcast.
Diese Journalisten, die jetzt dieses Merkel-Buch lesen und besprechen,
kommen mir alle vor wie damals LeFloid, die einfach mit Merkel ein Gespräch
führen, dann sagt Merkel so eine Minute lang was und er sagt,
ach ja, jetzt habe ich es verstanden und so.
Ja, also so völlig, wir sind hier ausgeliefert.
Das ist auch die Sache mit der Ukraine, das kriegen sie irgendwie nicht zusammen.
Da wäre es eigentlich wirklich mal interessant, auf diese Merkel-Position einzugehen.
Aber das interessiert nicht. Aber naja gut, das ist ja sowieso auch so erstaunlich,
wie das Erbe von Gerhard Schröder rezipiert wird.
Also im Prinzip ist ja der Tenor der deutschen Journalisten,
Gerhard Schröder war ein toller Kanzler, hat so ganz wichtige Reformen gemacht
wie die Agenda 2010, nur leider Putin-Freund und Gazprom.
Aber wäre das nicht, wäre Gerhard Schröder toll.
Und da kann man schon sehen, wie schief gewickelt da viele sind.
Ist ja eigentlich aufgefallen, dass ich jetzt Verteidigungsminister geworden bin.
Nein.
Denn, du hast es doch sicherlich mitbekommen, es werden Ausgehuniformen angeschafft.
In Gold?
In Höhe von vielleicht, in Höhe von über 800 Millionen Euro.
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Und dann hatte Carlo Massala ausgerechnet, das sind dann für 180.000 Soldaten
etwa so 4.500 Euro gibt man aus.
Da würde ich sagen, da sind wir ja schon in so einer Liga von Brioni,
aber das ist auch genau meine Politik, zu sagen, lass die Panzer sein,
leg die Gewehre nieder, wir kleiden uns, das ist einfach mal schön.
Ja, es ist in den Medien, der Krieg findet in den Medien statt,
wir müssen gut aussehen.
Das finde ich gut. Wir sprechen kurz über den Krieg, hören aus einer Sendung
des ORF Oberst Reisner, der jetzt gefragt wird von einem Moderator.
Der Politikwissenschaftler Carlo Massala hat zu dieser Situation auch gesagt,
es ist legitim die Frage zu stellen, ob das dann nicht bereits eine Art Dritter Weltkrieg ist.
Denn die Nordkoreaner jetzt am Schlachtfeld, ein asiatischer Staat,
also der in Europa Krieg.
Wir wissen schon lange eben, dass China mitmischt, auch Russland eben hilft,
die USA mischen mit, die ganzen europäischen Staaten, auch der Iran und,
und, und. Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, er hat ja im Prinzip hier auch den Papst zitiert, der schon vor Monaten
genau das Gleiche in den Raum gestellt hat, dass wir zunehmend in einen Weltkrieg abgleiten.
Und wenn man sich die Geschichte anschaut der letzten großen Kriege,
des Ersten und des Zweiten Weltkrieges, dann sieht man, dass am Beginn auch
nicht erkennbar war, dass es zu einem Weltkrieg gekommen ist.
Das hat der Historiker dann in der Einordnung so festgestellt.
Und Sie haben völlig recht, es ist natürlich so, dass je mehr Kriegsparteien
hier quasi tatsächlich oder Konfliktparteien hier tatsächlich im Spiel sind,
desto größer auch der Umfang dieses Konflikts.
Interessant ist aus meiner Sicht, dass wir wissen, dass die nordkoreanischen
Soldaten vermutlich in russischen Uniformen und möglicherweise nur auf russischem
Territorium eingesetzt sind, was ein Indiz dafür sein könnte,
dass man eben das doch versucht zu begrenzen.
Ja gut, aber wenn sich der Krieg dann auf diese Region verlagern,
die ukrainischen, dann ist es ja trotzdem ein Weltkrieg.
Ja, man muss sich das aber mal vorstellen, dass das jetzt so ausgesprochen wird.
Also, Zäsuren erkennen. Ich habe im Fernsehpodcast schon eine These aufgestellt,
von der mich jetzt interessiert, was du davon hältst.
Wir wissen ja, wie der letzte Weltkrieg endete.
Es wurden Atomwaffen abgeworfen.
Sollten wir jetzt wieder Atomwaffentests machen? Russland, Europa,
Amerika, zeigt mal, was es gibt, um dann eine mediale Debatte zu drehen.
Aber ich traue den Journalisten da nicht.
Also die würden auf dem Aurora-Atoll eine Atomwaffe sehen.
Ja und dann würden die sagen, ach das ist ja super, warum werfen wir die eigentlich nicht auf Moskau?
Das ist glaube ich die Reaktion der meisten Journalisten.
Wenn wir nur noch alles normalisieren, sollten wir das nicht machen.
Ja, wir normalisieren alles. Mir ist es auch nicht begreiflich,
also dass jetzt hier Oberst Reisner, das sagt, der im Übrigen im Gegensatz zu
den meisten Militärexperten mit seinen Einschätzungen immer richtig lag und
der das jetzt hier noch einmal so deutlich sagt.
Aber da keine Debatte ist, sondern wir haben die Debatte jetzt gehabt, Scholz oder Pistorius.
Die Journalisten haben sich in Pistorius verliebt, weil sie in ihm den starken
Mann sehen, der mehr eskalieren will.
Während Scholz immer noch als der so schlimm Zögerliche dargestellt wird,
als sei Scholz einfach nur verblendet.
Ich finde das so verrückt und dass es mittlerweile eine dissidente Position
geworden ist, den Bundeskanzler zu verteidigen und dessen Fan ich nun wirklich nicht bin an sich.
Es ist mir unbegreiflich, wie das passieren kann.
Deswegen sage ich, man sollte wirklich diese Journalisten nicht mehr rezipieren.
Ich finde Pistorius außenpolitisch bedenklich und das sind eben Felder,
auf denen wir ihn sprechen gehört haben.
Wie er noch im April sagte, naja Trump, der ist ja noch nicht mal Kandidat der
Republikaner, da droht schon nichts.
Amerika bleibt unser größter Verbündeter, Frankreich gucken wir dann mal und so.
Gleichzeitig sagen mir die Journalisten heute, es wäre mega cool,
wenn Pistorius Kanzlerkandidat würde. Warum?
Weil das Politbarometer und der Deutschlandtrend das sagen.
Ich habe diese Clips nicht dabei, aber Pistorius Absage kam wenige Stunden bevor
das Heute-Journal und die Tagesthemen noch Umfrageergebnisse,
Demoskopie zur Frage, wäre Pistorius nicht der Bessere.
Und beide Sender haben abends noch einfach nur die Moderation umgeschrieben,
also wenn Pistorius antreten würde, wäre er und so weiter beliebter.
Was ich schon mal für grotesk halte, ja. Also es heißt Kill your Darlings.
Wenn Pistorius zurückgezogen hat, kann man die Demoskopie nicht mehr zeigen,
weil was wäre, wenn politische Berichterstattung ist? Ja, völlig absurd.
Liebe Journalisten, macht sowas nicht. Zweitens, Pistorius wäre,
wenn er Kanzlerkandidat der SPD wäre.
Der Kanzler einer Partei, die im Namen Sozialdemokratie trägt.
Da kann auf gar keinen Fall irgendein Journalist sagen, was alle Journalisten
gesagt haben, nämlich, wir wissen nicht genau, wie sein sozialpolitisches Programm
aussähe, das müsste er dann als Kanzlerkandidat zeigen. Das geht nicht.
Man macht in Deutschland eine Ochsentour durch die SPD mit Sozialpolitik.
Man ist vorher Sozialminister, Bürgermeister, was auch immer.
Man ist nicht einfach, ups, jetzt hat man einen Innenminister,
der sich nur um Sicherheit und Migration gekümmert hat, dann Verteidigung und
dann wird man sozialdemokratischer Kanzlerkandidat.
Da hätte ich denen gleich sagen können, euer Scholz-Zug ist noch zu untertrieben als Analogie.
Sowas scheitert auf voller Linie. Und ich verstehe nicht, wie die Scholz-Zug
aus so einer Idee kommen.
Wahl ist ja erst im Februar.
Der sozialdemokratische Kanzlerkandidat der 150 Jahre stolzen Partei der Sozialdemokratie,
dessen Jugendverband Jungsozialisten heißt, hat ja dann noch ein paar Wochen
Zeit und um es zu erklären, was sein sozialpolitisches ist.
Ist uns aber auch eigentlich egal. Wir wollen einfach drei Kandidaten haben,
die Taurus liefern wollen.
Ja, das ist doch absurd. Dieser Journalismus ist absurd. Und ich bin,
ich kann nicht so weit sagen, schafft es ab, aber ich fürchte,
da jetzt droht, dass er abgeschafft wird.
Wir haben die ersten Staatskanzleien mit BSW-Beteiligung und so weiter und so fort.
Wir haben pending Bundesverfassungsgerichts Überprüfungen der KF-Entscheidung
und so weiter und so fort.
Es könnte durchaus sein, dass schon nächstes Jahr keine dritten Programme mehr
da sind für eine Weihnachtsansprache des Bundeskanzlers. Nächstes Jahr.
Das werde ich dann betrauern. Aber es wird so viel Mühe kosten,
den Leuten noch zu erklären, warum es falsch ist, diesen öffentlich-rechtlichen Apparat abzuschaffen.
Diese Kraft wird niemand aufbringen können durch so einen Firlefanz.
Ja, ja, also mir fällt es auch sehr, sehr schwer an.
Also ich bin, was das angeht, wirklich diese SPD-Kanzlerfrage gerade,
gerade auch, weil ich ja selber in so Fernsehsendungen bei Harder Buffair war
und so weiter, das ist schockierend zu sehen. Schockierend.
Wir hören nochmal Oberst Reisner.
Hier gibt es übrigens auch interessante Analogien zum Koreakrieg in den 50er
Jahren, wo man ja auch weiß, dass auf Seiten der Koreaner zum Beispiel sowjetische,
aber auch chinesische Truppen gekämpft haben, aber getan, sodass es nicht zu
100 Prozent offensichtlich wird.
Kann also sein, dass es auch hier der Versuch da ist. Aber sie haben völlig
klar, auch in der Bewertung dargestellt, dass wir also zunehmend einen Konflikt
sehen zwischen dem globalen Süden und dem globalen Norden mit unterschiedlichen Playern.
Und es drängt sich hier tatsächlich die Bewertung auf, dass wir immer mehr uns
in einen Weltkrieg bewegen.
Und dieser Weltkrieg ist nicht zu gewinnen.
Das muss man nochmal ganz deutlich sagen. Es ist nicht so, dass man sagt,
da müssen wir mal ein halbes Jahr die Zelle zusammenbeißen und dann wird es schon gehen. Nein.
Aber ich finde es sehr gut, wie er hier weiß. Er spricht für ein allgemeines
Publikum, kein militärisches.
Und es droht ein Konflikt zwischen globalem Süden und globalem Norden.
Also bitte, es droht ein Konflikt. Das ist wie, die Kinder sind von Armut bedroht,
während sie betroffen sind.
Also wir haben doch jetzt mehrere G20-Meetings hier, Dings-Meeting da, Weltklimakonferenz.
Es droht kein Konflikt globaler Süden gegen globalen Norden,
sondern der ist wirklich voll da.
Wir hören jetzt Friedrich Merz im Bundestag.
Zu sagen, dass wir nicht länger akzeptieren, dass er zivile Infrastruktur,
Krankenhäuser, Kindergärten, alle zivile Infrastruktur dieses Landes wahllos bombardiert.
Und wenn er das fortsetzt, in großer Übereinstimmung in Europa entschieden wird,
dass die Reichweitenbegrenzung für die Waffen, die die Ukraine hat, jetzt aufgehoben wird.
Herr Bundeskanzler, Sie sind auch persönlich mit Ihrer Haltung dafür verantwortlich,
dass die Ukraine gegen Putin mit einer Hand auf dem Rücken kämpfen muss.
Das geht so nicht weiter. Und wenn Putin das nicht akzeptiert,
dann muss der nächste Schritt erfolgen und ihm gesagt werden,
wenn er nicht innerhalb von 24 Stunden aufhört, die Zivilbevölkerung in der
Ukraine zu bombardieren,
dann müssen aus der Bundesrepublik Deutschland auch Taurus-Marschflugkörper
geliefert werden, um die Nachschubwege zu zerstören, die dieses Regime nutzt,
um die Zivilbevölkerung in der Ukraine zu beschädigen.
Und zu bombardieren.
Kann man schon mal hören, worauf man sich einstellen kann, wenn Mehrheitskanzler ist?
Nein, glaube ich nicht. Also diese Haltung, die er jetzt hat,
ist selbst nach zwei Jahren Medienbombardement der Bevölkerung nicht mehrheitstauglich.
Es ist völlig unaligned mit der amerikanischen Politik ab Januar. Und es ist auch...
Weiter zu verargumentieren, außer in so einer gerufenen Wortmeldung ins Plenum des Bundestages.
Aber wie erklärst du dir dann Habeck?
Ich sehe jeden Menschen, der sagt, ich kann das nicht verantworten,
ich bin nicht dabei, das sind Entscheidungen, die mich überfordern.
Also als Minister oder als Mitglied der Bundesregierung kann man sich so nicht daraus reden.
Man wird dadurch nicht weniger schuldig oder ist in der Verantwortung,
denn dann sterben auch Menschen. Insofern, das ist eine ganz schlimme und fürchterliche Situation.
Sie braucht Besonnenheit, sie braucht einen kühlen Kopf.
Wir sind alle per Amtseid dem Wohle des deutschen Volkes verpflichtet.
Alle Entscheidungen müssen sich von der Sicherheit und dem Frieden für Deutschland ableiten.
Aber sie würden trotzdem Taurus liefern. Ja, aus den genannten Gründen.
Also wir hören jetzt gerade, er sei dem deutschen Volk verpflichtet und der Sicherheit.
Wir hören Oberst Reisner, der sagt mit dem Papst zusammen, dass wir in einen
dritten Weltkrieg schlittern.
Dieser Weltkrieg wäre ja eine Gefahr für die Sicherheit Deutschlands,
würde ich ja mal behaupten. Also kann man doch nicht einfach da sitzen und sagen,
ja und deswegen würde man es liefern.
Jetzt hat man also Merz und Habeck, die in dieser Weise eskalieren.
Ich habe mittlerweile den Verdacht, dass Scholz sehr darum weiß,
wie gefährlich eine Koalition aus Schwarz-Grün sein wird, was die Eskalationsdynamik anbelangt.
Und ich habe mittlerweile sogar den Verdacht, dass diese Idee von Scholz,
dass wir erst im März wählen, was er jetzt vorgezogen ist aufgrund dieses ganzen
Pomboriums, den die Union veranstaltet haben, auch viele Journalisten,
dass wirklich diese Idee von Scholz war, wenn ich noch so ein paar Wochen mehr
habe und Trump in der Zeit im Arzt ist, dass sich möglicherweise da etwas so
tut, dass diese Eskalation gar nicht mehr stattfinden kann, weil sie nicht mehr stattfinden braucht.
Ich glaube, dass Scholz wirklich hier Tage, Wochen gewinnen wollte.
Kann sein. Und er hat sie ja auch gewonnen. Den Popanz, warum man jetzt unbedingt
zu Weihnachten Wahlkampf braucht, hat ja niemand verstanden.
Warum die christliche Union das forciert hat, völlig unklar.
Ein Wort zu Habeck. Wir haben ja schon über Habeck gesprochen.
Ich habe im Fernsehpodcast schon zwei Stunden über Habeck. Ich kann das alles
nicht mehr ertragen. Nur ein Punkt.
Mach uns das doch mal ein bisschen deutlich, damit wir das hier verstehen.
Also Zäsuren erkennen ist ja der Modus.
Nicht am Küchentisch Platz nehmen?
Ja, also Küchentisch. Egal, was du mir jetzt hinwirfst, ich werde alles in Grund
und Boden haben. Diese Küchentisch-Sache.
Wenn Robert Habeck glaubt, er bräuchte nochmal eine im Gespräch vermittelte
Aufklärung, weil die Politik nicht Bescheid weiß, wie der Stand der Dinge ist,
sondern es muss ihm nochmal anhand eines Einzelfalls illustriert werden,
dann ist alles verloren.
Hallo, ich bin Erzieherin und wissen Sie, ich verdiene gar nicht so viel Geld.
Völlig zu Recht, dir eine mediale Bühne zu geben.
Ja, das ist okay.
Für Einzelgeschichten. Also ich habe ja auch eine Theorie, die wie folgt laut,
die werde ich im Buch, habe ich sie ausführlich ausgebreitet,
aber es gibt keine mütterlichen Instinkte.
Wir haben ja den Text gelesen von der Conner Boy aus der New York Times,
die haben ja den Müttern ins Gehirn geschaut und gesagt, drei Monate nach der
Geburt sind die Hormone verflogen, wir sehen keine Veränderung.
Was bedeutet die Zuwendung zu einem Kind, von der wir immer sagen,
das ist die biologische Geburtenfolge, das ist Blut dicker als Wasser, was auch immer.
Nein, Menschen, die sich um Menschen kümmern, verfestigen dieses Band.
Das ist ein reiner sozialer Akt, der biologisch keine Entsprechung hat.
Wir können uns um alle kümmern. Das Wichtige ist nur, wir müssen viel Zeit miteinander verbringen.
Was für mich bedeutet, umso mehr über soziale Einzelstextale gesprochen wird,
umso mehr wendet sich die Bevölkerung und die Politik dem zu.
Also jede einzelne Wortmeldung, Talkshow, Parlamentsdebatte zu sozialen Fragen
und nicht zu militärischen verwandelt die Welt oder unsere Gesellschaft ein
bisschen mehr in eine soziale statt militärische Gesellschaft.
Was bedeutet, Habeck weiß es nicht, weil er wirklich doof ist,
ich erkläre gleich, warum er doof ist, aber das ist gut.
Oh, nicht, dass du jetzt gleich noch eine Anzeige bekommst.
Ja, genau, genau, genau.
Da sprechen wir heute auch noch drüber.
Ja. Nein, Habeck ist nicht doof, aber wie er sich verhält, ist doof.
Und ich möchte es an einem Beispiel machen. Wir haben das schon thematisiert,
ich will es nur immer wieder betonen.
Der Kanzler geht an die Weltöffentlichkeit, dieser Text wurde überall reportiert,
auch in Indien, auch in China, in Amerika sowieso.
Und sagt, ich zerbreche meine Regierung, um Schaden vom Volk abzuwenden,
entlasse ich Christian Lindner.
Und alles, was ich mitkriege von diesem Volk, und ich hänge in 37 Chatgruppen,
ist, das war richtig, das war gut, das war wichtig, das war überfällig.
Robert Habeck geht vor die Fernsehkamera und sagt, das hat sich heute falsch angefühlt.
Und dieser Moment zeigt für mich, Habeck ist nicht auf Augenhöhe mit dem Moment.
Er verpasst den Augenblick, er versteht die Zäsure nicht.
Noch Wochen später, heute immer noch, erklärt er der deutschen Bevölkerung,
richtig wäre gewesen, mit Lindner die Scheißkoalition weiterzuführen,
mich weiter demütigen zu lassen, die Schuldenbremse weitergewähren zu lassen,
hier nichts geschehen zu lassen, Hauptsache die Ampel hält durch.
Dass er jetzt einen Wahlkampf macht, indem er zum Küchentisch von Erziehern
geht, ist leider nur Plan B.
Und das ist eine total bescheuerte Denkweise, Ansage und Wahlkampfstrategie.
Die halte ich für so falsch, dass ich, weil du hast ja diesen Text von,
wie heißt sie, Lina und so weiter, der läuft ja auf diese Pointe hinaus.
Habeck tut es nicht für sich, er tut es für Merz.
Ach, von Laura Evert.
Laura Evert. Und das ist so wahr Und so wichtig, dass ich sage,
diese Grünen sind gerade für nichts zu gebrauchen.
Ich werde nachher die Alternative nennen. Es gibt ja eine, nämlich die Linkspartei.
Lauter junge Frauen U40, die auf der Bühne stehen und sagen,
solange wir in Deutschland Milliardäre haben, sind die politischen Programme
eigentlich egal. Halte ich für einen recht radikalen Satz, aber es ist der absolut
wahre, jetzt auszusprechende Gedanke, dem wir politisch folgen sollten.
So, es sind die ökonomischen Verwerfungen, die zu politischen Teilnahmslosigkeiten
und Desinteressen führen.
So, und das, was Habeck gerade veranstaltet, halte ich für so falsch, verfehlt.
Und wirklich nicht produktiv, was die nächste praktische Ausführung einer Bundesregierung angeht.
Nämlich eine schwarz-grüne, in der die Grünen vorher schon sagen,
dass sie alles erdulden, selbst in den Christian-Lindner-artigen Finanzminister,
dann halt von Seiten der CDU.
Die Hauptsache, es zerbricht nicht vorher, weil das würde sich falsch anfühlen. Das geht nicht.
Ja, das ist, wenn man nur darüber nachdenkt, dass wir alle an einem Tisch zusammenkommen.
Und es gibt gar keine Interessengegensätze.
Ich sitze nicht im gleichen Boot mit irgendwelchen Milliardären,
mit irgendwelchen Märzern oder was auch immer.
Aber das sollst du. Das ist ja Habecks Idee, dass wir alle in einem Boot sitzen
und dass wir alle eigentlich das eine Interesse haben. Und das ist falsch.
Und ich habe das Vergnügen, am Wochenende einen Online-Vortrag zu halten für
junge Grüne, also für Verbliebene.
Und ich kann hier schon mal den ersten Satz verraten. Es geht also um das Thema
Ungleichheit. Und ich werde Ihnen sagen, Ihr erster und wichtigster Gegner heißt Robert Habeck.
So werde ich einsteigen.
Sehr gut, ich sekundiere das, ich unterstütze das.
Das kann ich hier schon mal angucken. Es ist fundamental falsch, was da stattfindet.
Und wir hören jetzt nochmal unseren Bundeskanzler.
Ich habe sehr klar begründet, warum ich die Lieferung von Marschflugkörpern
Taurus, die in Deutschland eingesetzte Variante, nicht für richtig halte.
Sie würden nur eingesetzt werden können. Auch das muss gesagt werden,
wenn man sich mit der Zielsteuerung auch mitverantwortlich führt.
Das ist aber etwas, was ich nicht verantworten kann und auch nicht will.
Und gleichzeitig ist es so, dass wir auch klare Vorstellungen haben darüber,
dass die von uns bisher gelieferten starken Waffen, die wir dort zur Verfügung
stellen, die Artillerie, die Weidreich, die Raketenwerfer,
eben nicht eingesetzt werden können, um tief in das russische Hinterland hinein zu wirken.
Wir haben, das wissen Sie, eine Ausnahme gemacht in Bezug auf die Verteidigung von Schakif.
Das war richtig, weil unmittelbar hinter Grenzen gewissermaßen die Angriffe
gestartet sind und das war so dicht an der Stadt, dass es notwendig war,
das möglich zu machen, sich da verteidigen zu können.
Aber das ändert nichts an den Grundprinzipien, die mir wichtig sind und die
ich nicht einfach nur so formuliert habe, sondern die mein Handeln leiten.
Ja, er formuliert es nicht nur so, sondern er hat eine ganz klare Linie und
ich finde, die kann man auch erkennen.
Bei aller Kritik, die man am Kanzler sonst artikulieren kann,
es gibt dort eine klare Linie.
Naja, ich meine, das Gegenprogramm von Robin Alexander als Kommentator ist,
wir hören hier einen Kanzler im Wahlkampf, der dann irgendwie so Sprüche sagt
wie, haben sie die neue russische Rakete gesehen?
Furchtbar, furchtbar. Und er sagt, ja, der möchte gerne das Wort furchtbar unterbringen,
um den Leuten Angst zu machen.
Fürchtet euch nicht, ich als Kanzler kann euch und so weiter.
Und der Merz hat ja nicht mal Regierungserfahrung. Und da kann man halt wenig
dagegen sagen, nur die große Linie wird halt trotzdem deutlich.
Trotz Wahlkampf wird einfach deutlich, was Scholz hier macht.
Wir sollten jetzt ein bisschen doch über Podcast und Trump und all das sprechen, denke ich.
Aber wir nähern uns dem langsam, wenn du vorschlägst, ist das Thema Trump und
die Podcasts erst Punkt 6.
Und wir gucken aber nur wenige Clips, denn wir wollen uns nicht zu lange an
Trump aufhalten, denn mit Trump haben wir noch genug zu tun.
Ja, ich habe auch Clips dabei, aber da geht es mehr um die kleine Medienrevolution,
die stattgefunden hat und auch nochmal über die Manosphäre, also die Welt,
in der die Männer zu Hause sind im Internet.
Ah ja, die Männer. Lass mich einen kleinen Brückenschlag machen.
Merkel hat nun gesagt, Männer, Ausrufezeichen. Mein erster Gedanke war Männer.
Jetzt können wir ja dieser Wortklauberei von Pörksen oder wer auch immer folgen
und sagen, nicht Männer, sondern Männlichkeit.
Und du hast ja vorhin weibliche Namen genannt, Meloni, ich würde sagen Ursula von der Leyen.
Wir hatten ja mal andere, Regine Hildebrandt zum Beispiel, jetzt seit 25 Jahren
tot oder so. Ich möchte folgendes Bild aufmachen, um auch so ein bisschen mir
mit Teilen des Publikums es zu verderben.
Aber es gibt glaube ich etwas anzumerken, was wirklich wichtig ist und ich werde
es nachher bei der Nennung der linken Namen nochmal intensivieren.
Vielleicht kann man nicht sagen Männer, Ausrufezeichen, aber Männlichkeit schon.
Denn wenn wir ein Politiksystem haben, das pfadabhängig, Ochsentour,
europäische Parteien, Tradition, was auch immer, so funktioniert,
wie es funktioniert, bedeutet das,
auch die Frauen, die es in diesem Politiksystem geschafft haben,
sind eigentlich männliche Politiker.
Warum?
Weil da Durchsetzungsvermögen, Kleidungsstil, schon allein die Ansage an die
CSUler, die CSUlerinnen. Ich habe jetzt mit Dorothee Bär zu tun gehabt, also im Fernsehen nur.
Für diese Frauengeneration gab es damals nur eine einzige Ansage von ihren Förderinnen und Fördern.
Wenn sie in den Ortsverband gehen, melden sie sich immer.
Auch wenn sie nichts zu sagen haben, machen sie sich präsent,
seien sie vor Ort, bringen sie sich ein.
Es ist nicht wichtig, was sie sagen, es ist nur wichtig, dass alle sehen,
sie können zu allem was sagen.
Ich kenne diese Argumentation.
Diese Art von Männlichkeit, also sich mächtig in eine Interaktion und ich will hier...
Röttger Brechmann.
Ja, das Diktum. Vielleicht ist es nur eine spezifische Art, also klar,
es ist nur so eine spezifische Art von Christian Lindner, Merz,
Männlichkeit, die einen so hinauskatapultiert.
Also eine Ortsverbandsgremiensitzung so zu managen, so zu manifestieren,
dass man danach auf großer Bühne mit demselben Vorgang. Verhalten plötzlich
so Trump-artig und so, ja.
Das ist nicht die vollständige Männlichkeit, aber es ist doch ein sehr männlicher Zug.
Warum soll das ein männlicher Zug sein?
Weil Frauen einfach ihr Leben anders führen. Deswegen finden sie ja diesen Sphären so wenig statt.
Geführt haben, aber das ändert sich ja radikal. Und wir haben es ja zum Beispiel
im Showbusiness schon viel länger so sehen können,
dass Frauen sich, ja du würdest jetzt sagen männlich halten,
aber ich würde diese Zuschreibung einfach loslösen vom Geschlecht,
weil wir damit nicht weiterkommen.
Also generell gilt, wenn man auf einer Bühne gesehen werden will,
Muss man das Wort ergreifen.
Wenn man dort sitzt und nicht spricht, dann wird man nicht beachtet.
Wenn man überhaupt auf eine Bühne hinaus will, muss man von Leuten erkannt werden,
die sagen, der Mensch muss auf eine Bühne.
Diese Eigenschaften sind aber keine männlichen Eigenschaften,
sondern das sind die performativen Akte und sagen wir,
die performativen Skills, die man mitbringen muss,
um in der Öffentlichkeit zu wirken.
Das ist aber unabhängig von dem Geschlecht so und da gibt es verschiedene Ausgestaltungen
dessen und dann gibt es natürlich ein sehr präpotentes Verhalten vielleicht bei welchen und ja,
patriarchale Strukturen haben es mit sich gebracht, dass Männer es leichter
haben, Unsinn zu reden, ohne dass sie korrigiert werden dabei,
während bei Frauen genauer hingeblickt wird. Alles zugestanden.
Ich würde nur davon abraten, jetzt auch hier noch einen Geschlechterkrieg auf
dieser Ebene anzufangen, weil am Ende es doch wichtig ist,
dass die richtigen Leute am richtigen Ort regieren.
Und es geht doch jetzt schon auch darum, dass man eine Professionalität hat.
Wir haben es immer dafür ausgesprochen, dass man eine Professionalität mitbringt.
Das heißt auch, dass man sich entsprechend anzieht. Wir hatten hier mal über
Linke gesprochen, die merkwürdig angezogen sind und da waren Männer wie Frauen mit gemeint.
Und Ähnliches ist doch auch bei dem Agieren auf einer Bühne.
Wenn man natürlich da sagt, ich möchte eigentlich gar nicht so gerne sprechen
und will mich nicht so hervortun, dann ist das so.
Ich sehe dein grundsätzliches Problem, das du da ansprichst,
nur das würde dich vom Geschlecht loslösen,
dass Leute, die auf Bühnen stehen und reden und dazu gehören wir ja in kleinerem
Maße auch, ohnehin einen gewissen Knacks haben,
da da ja eine gewisse Hybris mitschwingt, dass man glaubt, man sei dazu ermächtigt oder berechtigt,
Leuten etwas zu erklären, während die anderen zuhören.
Das ist generell eine komische Angelegenheit, wenn man darüber genauer mal nachdenkt.
Und man muss sicherlich auch da sich zu überwinden, dies zu tun und muss dafür bereit sein.
Wenn man nicht dafür bereit ist, dann ist man da auch nicht am richtigen Orte.
Aber da würde ich nicht sagen, da kommen wir jetzt mit diesen Kriterien männlich,
weiblich weiter, weil ich glaube auch, dass viele Frauen das überhaupt nicht
wollen, dass sie jetzt die zum Beispiel auf Bühnen gut funktionieren oder sehr taffem auftreten sind,
gleich mit Männlichkeit assoziiert werden, sondern das kann auch eine sehr, sehr weibliche.
Art sein, nur eine andere Art, weil wir können ja jetzt auch nicht in alte Geschlechtermuster
zurückfallen, wo wir die Frau eher als das behütende,
weh- und warmherzige Wesen erkennen.
Warum sollte sie das sein? Und die Dramengeschichte, die abendländische,
angefangen bei Medea und Antigone ist voll ja von Frauen, die sich nicht männlich
verhalten, aber die durchaus wissen aufzutreten und die darum wissen,
auch ihre Macht auszuspielen.
Absolut. Ich will zwei Sachen dazu sagen.
Das eine ist, ich will diesen Podcast jetzt nicht aufhalten,
obwohl dieses Thema wirklich mein neues Lieblingsthema ist.
Also ich könnte jetzt stundenlang Gegenworte finden, aber im März kommt ja mein
Buch und dann werde ich da eh tausend Gelegenheiten haben.
Zweitens, wenn die Reaktion, also deine jetzt, darauf ist, lass uns doch das
Phänomen betrachten ohne Geschlechterunterschiede, dann sag ich, no.
Von mir aus können wir über alles diskutieren, aber über eins nicht,
dass es einen Geschlechterunterschied gibt.
Nein, es gibt einen Geschlechterunterschied, nur nicht in allen Sphären.
Ich sage, es gibt einen Geschlechterunterschied, sondern in dieser Frage,
die hier gerade aufgeworfen ist, ist der Geschlechterunterschied der maßgebliche
und alles tragende, fundamentale Unterschied, der hier eine Rolle spielt.
Und es ist nicht unbedeutend, ich will es nur mal als Parallelität.
Wir haben einen Diskurs zum Klimawandel.
Bei dem wir sagen, wir haben bisher verstanden, wie Politik und Wirtschaft funktioniert,
es gibt einen Profitgedanken, es gibt Machtinteressen, wie auch immer.
Also klar holen wir die Kohle raus und 150 Jahre später stellen wir fest,
nee, auch wenn wir die Materialien, die Werkzeuge und so weiter haben,
wir bohren jetzt mal nicht nach dem Öl. Wir machen es einfach nicht.
Auch wenn da Milliarden-Business und die Ölbranche verdient irgendwie pro Stunde
zwölf Millionen Dollar und so weiter.
Wir machen es aber einfach trotzdem nicht. Also wir machen eine künstliche Restriktion.
So und jetzt haben wir ein durch und durch patriarchales, nicht nur männliches,
sondern patriarchales Wesen als neuen amerikanischen Präsidenten,
der durch ein Wort auffällt und sagt Drill Baby Drill.
So, und in diesem Maße, wie wir beim Klima gerade feststellen.
Alle Diskurserrungenschaften, die wir die letzten Jahrzehnte diskutiert haben,
spätestens seit Greta, möchte er einfach ausradieren.
Und der Schutz von Frauen lautet bei ihm, ich beschütze alle Frauen,
ob sie wollen oder nicht.
Ja, da gibt es eine ganz große Parallelität. Ja, das will ich ja nicht leugnen.
Ja, ich will es aber wie folgt jetzt sagen. Also meine rhetorische Klammer für
alle, die mit mir das diskutieren wollen, ist, Und wer meint,
der Klimaschutz erfordert Restriktionen,
wir müssen hier über Sachen, wir müssen auch auf Sachen verzichten oder eben
in technische Richtung irgendwie das Windrad und so weiter,
der muss das bei dieser Gender-Diskussion genau so akzeptieren.
Unter Vizepräsidentin Kamala Harris ist Amerika… Ja.
Deswegen sagt er nicht Männer und Frauen, sondern männlich und weiblich.
Und auch Männer können weiblich sein, sowie auch Frauen männlich sein.
Ich glaube, dass diese Kategorie einfach falsch ist. Das werde ich dir dann
zum nächsten Jahr… Also Kamala Harris, als sie Vizepräsidentin war,
hat mit beiden zusammen dafür gesorgt, dass Amerika der größte Erdgas- und Erdöl-Prosorzent ist.
Ja, weil sie in einem männlichen System Vizepräsident war. Sie hat das Amt des
Vizepräsidenten ausgefüllt.
Nein, nein, nein, also ich finde, man kann das nicht, weil das würde so suggerieren,
dass Frauen die besseren Menschen sind und das ist einfach falsch.
Naja, aber ich kann ja jetzt nicht akzeptieren zu sagen, naja,
es ist ein patriarchales System, in dem die Männer… Nein.
Die setzen Industrieinteressen durch und setzen Kapitalinteressen durch,
egal ob es ein Mann oder eine Frau ist.
Genauso wie manche Außenminister Staatsinteressen so auslegen,
wie sie es auslegen wollen und sie durchsetzen. Baerbock, die sich in jedem
zweiten Wort darauf bezieht, dass sie Mutter von zwei Kindern ist.
Macht keine feministische Außenpolitik.
Baerbock unterstützt mit den Waffenlieferungen vehement einen Krieg gegen Frauen
und Kinder in Gaza. Lass uns das wirklich abkürzen. für eine große militärische
Eskalation in der Ukraine.
Sie ist eine, die eine absolute Hardlinerin ist.
Dann muss ich jetzt anders sagen, ah okay, dann ist Olaf Scholz der mit der
weiblichen Komponente, denn der will versuchen zu deeskalieren,
während Baerbock die mit der Männchen...
Kein falscher Gedanke.
Dann kommen wir aber nicht weiter.
Kein falscher Gedanke, aber ich will es jetzt mal ganz kurz nur auf die Spitze
treiben, nur um den Denkhorizont entsprechend aufzumachen.
Wenn wir jetzt von einer weiblichen Vizeprozess Präsidentin reden,
dann ist die, sie ist eine Frau.
Aber das System ist ein männliches System. Was bedeutet, wenn wir meiner Argumentation
jetzt zu Ende denken, findet in diesem Gedenkgebäude kein Nationalstaat mehr statt.
So weit möchte ich das treiben. Aber der Nationalstaat ist das Erste.
Was da ist.
Ganz genau, er ist ja da. Und deswegen müssen wir immer...
Schlechtlichkeit keine Rolle beim Nationalstaat, sondern der Nationalstaat und
sein Interessen, der hat das gesetzt.
Der Nationalstaat ist ja da, also blenden wir seine Bedingungen aus und reden
niemals über die Bedingungen, die dazu führen, dass es ein Nationalstaat ist.
Nein, ich bin ja sehr dafür, über patriarchale Strukturen zu sprechen.
Nur können wir nicht überall jetzt die Welt in männlich-weiblich aufteilen,
wo uns das jetzt gerade passt.
Also wir sagen, die eher nicht so unsgenehme Politik, die scheint jetzt männlich
konnotiert zu sein, die eher bessere Politik ist weiblich konnotiert.
Dann kommen wir überhaupt nicht weiter. Erstmal kommen wir dann in allen Kategorien
durcheinander, weil wir nicht davon ausgehen können, dass wir jetzt immer,
also wo soll das erkenntnistheoretisch hinführen, Wenn wir jetzt sagen,
ja Meloni ist ja eigentlich wie ein Mann.
Nein, Meloni bezieht sich ständig darauf, dass sie Mutter ist.
Und deswegen ist das richtig. Alice Weidel ist eine lesbische Frau.
Ich biete dir jetzt noch einen Gedanken an. Zu Ende gedacht heißt das nicht
nur kein Nationalstaat oder was auch immer,
sondern zu Ende gedacht bedeutet das, wir brauchen adäquat, äquivalent zu dieser
materiellen Klimapolitik, um einfach den Planeten nicht zu zerstören.
Brauchen wir eine soziale Klimapolitik, die in ihrer Folge bedeutet,
es gibt keine demokratische Mehrheit dafür, das komplette politische System
zu zerstören. Das ist das Ziel.
Jetzt haben wir dieses System und wir erleben es jetzt auch in Amerika.
Und ich will nochmal betonen, diese Zäsur fällt viel krasser aus,
als wir uns heute vorstellen können.
So.
Gewiss.
Und jetzt geht es mir nicht darum zu sagen, naja, aber da haben sich ja auch
schon Frauen durchgesetzt in diesem System, wie wir es bisher haben.
Ja, genau, da haben sich Frauen durchgesetzt.
Das ist ja kein Gegenargument oder so, das ist genau der Punkt.
Auch Frauen zerstören mittlerweile diese soziale Welt. Meloni ist eine Postfaschistin.
Und die Leute wird immer so, Postfaschistin, also Faschist ist doch nur noch
so ein ästhetischer Begriff, der so angemerkt wird, um zu sagen,
da bin ich aber nicht einer Meinung oder sowas. Da würde ich sagen,
nee, das ist ein Begriff, der was bedeutet.
Und die Meloni, die zerstört da auch gerade Italien.
Ja, und ich möchte hier ganz deutlich sagen, und es gibt auch weibliche Faschistinnen.
Ja, genau.
Und die sind aber da nicht alle, die faschistisch sind, männlich.
Verstehst du? Deswegen will ich diese Kategorie nicht.
Außerdem finde ich das auch falsch, das so zu konnotieren, weil es einen Unterschied
gibt zwischen Patriarchat und Männlichkeit.
Männlichkeit meint nicht Patriarchat. Wir müssen nicht jetzt anfangen,
Männlichkeit als solches zu brandfragen.
Weshalb Patriarchat ja auch der bessere Begriff ist.
Genau und deswegen rate ich dringend davon ab, diese Unterscheidungen männlich-weiblich
jetzt bei der Bewertung von Politik zu sehen.
Es sei denn, es wird gerade eine frauenfeindliche Politik gemacht,
dann kann man die aber auch genauso nennen und das ist ja das,
was Trump dort umsetzen will.
Aber es geht eben nicht um frauenfeindliche Politik.
Ja, das ist Frauenfeindliche Politik.
Ja, aber das, worum es mir geht, wenn man da sagt, es gibt Frauenfeindliche
Politik, das ist so krass, zu kurz gedacht darum, worum es eigentlich geht.
Dass ich einfach sage...
Aber du kannst doch nicht sagen, es ist männliche Politik, weil es auch ganz andere...
Patriarchale, finde ich gut.
Ja, es ist eine patriarchale Politik, ja.
So, was ja nur bedeutet, der Podcast ist anderthalb Stunden alt,
ich hoffe, alle Hörerinnen verstehen, die Zäsur ist gigantisch.
Wir haben es mit gigantischen Zäsuren zu tun. Das Pfadabhängige Denken,
deswegen auch die Konflikte.
Ach so, so machst du das jetzt.
Ich mache genau Pfadabhängigkeit. Ja, ich will es mal, also diese Trump-Sache.
Trump wurde jetzt gewählt. Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Ich will mal zwei Sachen gegenüberstellen.
Zum einen Serdar Somuncu, der in seinem Podcast vor sich hin redet.
Ich wiederhole es nochmal, die Wahl Donald Trumps ist für mich Anlass zur Freude
und weniger Anlass zur Sorge.
Die Wahl Donald Trumps ist für mich in vielerlei Hinsicht eine Befreiung von
ganz vielen Umständen, die zuletzt selbstverständlich zu sein schienen und die
jetzt durch die Wahl von Donald Trump wieder infrage gestellt werden.
Und ich sage es nochmal, weil ich weiß, dass die Menschen unglaublich oberflächlich
zuhören. Das heißt nicht, dass ich Donald Trump gut finde, sondern ich halte
die Konsequenz dieser Entwicklung für gut und für richtig.
Ob Donald Trump ein guter Politiker ist, das weiß ich nicht,
das sei dahingestellt, aber dann müsste ich der Vollständigkeit halber auch
sagen, ich fand auch Joe Biden nicht gut und ich fand auch Barack Obama nicht
gut und ich fand auch George W.
Bush nicht gut und ich fand die letzten 47 Präsidenten der USA nicht gut.
Ja, also zwei Ideen, die ich wirklich absurd albern finde.
Zum einen, Serdar Simonshu weiß, dass er hier, dieser Podcast ist übrigens Boygroup, irgendwas.
Also man findet ihn unter Boygroup, Sermonshu Boygroup bei YouTube.
Diese Idee zu sagen, also vor Publikum, ich finde einen Präsidenten nicht gut,
ist einfach diese ästhetische Kategorie nach Herr Simonshu.
Herr Trump hat die Wahl gewonnen, wie fühlen Sie sich? Und dann macht er irgendwie
zwei Stunden Podcast zur Frage, wie er sich fühlt. Es ist völlig egal,
ob du das gut oder nicht gut findest.
Klar, wir verhalten uns alle dazu und sagen, Obama, das ist doch wie dieser
Kandidat aus West Wing, den fand ich schon im Fernsehen gut und jetzt sehe ich
ihn halt nochmal im Fernsehen. So eine war eine Serie und es ist halt Realität.
Zweitens, diese Idee von, dass Donald Trump einfach ein weiterer Präsident nach
Obama, Clinton irgendwas ist.
Ist absurd. 2024 müssen wir diesen Pfad abbrechen.
Hier wurde nicht einfach über einen nächsten Präsidenten befunden,
sondern hier wurde dieses Project 2025 vorgestellt.
Das Verfassungsgericht hat gesagt, er darf alles, auch Leute töten, auch im Inland.
Im Ausland ist das ja schon gang und gäbe, aber jetzt auch im Inland,
auch politische Gegner.
Hauptsache, es ist halt ein präsidialer Akt, also während der Amtszeit passiert.
Das ist die Kategorie, die jetzt zählt.
Die New York Times dagegen gar nicht hämisch, sondern die könnten jetzt auch
einfach da sitzen und sagen, wenn ich mir die Texte nochmal anschaue,
die ich jetzt geschrieben habe im Wahlkampf, also ich finde Trump echt nicht
gut und ich freue mich jetzt auch nicht darüber,
sondern nein, die sagen natürlich, was jetzt zu sagen ist.
Just absorbing what you were saying, Maggie, he will have wiped out any legal
repercussions for behavior that in the eyes of very well-respected prosecutors,
both locally and federally, were criminal.
He has all but defeated any form of accountability. Yes, correct.
What is the form of accountability now? The Supreme Court has ruled that a president
is immune for official acts, which may have a very broad meaning.
There's no universe in which this composition of Congress impeaches Donald Trump for anything.
Congressional oversight, particularly if Republicans take the House,
there will be no oversight, really very little oversight.
The news media, in the eyes of many Americans, is discredited.
More than half the country have tuned out the mainstream media.
We are now in little information silos.
So it's almost impossible to overstate how much Donald Trump has defeated the
system und wie hervorragend die aktuellen Komposition der System ist für Donald Trump.
Das ist sozusagen die besten Worte.
Also, im Kongress absolute Mehrheiten für Trump und er hat sie alle auf seiner
Linie. Sie wurden ja zur Hälfte auch wegen ihm überhaupt erst gewählt.
Juristisch droht ihm gar nichts, sondern ganz im Gegenteil.
Ihm wurden alle Rechte explizit vorher eingeräumt und medial schachmatt.
Also es ist völlig egal, was Journalisten jetzt noch dazu sagen.
Interessiert niemanden. Die Leute hören nicht mal zu.
In der Hinsicht ist Donald Trump nicht einfach, naja, ich mochte schon Clinton
und ich mag eigentlich gar keinen amerikanischen Präsidenten und jetzt Trump mag ich halt auch nicht.
Aber ich freue mich, dass es jemanden ärgert, dass er gewählt wurde.
Also man kann jetzt so hämisch an die Sache rangehen.
Das kann man mal für zwei Stunden klammheimlich tun, aber vielleicht nicht.
Typischerweise haben wir dafür die Opernbühne, für solche Gefühle.
Ja, ja, genau.
Das ist nicht, das Weiserhaus ist nicht der richtige Ort. Gut, jetzt,
da wir darüber diskutierten, patriarchale Politik und wohin sie führt,
nämlich dazu, dass ein Publikum mehrheitlich das politische System selbst ablehnt
und abwählt, statt einfach den nächsten Präsidenten, der das halt machen soll.
Ich will das Außenmaß nochmal beschreiben.
Donald Trump kam jetzt auf 76, irgendwas Millionen Stimmen. Das sind knapp 50 Prozent.
49,97 oder so, also nicht mal 50 Prozent.
So, 50 Prozent sind sehr viel, denn alle partikularen Interessen in einer Gesellschaft
sind Minderheitenpositionen.
Studenten, alle Studenten zusammen in Deutschland 5 Prozent.
Irgendwelche Verkäufer von irgendwas. Niemand verkauft an mehr als 50% irgendwas.
Alles ist sozusagen Minderheitenposition.
Also Trump hat jetzt gegen alles einfach Mehrheitenposition.
Gegen den kompletten akademischen Betrieb,
gegen jede Art von der Staat tritt dir auf die Füße, weil das Finanzamt irgendwas
will oder was auch immer, die Polizei will was von dir, irgendwelche Staatsanwalten,
du kommst als Migrant, du bist immer in einer Minderheitenposition. Es gibt gar keine.
Also du bist eigentlich in keiner Rolle, nicht mal Eltern.
Nicht mal 50 Prozent der Bevölkerung sind Eltern oder so. Also mit Eltern,
mit Kindern im eigenen Haus, die das also noch brauchen, irgendwelche Elternrechte.
Das heißt, Trump schwebt jetzt über allem. Er hat eine, selbst mit 49,97 Prozent
hat er eine Mehrheit, nämlich Trump-Wähler, die alle anderen partikularistischen
Interessen übertrumpft.
Wenn gleich wir nicht vergessen sollten, dass wir es ja mit einem föderalen
Staat zu tun haben, mit Bundesstaaten, die sehr viel mächtiger sind als jetzt
die Bundesländer in Deutschland.
Ja, also es kam von Julian Reichelt ein Hinweis darauf, wie 2028 die Olympischen
Spiele in Kalifornien in Los Angeles ablaufen sollten, nämlich er meinte,
der Musk wird eine Rakete bauen, mit der Trump auf den Mond geschossen wird
und dann von dort ein Football zurück auf die Erde wirft, der im Stadion landet.
Hat Julian Reichelt gesagt.
Ja, das hat Julian Reichelt so gesagt. Ich habe da nur drüber getwittert,
nö, 2028 hat sich Kalifornien unabhängig erklärt, die Olympischen Spiele haben
mit Amerika überhaupt gar nichts zu tun, weil sie einfach in der sechstgrößten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt stattfinden in Kalifornien.
So, und das ist auch ein Szenario, das wahrscheinlich sogar viel wahrscheinlicher
ist, als dass Elon Musk eine Rakete baut, mit der Donald Trump vom Mond aus
ein Football auf die Erde wirft.
Wenn ich an Donald Trumps Alter denke, würde ich ihm auch nicht eine Reise dieser Art empfehlen.
So, jetzt haben wir ja diskutiert,
Eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung lehnt dieses System ab und ich möchte es gerne
labeln als, hier ist 400 Jahre Patriarchat gescheitert.
Das wäre sozusagen meine Zäsur.
Also gescheitert in dem Sinne, dass sie aber erfolgreich sind.
Was heißt erfolgreich? Wer ist denn erfolgreich?
Ja, Trump ist ja erfolgreich. euch.
Naja, gut. Also 49,97% haben gesagt, wir wählen Trump und 51,1% der Bevölkerung
kriegt jetzt vorgesetzt, was es bedeutet, keine Mehrheit zu haben durch,
was weiß ich, Electoral College und so weiter.
Das heißt, eine Mehrheit, die Restmehrheit, die letzte Mehrheit,
die noch in diesem alten System mobilisierbar war, wir wissen ja nicht genau,
wann die nächsten Wahlen und wie das abläuft, schon die Midterm Elections sind ja sehr, mal gucken,
dieses System, was wir bisher hatten, nämlich, dass einfach Demokratie heißt
Mehrheiten auszählen und dann und so weiter.
Also in diesem System ist Donald Trump der letzte Präsident.
Es wird nicht einfach, diese Zäsur möchte ich heute behaupten und betonen,
auf die ist jetzt zu achten.
Wenn jetzt irgendwelche Journalisten und du das weiterziehen wollen, das dann einfach...
Nein, ich will nicht das weiterziehen in dem Sinne, dass ich sage, bleibt alles wie immer.
Aber was ich sagen will, ist, ich gehe davon aus, dass es wieder ordentliche
Wahlen in den USA geben wird.
Weiß ich nicht, wem der dann kandidiert. Ich will nur Nur noch gerade hinzufügen,
dass Kamala Harris zwar immer auftrat und alle möglichen beim Namen nannt,
die sie alle mit gemeint haben will,
dass sie auch gegen diese Anti-Abtreibungsbewegung der Republikaner in Reden
sich positioniert hat, dass sie aber auch nicht dafür bekannt war und auch nicht
dafür bekannt geworden ist,
eine Frauenpolitik zu machen im Hinblick auf Sozialpolitik.
Da werden wir gleich explizit zu sprechen. Vorher noch eine Etage tiefer,
was diese emergenten Verquickung angeht.
Ich habe es vorhin schon mal betont, die Amerikaner verabschieden sich jetzt
von einem politischen System, weil ihre politische Teilhabe in ihm nichts bedeutet,
als Folge einer ökonomischen gefühlten Ohnmacht.
Also wer sich ökonomisch nicht sozusagen verortet sieht, der versteht auch nicht,
warum er jetzt politischen Platz finden sollte.
Bernie Sanders hat das ausdrücklich und sehr nachvollziehbar im Podcast The
Daily betont und zwar auch im Widerspruch, sagen wir mal in Konfrontation mit
diesem Mediensystem, das vor ihm saß, um sich seine Meinung abzuholen.
Their lives because hey no change is going to come why would i want to vote
for a group of people who don't even acknowledge the reality for example you
tell me you follow these things i do we have today more income and wealth inequality
than we've ever had in the history of this country did you hear a lot of discussion on that,
We are the only major country on earth, not to guarantee health care to all
people is a human right, and the only major country not to provide paid family and medical leave.
Do you hear much discussion of that? Not in this campaign.
Not in this campaign. You got 20 million people in America today who are trying
to get by on less than 15 dollars an hour.
Did you hear any serious discussion of the need to raise the minimum wage to
a living wage? I don't think we did. I missed that one too.
So, und das ist aber genau das, was er ja hier sagt, was für die New York Times
in der Regel kein Thema ist.
Doch.
Selten. Also die New York Times, ja jetzt kommen wir nicht mit einzelnen Details,
aber die New York Times ist dafür bekannt,
dass sie immer die zentristischste Position der Demokraten annimmt und dass
da die Klassenfrage in der Regel keine Rolle spielt, es sei denn,
es ist mal jemand wie Bernie Sanders da und ermahnt sie nochmal dahin.
Kamala Harris hat sich nicht in Interviews, in Podcasts getraut,
wo diese Frage angesprochen werden könnte.
Ja, alles richtig. Die New York Times macht jeden Tag 500 Artikel.
In denen spielt es nicht über die Klassenfrage eine Rolle. Kamala Harris und
Hillary Clinton, die von der New York Times gepusht und gekrönt und verehrt wurden.
Die New York Times und Hillary Clinton und Kamala Harris interessieren sich
für die Klassenfrage noch weniger als Robert Habeck.
Ja, ja, ja, aber Vorsicht jetzt vor dieser Häme, im Sinne von die New York Times
stirbt zu Recht oder sowas.
Also, Josh Hawley, also wenn die New York Times stirbt, haben wir wirklich nur
noch die Menosphäre, wir kommen gleich auf sie zu sprechen.
Ja, ich will ja auch jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich froh bin, wenn sie stirbt,
aber ich will doch sagen, es ist doch ein fundamentaler Irrtum, dass man jetzt,
also ich verstehe gar nicht, was die New York Times könnte doch einfach mal
eine Selbstkritik üben, wir haben wieder, wie bei der Wahl von Hillary Clinton,
dasselbe Theater veranstaltet.
Also, ich will jetzt den Konflikt nicht so weit treiben.
Und wenn die in drei Jahren wieder jemanden haben, der noch von Hillary Clinton
Absolutionen erhält, dann wird die New York Times das genau so wieder machen.
Und die werden sich wundern, dass das nicht ankommt.
2016 haben alle Medien verpasst, zu sehen, was da passiert mit Trump.
Und jetzt will ich etwas sagen, nur kurz, aber auch, weil ich mich auch mit
Leuten aus dem Internet, die mir eigentlich wichtig waren, sehr über diese Frage
zerstritten habe und ich wirklich keine Lust mehr auf diese Leute habe. Ich nenne keine Namen.
Aber während die deutschen Journalisten zwar nicht so flächendeckend,
aber durchaus dieselben Fehler wie 2016 gemacht haben, trifft das auf die New York Times nicht zu.
Die New York Times hat mir die ökonomischen Unterschiede und die neue Macht
Trumps dargestellt und als, deswegen bin ich ja auch so erregt darüber, bevor es passierte.
Es ist nicht so, dass der New York Times Leser am Morgen nach der Wahl aufgewacht
ist und wie 2016 dachte, oh krass, ich bin ja gar nicht vorbereitet.
Nee, das kommt ja auch nicht.
Sondern alle waren vorbereitet. So, ich habe einen Clip gesehen von Josh Hawley.
Wir kennen ihn, einer der republikanischen Originalisten, der also wirklich
hardcore die religiöse Linie und so weiter im Kongress durchschiebt.
So, die Republikaner kümmern sich jetzt um die soziale Frage.
Und zwar in folgender Form.
Josh Hawley, also googelt es gerne mal, das ist spektakulär,
finde ich. Josh Hawley macht eine Anhörung im Kongress.
Vor ihm sitzen die Chefs von den Kreditkarten, also American Express,
Mastercard, Visa. Er fragt sie als allererstes.
Wie viel Gewinn machen sie? Und dann sagt die Visa-Frau ungefähr 50% und der
Mastercard-Typ sagt, bisschen höher als 50%. Also 50% Profit Margin auf den Umsatz.
Und dann klärt Josh Hawley mit denen im Gespräch, wo kommt dieser Umsatz und dieser Gewinn her?
Die Dispo-Kreditzinsen auf diese Konten, aus denen die die Gewinne ziehen,
liegen bei über 20%. Und dann fragt er sie, wie hoch sind denn die Schulden?
Auf die sie dann 20% als ihren Gewinn drauflegen.
Die druckst natürlich rum. Josh Hawley ist aber vorbereitet,
lässt eine Grafik reinfahren, wo ersichtlich wird, über 1 Trillion Dollar,
über eine Billion Dollar.
Was bedeutet im deutschen Verhältnis, die deutsche Volkswirtschaft setzt 4 Billionen Euro um.
Amerika natürlich ein bisschen mehr, es sind ja mehr Leute, sagen wir mal 5
mal mehr. Also ich weiß es nicht genau, aber sagen wir mal so 20 Billionen.
20 Billionen ist das BIP Amerikas.
Was bedeutet, 5% dieses BIPs,
5% der kompletten volkswirtschaftlichen Größe Amerikas läuft über,
du bist eigentlich pleite und wir ziehen dir nochmal pro Jahr 20% davon als unseren Profit raus.
Der Durchschnittsamerikaner hat 6 Kreditkarten.
Ja, die selbstzerstörerischen Kräfte in Amerika durch einfach nur irgendwelche
BWL-Profit-Kalkulationen haben jetzt dazu geführt, dass dieses,
ja die Butter ist zu teuer, deswegen wählen wir jetzt alle Trump,
zum Abriss dieses politischen Systems geführt hat, diese Verkettung.
Es ist also Thema in Sparten der New York Times und bei den Republikanern,
wenn sie Kongressanhörungen machen.
Aber bei Kamala Harris war es kein Thema.
Bei Kamala Harris war es kein Thema. Und deswegen hat sich die Wahl auch mit
ungefähr 1,4 Prozent eben verloren, was ein wirkliches Drama darstellt.
Denn diese Fragen liegen da, sie müssen besprochen werden und sie werden aber nicht besprochen.
Und jetzt macht Bernie Sanders einen ganz, ganz, ganz wichtigen Punkt, auch für Deutschland.
You know, you can't fight something with nothing. You've got to have an alternative vision.
Trump had his vision. It was incorrect. It was dishonest. It was,
in many cases, racist and sexist.
He had a vision. He had an explanation.
To my view, Democrats really did not.
So, auch liebe deutsche Wahlkämpfer, wenn ökonomische und soziale Fragen im
Raum stehen und die Regierungsparteien, und da erzähle ich jetzt Merz als Altparteien, fuck,
damit rein, weil es ist nun mal 16 Jahre Merkel und so gewesen.
Wenn diese etablierten Parteien die ökonomischen Klassenfragen und sozialen
großen Fragen ausblenden, kommt die Gegenseite mit allem durch. Mit allem.
Nicht nur mit Migration, sondern they are eating our cats and dogs.
Selbst das ist noch ein überzeugenderes Argument, als nicht über diese Klassenfragen
zu reden. Das haben wir jetzt in Amerika gesehen.
Wir haben derzeit noch keine Opposition wie Trump, die einfach alles erzählt,
nur Lügen, nur Scheiß, wo es völlig egal ist, das zu begleiten.
Das haben wir in Deutschland noch gar nicht. Aber selbst wenn wir es hätten,
käme die etablierte Parteienlandschaft damit nicht zurecht, weil SPD und Merz
auf diese Fragen keine Antwort haben.
Und die 50% Mehrheit für irgendetwas ist bei einer 20% Armutsrate einfach ein
Fingerschnips entfernt.
Und das müssen die deutschen Parteien jetzt verstehen.
Aber das ist doch meine Rede.
Das ist deine Rede, nur ich sage.
Es mag ja sein, dass die New York Times ein bisschen mehr den Fokus aufs Ökonomische
zum Teil gelegt hat, aber wenn man sieht, wie sehr Kamala Harris dann,
vor allem von Esra Klein ich habe mir diese Podcasts ja alle dazu angehört hofiert
wurde und da nicht einmal diese Frage gestellt wurde,
wie sieht es denn eigentlich mit dem ökonomischen aus,
sondern die ganze Zeit nur gesagt wurde, toll,
dieser Migrationshintergrund, sie ist eine Frau und bla bla bla,
dann ist das ein ganz großes Problem und das ist ja das, was Bernie Sanders
hier anspricht und wir haben ja auch jetzt hier in Deutschland hat man den Eindruck,
wenn man den Wahlkampf verfolgt,
das einzige, was die Deutschen umtreibt, sind Taurus-Lieferungen und zwar wird
suggeriert, dass alle eigentlich diese Lieferungen wollen, was nicht stimmt,
wie wir aus Umfragen wissen.
Was wäre eigentlich das große Thema, Tom Krebs hat es ja aufgeschrieben in dem
Buch Fehldiagnose, das sich im letzten Salon vorgestellt hat, Reallohnverlust.
Also in Deutschland gibt es, um mal eine Pointe zu machen, die natürlich nächstes
Jahr durch mein Buch hoffentlich breitere Wirkungen entfaltet,
aber auch, ich habe sie nachher nochmal im Rundown drin, wenn wir dazu kommen.
Friedrich Merz ist vor die Presse gegangen und hat gesagt, ich finde es,
Zitat, schockierend und empörend, dass Olaf Scholz seinen Namen auf einen Gruppenantrag
zum Thema Abtreibungsrechte klebt.
Denn, Zitat, kein Thema ist derart aufgeladen zu einem gesellschaftlichen Großkonflikt
zu führen wie Abtreibung.
Naja.
So. Abtreibung, es gibt 100.000 Abtreibungen in Deutschland,
das heißt bei 80 Millionen Menschen so 0,15 Prozent der Leute machen pro Jahr
eine Abtreibung. Wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen sozioökonomisch denkt,
die haben ja auch Freunde, Family, Friends und spielt eine Mann eine Rolle, wie auch immer.
Sagen wir mal so 0,5 Prozent der Bevölkerung haben pro Jahr mit einer Abtreibung zu tun.
Da droht kein Großkonflikt. Das ist völlig Pseudo, er wollte irgendwie nochmal
ein Thema mobilisieren, was auch immer.
Das ist für Friedrich Merz ein Großkonflikt.
Genau. Während er gleichzeitig das, wo wirklich der Großkonflikt nicht nur droht,
sondern da ist und einfach nur auf ein politisches Angebot wartet,
das sagt, wenn ihr mich wählt, sprengt ihr hier alles in die Luft.
Und dann wählen die Leute genau das. Und das blendet er aus.
Und das ist einfach ein großer, großer Fehler.
Jetzt haben wir es aber in Amerika einmal erlebt und wir möchten es,
außer du willst noch kurz was sagen.
So ein Menosphere. Ich will es nur ganz kurz sagen, wir hatten ja wieder einmal
recht, aber waren leider optimistisch.
Wir haben im Salonteaser über Christian Lindner und über die Scholz-Rede gesprochen.
Haben darüber gesprochen, dass Scholz hier ganz deutlich benennt,
woran es liegt an der Schuldenbremse. Er will nicht, dass er entweder oder.
Das Thema ist verflogen.
Da konnten wir.
Der Podcast war veröffentlicht, wir sahen bei Twitter, worüber wurde diskutiert.
Wann wird gewählt? Wir wollen jetzt schon an die Macht. Können wir bitte den
Wahlkampf zu Weihnachten machen? Wir als christliche Partei approve this message.
Und die Journalisten darauf, fünf Tage später, Taurus, Taurus, Taurus, Taurus.
Es ist schlimm, es ist schlimm, man hält es nicht aus, aber...
Anders als bislang, wo es immer hieß, ach diese Linken, die erklären nur irgendwas, keine Ahnung so.
Wir machen jetzt eine empirische Argumentation mit amerikanischer Realität.
Wenn es in Amerika passiert, kann es auch bei uns passieren.
Es ist geschehen, es kann wieder geschehen.
Scott Galloway betont jetzt mal zwei Minuten lang, was es mit dieser Manosphere
und diesen ökonomischen Konflikten auf sich hat und was die Wähler eigentlich wählen wollen.
The one in the election. And if you look at the age group that had the biggest
swing from 2020 in terms of who they voted for, hands down, there was an 11-point
swing towards Trump among 18 to 29-year-olds. Yeah.
And if you're a self-appointed social justice warrior or you're making judgments
on someone's character or you may not think they acquit themselves well personally
or professionally, but you can't afford a home.
The government or the left is lecturing at you about bailing out people who
went to college where you have absolutely no prospect of going to college either
because of inability to get in or inability to afford it.
If you can't see a way to having anything resembling the life your parents had,
you're not interested in being lectured about who's a better person.
You not only want change, you want disruption.
You don't even want conventional Republicans. You certainly don't want Democrats.
And the other age segment that swung the furthest was in my view,
their parents, 45 to 64-year-olds, because if you're a single mother Ja.
Und ihr, alle, das ist was nicht so ein.
Allein überestimaten, die Rolle der Bodelig Autonomie würde in dieser Reise spielen.
Denn Trump war able zu distanceen sich mit dem Menschen, ich bin nicht so crazy
als die Leute hier. Und so, die Leute haben die Beobachtung,
dass es nicht so eine Votation gegen Bodelig Autonomie ist.
Aber wenn du siehst, wenn du eine Mutter oder du ein Kind und deine Kinder und
deine Kinder, die ihr Kinder sind, die ihr in der Tat, You just want change.
You want to burn the whole place down.
So if you look, in my view, if you look at what really drove this election,
it was one, bodily autonomy was not the referendum, the motivator that people thought.
And it's not only young people that are struggling, 24% less wealthy than they
were 40 years ago, where seniors are 72% wealthier.
If pop-up and Nana complain, it's bad.
Das droht hier auch, also in Südeuropa auf jeden Fall und bei uns auch.
Es ist nur das Angebot noch nicht da. Wer dachte, ja die AfD und so,
das ist ja alles ganz schön gefährlich.
Also die AfD hält sich noch ganz schön an die Konvention.
Da werden auch die Reden im Bundestag beendet, wenn der Präsident sagt,
so, Redezeit ist vorbei, wie auch immer.
Schaut euch Österreich an. Kickl bei der Nationalratswahl, wir haben diesen Clip hier gespielt, es,
Keine Rücksicht mehr zu nehmen auf das politische System, wie es ist, ist das Erfolgsrezept.
Wir haben jetzt in der Steiermark eine Landtagswahl gehabt, bei der die FPÖ 17,8% plus hatte.
Der größte Zuwachs so einer neuen Partei, so einer neuen Protestpartei ever
in den deutschen Landtagen.
Also es geht jetzt erst los, dass das richtig ausgearbeitet wird.
Ach, da ist jemand, der für mich das politische System in die Luft sprengt,
wähle ich sofort. Inhalte?
Scheißegal. Hauptsache, da hält sich jemand nicht an die Konvention.
Das haben wir in Deutschland noch nicht so. Jetzt hat Scott Gatoway hier angesprochen,
aber die Menschen haben doch trotzdem noch und es war doch voll bedeutend und
wir haben es ja auch betont, Michelle Obama hält noch diese Rede an die Männer,
die uns lieben und so weiter und so fort.
Der interessanteste Punkt in der amerikanischen Wahl ist der zwischen einem
handfesten partikularistischen Interesse, nämlich ich brauche ein Recht auf
Abtreibung, und General Election ums Präsidentenamt.
Denn in zehn Ländern, in zehn Bundesstaaten stand beides auf dem Wahlzettel.
Kate, so much of the focus on Election Day was, quite naturally,
on the race for president.
And I think as a result, a lot of us, and here I'm guilty myself,
we're not going to. Didn't quite understand how much abortion was on the ballot.
And literally, not in that spiritual way that we sometimes talk about in political
reporting, that something is on the ballot. No, this was actually on the ballot.
That's right. So in 10 states, and pretty diverse states across the country,
there were amendments on the ballot to establish abortion rights in the state constitution.
This was a record number of ballot measures on abortion.
In seven of those 10 states, those amendments won. So quick math,
that's a 70% victory rate.
In zehn Bundesstaaten stand also auf dem Wahlzettel, machen sie ihr Kreuz hier,
wenn sie Abtreibungsrechte als verbrieftes Recht in eine Verfassung haben wollen.
Was bedeutet, danach kann gar kein Landesparlament mehr sagen, hier und so weiter.
Weil das geht sofort vor das lokale Verfassungsgericht, die sagen,
es steht doch eine Verfassung, was macht denn hier für einen Scheiß und so.
Also es wurde einfach wie die Schuldengremse fundamental abgesichert.
Es stand in 10 von diesen 50 Bundesstaaten so auf dem Wahlzettel und in 7 hat
es gewonnen. Es gab also 3, auf denen es nicht gewonnen hat.
Einer davon ist Florida. Wir denken jetzt, naja klar, Florida wurde ja auch
gedreht, das ist ja jetzt nicht nur Trumland, sondern auch Sun City und so,
da leben die ganzen Alten, die wählen natürlich die roten Themen und sagen Abtreibung,
ne da bin ich voll dagegen.
Aber in Florida gewann diese Abstimmung das in die Verfassung zu schreiben nur
nicht, weil man dort 60% braucht.
In Arizona, it wins by 62%. In Nevada by 64%. Missouri becomes the first state
to overturn a ban on abortion and they get 52% of support. In a very red state.
Yeah, even one of those three states where the ballot measure didn't succeed,
which is Florida, it's still got a majority of support.
It was 57%. It was just that Florida required 60% to pass.
So, in Florida haben die Leute zu 57% gesagt, wir möchten das in der Verfassung.
Hatte dann Niederlage, weil 60% erfordert sind.
Trump kam nur auf 56% in Florida.
Also wir haben es hier mit einer Disparität bei einem Thema,
das mich interessiert und einem, ich möchte gerne das ganze politische System
in die Luft sprengen, von mehr, also das ist mehr als Lanslide.
Lanslide ist so 5% plus minus oder was, das hier sind 15.
Bedeutet aber, dass Republikaner für die Liberalisierung von Abtreibungen gestimmt
haben und zugleich für Trump.
Und das ist doch einfach zu erklären.
Ich habe eine ganz einfache Erklärung, sag du?
Melania Trump sagt, sie ist pro-choice.
Sehr viele Republikaner sind liberal bis libertär und sind deshalb pro-choice.
Viele Republikaner sind nicht mehr christlich.
Trump mag mit der Bibel da rumrennen, aber er ist der typische Protagonist von
Republikanern, die nicht mehr mit dem Christentum verwurzelt sind.
Wir haben also eine radikale Christianisierung in einem gewissen Spektrum der
Republikaner und diese setzen sich durch und wollen deshalb Abtreibungsrechte
limitieren oder ganz einschränken.
Und auf der anderen Seite haben wir Republikaner, die sich überhaupt nicht um
solche Fragen scheren, die sofort bereit wären, Kinder auch zu züchten oder sonst was zu machen,
die ganz andere Träume haben und die nicht mehr an irgendein konservatives religiöses
Weltbild geknüpft sind.
Und da kann man es ganz deutlich sehen, es wird Trump-Unterstützer geben,
die pro-Choice sind, die auch pro-Gay-Ride sind,
die aber zugleich sagen, Trump ist der richtige Mann, weil er alles mal in die Luft sprengt.
Also ja, also Ideologie, Weltbild, Christentum spielt eine Rolle,
aber es ist glaube ich doch profaner als was Melania Trump im Wahlkampf macht.
Die Entscheidung für eine Abtreibung ist im Konkreten eigentlich nie ideologisch,
sondern man stellt einfach fest, oh ich bin jetzt schwanger und dann fragt man
sich, passt mir das gerade?
Kann ich mir das Kinderzimmer leisten? Ist meine Beziehung stabil genug?
Wie auch immer. Und dann entscheidet man sich erstmal aus fünf ökonomischen
Gründen dagegen und dann klar kann es auch noch eine Großwetterlage in Sachen Ideologie geben,
aber Trump zu wählen, um zu sagen, dieses System, das mich ökonomisch nicht
mehr zur Potte kommen lässt,
möchte ich zerstören, ist absolut kongruent mit einer Entscheidung,
ich brauche Abtreibungsrechte, weil ich kann mir kein Kind leisten.
Also es sind beides ökonomische Entscheidungen, die sozusagen ohne großen Überbau
und jetzt was sagt nochmal irgendwer zu Trump und was hat der da so Wunsch für
eine Meinung, sondern es ist eine ganz konkrete Lebensplanung,
mein Gehalt ist so und so viel, ich kann mir kein Kind leisten und ich hätte
aber trotzdem gerne random Sex.
Ja und das ist, da will ich ja gar nicht widersprechen, ich glaube nur,
dass wir uns ein bisschen zu sehr darauf fokussieren, wenn wir sagen,
Trump ist jetzt derjenige, der ein religiöses Weltbild zurückträgt.
Trump hat im Wahlkampf ganz klar gesagt, das ist Angelegenheit der Bundesstaaten.
Ja und deswegen können wir ja auch ganz deutlich sehen, auch wenn das viele nicht erkennen wollen,
Trump vereinigt hinter sich einen sehr gärigen Haufen von verschiedenen Leuten,
die nicht in Einklang zu bringen sind und wir werden jetzt gleich was über die
Manusphäre ja hören und da ist auch sozusagen,
das ist nicht eine einheitliche Linie, da sind nicht alle, die in der Manusphäre
sind zugleich gegen Abtreibung, ganz im Gegenteil.
Und da haben wir nur einen Präsidenten, der merkwürdigerweise es schafft,
diese Lager auf sich zu vereinen, wo sie doch eigentlich nicht zusammenpassen.
Und das ist sicherlich eine moderne Ausgestaltung von, sagen wir,
postfaschistischen oder wegen mir auch ultraautoritären Führerpersönlichkeiten,
dass sie so verschiedene Positionen hinter sich vereinigen.
Und wir sehen es ja in Deutschland auch.
Das Lebensmodell von Alice Weidel widerspricht fundamental vielen AfD-Anhängern.
Und trotzdem werden sie Alice Weidels AfD wählen und werden auch mit Alice Weidel
einverstanden sein, solange sie ihre Ideologien und Idiosynkrasien auch ausleben dürfen.
Ja, es ist ja auch dieses Phänomen von Meloni ja auch.
Meloni wird gewählt, die Migrationszahlen explodieren, also das Ziel wird nicht
erreicht, da die Grenzen zu schließen.
Die Wähler wissen das auch, sehen das ja am Fernsehen und sagen sich aber,
ja, aber die Meloni will es trotzdem.
Also ich bin einfach davon überzeugt, wie sie redet und das ist bei Weidel eben
auch. Weidel hatet einfach rum und man mag diesen Hate, egal was da dahinter steht.
Und auch hier Meloni nochmal interessant. Sie ist, soweit ich weiß,
alleinerziehende Mutter.
Sie ist nicht verheiratet. Das ist eigentlich etwas, was die Konservativen immer torpediert haben.
Also die Politik von Margaret Thatcher und Ronald Reagan war eine Politik gegen Alleinerziehende.
Das war eine frauenfeindliche Politik, die vor allem an den Alleinerziehenden
festgemacht wurde. Und die Alleinerziehenden wurden als asozial,
als unverantwortlich und so weiter dargestellt.
Das hat sich total gewandelt nun, nicht im Ganzen, also diese Politik gibt es
natürlich immer noch, aber zugleich schaffen die es,
eine Politik zu machen, die weiterhin Alleinerziehende radikal benachteiligt,
aber diese Politik wird durchgeführt von einer Frau, die alleinerziehend ist.
Familienpolitisch ist ja auch die Solomutterschaft liegen geblieben.
Das ist ja in Deutschland genauso.
Wir sagen zwar nicht, Alleinerziele sind asozial, aber dass 50% von denen in
nicht selbstverschuldeter Armut leben, ist halt so.
So gehen die damit um.
So, jetzt kommt, ich habe ja eben schon betont, Bernie Sanders sagt,
wenn man die ökonomischen Fragen nicht betont, ist egal, wie die Argumentation
läuft, you can't fight something with nothing.
Muss halt irgendwas im Angebot haben. Ansonsten setzt sich dieses Something durch.
Joe Rogan war also bei J.D. Vance. Nee, J.D. Vance war bei Joe Rogan.
So rum, sie haben ein Gespräch geführt. Wir hören jetzt nur mal in zwei Ausschnitten,
du hast ja danach auch noch welche, habe ich gehört, in zwei Ausschnitten,
was da so diskutiert wird.
Und ich will sagen, hier geht es um Migration.
Und wir haben es auch schon betont, ein Grad mehr Temperaturanstieg für die
Welt bedeutet eine Milliarde mehr Flüchtlinge. Wir hören mal, wie die darüber reden.
Und das was wirklich beeinflusst ist global cooling. Randall Carlson,
der in Asteroid Collisions und die Younger Drys Impact Theory,
ist ein ein Fassinatier.
Aber er sagt, dass die perioden in der Geschichte, wo wir sehr close sind,
sind wir wie wenn es ein Ice Age ist. Das sind die meisten beeinflusst.
Das ist richtig. Wenn es global warming ist, dann geht es um,
dass es nicht so warm ist. Und das ist das Leute haben immer wieder gemacht.
Und du hast es technologisch gemacht.
Das finde ich so hart, dass die beiden im Gespräch einfach sagen,
naja, erstens wird es kälter und zweitens, wenn es wärmer würde,
dann zieht man halt einfach weiter.
Und man denkt, ja genau, die Leute ziehen eben gerade alle weiter,
deswegen habt ihr so eine riesige Migrationsdebatte da bei euch und die euch
da ins Amt gespielt hat. aber im Gespräch so, ja gut, zieht man halt weiter, wo ist denn das Problem?
Das war jetzt zum anderen,
Wir haben ausführlich betont, wie sehr diese Typen so ein zivilisatorisches,
demografisches Projekt einfach vor sich haben.
Die Childless Cat Lady, die Alleinerziehende, das geht nicht.
Hier müssen Thread Vives her, die uns einfach, your buddy, my choice und so weiter.
Die beiden reden jetzt über die Weltbevölkerung. Wir wissen,
wie Elon Musk darüber denkt.
Wir wissen, worüber die so beim Abendessen reden, wenn sie da gemeinsam in ihrem
Flugzeug ihre Hamburger essen und so. Diese Themen. Das ist wirklich...
Das ist so nicht so true. Das ist so nicht so true. Und es ist auch,
Historisch, like one of the craziest moments in history, in my opinion,
is the Mongols and what the Mongols did in the 1200s.
They lowered the carbon footprint of Earth because they killed so many people.
They killed 10% of the population of Earth.
That is crazy. And because of that, because they devastated these places and
killed so many people, trees grew, more trees grew, and it lowered the carbon
footprint. These places that had been overcome by agriculture were then reconsumed by nature.
And it lowered the carbon footprint of Earth. Well, there is a fundamentally,
it raises the point, there's a fundamentally anti-human element of the radical
environmental movement in the United States of America.
They're saying we have to reduce population. This is one. And when they say
it with vaccines, you're like, slow down.
That's right. Did you just say that out loud?
And then when you read Robert F. Kennedy Jr., and I encourage everyone to read
Robert F. Kennedy Jr.'s book, The Real Anthony Fauci.
Das ist alles so irre.
Ja. Also die Antinatalisten sind die größte Gefahr, deswegen sind wir gegen
Abtreibung, sonst machen wir es wie die Mongolen.
Und dann kommt dann auch die Impfung mit rein und die Mongolen haben ja 10%
der Weltfolgen getötet und so weiter. Also das ist wirklich… Aber.
Jetzt sag mal, das ist ja jetzt eine inhaltliche Kritik.
Wie hat dir das atmosphärisch gefallen? Ich habe das den gesamten Podcast gehört.
Also, wir haben dieses Phänomen, dass eigentlich Fernsehsendungen so heißen,
wie der Typ, den man da gerne sieht.
Karim Joska, Sabine Christiansen, Anne Will. Und jetzt heißt aber plötzlich
eine Partei Sarah Wagenknecht.
Was bedeutet, wir haben es hier mit einer illegitim korrupten Sektorenüberschreitung
zu tun, die nach Steffen Mau die Arenen durcheinander bringt.
Also wir führen plötzlich auf Bühnen auf, die aber nicht mehr Bühnen sind,
sondern Parlamente oder das Weiße Haus.
Weil das was wir hier sehen ist einfach Gelaber, das halt stattfindet weil Leute
das gerne hören und das hat eigentlich keine politische Konsequenz nur jetzt
ist es halt der Vizepräsident der genau über diese Attraktivität in dieses Amt kam ganz richtig.
Denn ich habe dieses Interview gehört, ich musste nach Emden für einen Vortrag,
und ich hörte das komplett während der Fahrt, dreieinhalb Stunden und ich hatte gute Laune dabei,
Also nicht, dass mir jetzt einer unterstellt, ich würde mit diesen Inhalten
sympathisieren, keineswegs, aber in der Art, wie die da rumkaspern,
quatschen, quatschen, quatschen und dann habe ich mir immer wieder klar gemacht,
der sitzt jetzt sechs Tage vor der US-Wahl, bevor er also Vizepräsident wird.
Dreieinhalb Stunden angstfrei in einem Podcast und labert einfach drauf los.
Kamala Harris und alle anderen professionellen Politiker lassen sich sechs Tage
lang briefen, um 20 Minuten bei CBS Rede und Antwort zu stehen.
Lernen Sätze auswendig bis zum geht nicht mehr.
Und die reden einfach darauf los und da gibt es noch ein Buch,
das sagt dies und das und ja die Impfung und Big Pharma und irgendetwas über Männlichkeit.
Sie machen einfach immer weiter.
Und genau diese angstfreie Performance ist es natürlich, die so wahnsinnig gut
angekommen ist, dass man sagte, also wenn der so angstfrei da quatschen kann,
dann ist das doch kein Problem.
Und das war ja ein ähnliches Ding mit Maximilian Krah bei Thilo Jung,
dass Thilo natürlich versuchte.
Ganz anders als Jorgen, der ja wirklich nur kuschelt, Thilo versuchte,
investigativ zu sein, aber Krah merkte irgendwann, wenn ich einfach nur durchhalte
hier und ein bisschen locker rede und mich nicht verbiegen lasse und das sechs
Stunden durchziehe, dann wird allein dies als performativer Akt schon wirksam sein.
Und das erleben wir jetzt bei diesem Podcast die ganze Zeit und deswegen werden
wir diesen Shift erleben.
Wir haben ihn jetzt bei der US-Wahl erlebt, also der Podcast ist das Zentrum,
da findet ganz wichtiges statt, nämlich da findet eine Art der Kommunikation statt,
die so unmittelbar in die Ohren reingeht, dass man sagt, ach ja, könnte ich wählen.
Und wir kennen jemanden in Deutschland, der das jetzt gerade das schon macht mit dem Podcast.
Lindner war bei Tim Gabel zu Gast. Ich habe es mir nicht angehört,
ich habe nur mal kurz reingeschaut und Tim Gabel ist ja jemand,
der Fitness-Influencer ist,
der ja wahrscheinlich von sich sagen würde, eigentlich bin ich gar nicht so
politisch, aber irgendwie ist man dann doch immer so politisch,
dass man absolut so einen Lindner-Kurs vertritt und da kann man schon sehen,
wie so diese Kuschel-Interviews eine große Wirksamkeit entfalten können.
Ja, die beiden sitzen quasi nur rum und ereifern sich darüber,
wie schlecht der Start ist, denn der Gabel hat es doch auch geschafft mit einer
App und so weiter und so, wieso ist das alles so kompliziert.
Da wir hier eine Zäsur haben, will ich einen Clip spielen, der so ein bisschen
neben der Spur wirkt, aber bevor wir nochmal ausdrücklich über diesen Redaktionsschluss gleich reden.
Und Pistorius wurde natürlich dann auch im Journalismus gefragt,
was hat sie mit dem Rückzug auf sich, also ihre Umfragewerte sind doch so gut.
Was ja bedeutet, die Journalisten sitzen so da und denken sich,
wieso kümmert sich ein Politiker um irgendein anderes Kriterium als das Publikum
mag ihn, sieht ihn gerne.
Wo wir sagen, ja, das sind die Kategorien für Film, Bühne, was auch immer.
Musik, aber nicht in der Politik. So, und es übernimmt aber sozusagen diese
Medienlogik, gerade auch durch den Ausfall redaktioneller Medien,
die einem nochmal irgendwie versuchen zu erklären, um was es eigentlich geht.
Nur, wenn der innerste innere Mainstream der öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender,
das heute Journal, selber alle Prinzipien über Bord wirft und sagt,
Herr Pistorius, ich verstehe das gar nicht, also Sie sind doch einfach beliebt,
Brauchen sie noch was anderes?
Expertise? Sind sie bescheuert? Ja, so ungefähr. Pistorius versucht das nochmal
ganz gut zu kontern, wofür ich fast gesagt hätte, genau wegen dieser humble
Opinion könnte man ihn jetzt doch zum Kanzlerkandidat machen.
Aber es zu hören, wie er auch nochmal versucht,
die letzten vernünftigen Prinzipien zu retten, und zwar nicht da,
wo sie schon verloren sind, in der Menus-4-3-Stunden-Podcast-Blase,
sondern nochmal im heutigen All, gibt mir wirklich zu bedenken.
Also das sind einfach wirkliche Zäsuren, die hier stattfinden.
Bei der Frage, mit welchen Kandidaten würde die SPD ein besseres Ergebnis erzielen,
da sehen Sie eine überwältigende Mehrheit sagt mit Boris Pistorius,
also mit Ihnen und sogar eine überwältigende Mehrheit der SPD-Anhänger sagt das.
Kann man denn an diesen Zahlen wirklich vorbei sein?
Ja, man muss es im Zweifel sogar, weil andere Maßstäbe wichtiger sind.
Umfragen sind gut, Beliebtheitsumfragen sind mal schöner, mal weniger schön,
sie sind aber auch vergänglich.
Und Demokratie und staatspolitische Verantwortung müssen sich nach anderen Fragestellungen richten.
Wir wissen außerdem, dass Beliebtheitsumfragen noch lange sich nicht umwandeln
lassen in Stimmen an der Wahlurne.
Herr Absur ist aber auch, selbst SPD-Abgeordnete
haben ja jetzt in der Vergangenheit, in den letzten Tagen...
Also Christian Sievers zeigt jetzt, das ist ihm alles egal? Es geht ihm nur,
also mir geht es nur darum, ob die Leute mich mögen, wenn ich das heute schon moderiere.
Dann versucht die ihm das jetzt auch aufzutragen.
Immer wieder gesagt, Scholz sei bei den Menschen im Land unten durch.
Ich sehe das nicht so, um es deutlich zu sagen, sonst hätte ich mich heute nicht so klar geäußert.
Es mag hier und da diese Stimmung geben, aber gegen diese Stimmung anzugehen,
ist jetzt unsere gemeinsame Verantwortung.
Eine Partei in Regierungsverantwortung, die den Kanzler stellt,
die sich nur mit sich selbst beschäftigt, die ist nicht attraktiv für andere.
Wie sehr kann denn so ein Move, sage ich jetzt mal, den Sie jetzt gerade machen,
Sie selbst auch beschädigen?
Also sollte man als Spitzenpolitiker jemals ausschließen, Bundeskanzler werden zu wollen?
Ist ja wirklich interessant. Jetzt fragen Sie schon wieder, ob das nicht schädlich
wäre, etwas auszuschließen.
Ich habe nie etwas ausgeschlossen. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass ich jetzt,
dass ich nicht kandidiere, dass ich nicht zur Verfügung stehe.
Und das ist der Punkt jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Und dabei bleibt es auch.
Man könnte ja auch mal fragen, warum ist eigentlich Scholz in der Bevölkerung
gerade nicht so beliebt?
Naja, vielleicht, weil ihr jeden Tag sagt, dass Pistorius der Kanzler der Herzen ist.
Es ist eine reine mediale Debatte und die ganze Zeit fragen die Journalisten,
die Politiker, warum führen sie denn diese Debatte und die Politiker so,
wir versuchen hier gerade das Land zu retten, aber sie kommen ja immer mit dieser Debatte.
Also es ist wirklich, es ist Redaktionsschluss. Wir müssen jetzt,
ich will nur zwei Clips im Vorfeld kurz.
Eilenberger hat zwei Experten da, Elisabeth Bronfen und Manfred Berg.
Mit der ich am 4.12. in Zürich auf einer Bühne sitzen soll.
Sehr gut, denn du kannst ja auch nochmal den Allenberger dann machen.
Aber ich glaube, es geht um was anderes, es geht um Film.
Ja, also Allenberger stellt sehr gute Fragen und man hört so ein bisschen,
ihm geht es hier auch um was.
Also Trump verfügt jetzt, im Unterschied zu 2017, über eine Machtfülle,
die er damals nicht hatte.
Und das ist ja eine Situation, in der doch viele Menschen sagen,
das ist ganz anders als bei seiner ersten Präsidentschaft. Nicht nur ist er
programmatisch besser vorbereitet oder wirkt besser vorbereitet,
er kann auch in dem Maße, in dem das in Amerika überhaupt möglich ist und so
stark ist es vielleicht gar nicht möglich, durchregieren.
Und jetzt mal Hand aufs Herz, für wie hoch halten Sie die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das die letzten Freien und Fähren waren im Land der Freien?
Ich finde, diese Frage sollte jetzt überall immer gefragt werden.
Das ist einfach die Frage, um die es jetzt geht.
Ja, unwahrscheinlich. Also Sie meinen, das System wird halten?
Was macht Sie da so optimistisch? Es gibt schon noch immer eine Verfassung.
Ja, aber es gibt auch ein Verfassungsgericht, das gesagt hat, Trump steht drüber.
Die Verfassung ist in der Hand eines Gerichtes, das von Trump bestellt ist und
das wackelige Entscheidungen trifft bezüglich auf die Substanz dieser Verfassung.
Also ich bin Ihrer Meinung, aber ich würde vor allem sagen, wir haben in letzter
Zeit viel über den Faschismusbegriff in dem Zusammenhang diskutiert.
Harris nannte Trumps Faschist. Und ich denke, der Faschismusbegriff ist ein
Empörungsbegriff, der analytisch inzwischen sehr problematisch geworden ist.
Aber die USA haben zu starke demokratische, föderale und libertäre Traditionen,
als dass sich die Amerikaner einer zentralistischen Diktatur unterwerfen würden.
Daran kann ich nicht glauben. Ich sehe ein anderes Szenario.
Ich sehe das Szenario, und das würde die These von der Spaltung eher stärken,
dass sich die blauen Bundesstaaten politisch so weit wie möglich abzukoppeln. versuchen.
Ja, also entweder lebt man diese neue Rolle des Präsidenten voll aus oder man
hat einen Separatismus.
Mal sehen. Ein kleiner Clip nur, denn ich finde, so SWR Kultur oder so,
die dann einfach ihr Forum machen, da hat man jetzt so manchmal Gesprächspartner,
die so ein bisschen schon einfach den Schritt gegangen sind, der Zäsur.
Ja, habe ich mal gesehen. Wie ist das denn? Was kann denn noch dazwischen kommen?
Es gibt ja noch Prozesse gegen Trump.
Ich kann da natürlich, sobald er im Amt ist, sich selber sozusagen reinsprechen,
aber Es gibt einen Schweigegeldprozess, das Strafmaß wird am 26.11.
Verkündet. Ist das noch etwas, ein Stolperstein hin zur Präsidentschaft?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Also erstmal, selbst wenn er da verurteilt wird,
kann er in Berufung gehen. Das dauert alles noch so lange, bis er dann wieder
am Amt ist, rechtskräftig.
Und dann ja, dank des obersten Gerichtshofs, den er ja besetzt hat,
mit reaktionären Leuten auch mehr oder minder machen, was er will.
Die haben ihm ja praktisch einen Freibrief gegeben, sogar Leute umzubringen.
Also Amerikaner im Ausland machen das Präsidenten ja sowieso häufiger.
Das kann man immer mal wieder jetzt einflechten so. Der amerikanische Präsident
darf jetzt seine politischen Kontrahenten töten.
Und dann mal gucken, was Luis Klamroth dazu sagt.
Ja, wenn es nötig ist.
Oder Frau Ilna, wie auch immer. So, Redaktionsschluss.
Feldenkirchen referiert mal kurz die Debatte, die ja, sagen wir mal,
in Amerika nur so ein bisschen Vorläufe hat.
Auch in Frankreich zum Beispiel sind alle großen Zeitungen in Milliardärshand.
Hier in Deutschland, ja, wir haben noch die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen und die haben
auch einen hohen Zuspruch.
Selbst die Shell-Jugendstudie sagt wieder, die jungen Leute sagen,
das ist ein ganz wichtiges Programm. Nutzen sie es? Nein.
Mit hinzu, dass dann auf der Bühne der Präsentation der Jugendstudie gesagt
wird, es wäre schön, wenn die jungen Leute, die den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen so
viel Zuspruch geben in Sachen Vertrauen, das auch mal nutzen würden.
Die gucken ja in sozialen Medien, bei TikTok.
Ja gut, da kriegt man dann mal in der Minute viel Programm oder so unter 10 Stunden.
Feldenkirchen also sitzt im Podcast von Micky Beisenherz und kommt kurz darauf zu sprechen.
Milliardäre ohne Rückgrat. Darüber schreibt die Zeit.
Milliardäre und einflussreiche Unternehmer spielen im US-Wahlkampf eine entscheidende Rolle.
Auf Seiten der Republikaner ist es vor allem der schon erwähnte Elon Musk,
der mit seinem Engagement und seinen Großspenden für Trump von sich reden macht.
Auf Seite der Demokraten gerieten zuletzt Amazon-Gründer und Besitzer der Washington
Post Jeff Bezos sowie Patrick Shun-Shion, Eigentümer der LA Times, in die Kritik.
Denn die beiden haben offenbar verhindert, dass sich ihre Redaktionen,
die Zeitungen, für Kamala Harris aussprechen.
Das ist in den USA, hat das Tradition, dass Zeitungen, in Deutschland gibt es
das nicht, aber vor der Wahl sagen, so wir haben alles geprüft und das ist der
beste Kandidat oder die beste Kandidatin.
Und warum diesmal nicht? Also das haben auch die LA Times und die Washington
Post in der Vergangenheit gemacht.
Vermutlich, so heißt es auch hier, weil beide Milliardäre mit einem Wahlsieg
von Donald Trump rechnen und ihre Unternehmen vor der Rache Trumps schützen
wollen. Denn für beide sind die Zeitungen vor allem ein Hobby,
von dem sie sich ihre Geschäfte in anderen Bereichen nicht kaputt machen lassen.
So, hier ist also Rätselraten. Warum hat der Jeff Bezos das gemacht?
Und in Amerika ist die Debatte ein bisschen anders. John Heilmann,
einer dieser großen Politstrategen, die jetzt bei Hacks on Tap,
er mit David Exelort und Mike Murphy, die ja jeweils Präsidentenwahlkämpfe gemanagt haben,
Podcasts zusammen haben.
Die sind jetzt auf einer Bühne, es ist nicht allzu gut zu verstehen,
aber der John Heilmann erklärt mal kurz, wie kam es dazu, dass Jeff Bezos dieses
schon geschriebene Statement dieser Redaktion dann gekillt hat.
Donald Trump did a public meeting with Blue Origin, one of Jeff Bezos' companies,
on the same day that this op-ed got killed.
That is an act of public enforced obeisance where if there was a legitimate
argument, if the Washington Post
or any newspaper doesn't want to publish editorials, that's totally legit.
If they'd announced this a year ago, two years ago, on a reasonable time frame,
and said, you know, we want to get out of the business of editorials,
that would have been completely legitimate and totally fine.
Instead, at the very last,
Das ist ein, als ich sage, ein act of public bending die Knee.
Also, Jeff Bezos hat eine Firma, Blue Origin, mit der fliegt er auch in den
Weltraum. Die ersten Touristen sind damit schon hochgeflogen.
Trump hat an dem Tag, und er wusste, die wollen das da publizieren,
Ein Meeting mit Blue Origin gemacht in aller Öffentlichkeit,
bei dem er die Gelegenheit nutzte, Jeff Bezos zu sagen, du publizierst das nicht.
Und dann hat Jeff Bezos bei seiner Redaktion angerufen und hat gesagt,
ich als euer Eigner sage, ihr publiziert das nicht.
Primat des Politischen.
In dem Fall ist es das Primat der Macht über die Ökonomie.
Was bedeutet, hier fand eine, können wir jetzt verschiedene Sachen,
also Arenenüberschreitung, eine Sphärentrennung wurde nicht eingehalten,
es fand Korruption statt, würde man systemtheoretisch sagen.
In Deutschland ist das natürlich anders. Da entscheidet immer noch der Springer
Verlag, wer hier regiert. Ja, also ich meine, wir reden die ganze Zeit über die USA.
Wir haben einen immer mächtiger werdenden Springer Konzern.
Nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern auch darüber hinaus.
Wir haben einen Springer Konzern, der ganz...
Total immer mächtiger werden soll. Aber wieso?
Naja, also mit dem Zukunft von Politico. Der Einflussname jetzt,
die stattfindet bei der Bewertung von Außenpolitik. Wir sehen die ganze Zeit Warnschüsse.
Wenn doch mal manche Grüne sich erlauben, infrage zu stellen,
dass diese Waffendieferungen an Israel Probleme mit sich bringen,
kommt direkt einen Tag später als Warnschuss.
So muss man es ganz klar verstehen. Baerbock hat sich mit Israel Hassan zum
Dinner getroffen. Wer ist dann dabei?
Michael Barenboim wird dann da rubriziert und andere aus Künstlerkreisen.
Wir haben einen Springerkonzern, der seit Beginn des Krieges gegen die Scholz-Regierung
geht, vor allem gegen Scholz selbst.
Wir haben einen Herausgeber, ich will es noch bis zum Ende auflösen.
Das ist enorm, deshalb, weil sie nicht nur über sehr viele Zeitungsorgane und
die Bild-Zeitung verfügen, die etwa 750.000 Digitalabos hat plus die Printausgabe.
Die Bild-Zeitung gibt den Ton an, auch für ganz viele andere Redaktionen.
Es ist so, dass was in der Bild-Zeitung als Thema gemacht wird,
wird von der dpa dankbar aufgegriffen. Auch deshalb, weil dpa natürlich auch
zum Teil von Springer-Medien mitfinanziert wird. So ist ja dieses Konglomerat.
Wir können also sagen, dort wird der Ton gesetzt und das haben wir jetzt gerade
beim Thema Habeck-Heizungsgesetz wunderbar sehen können. Wir sehen es ebenso
bei der Bewertung des Nahostkriegs und wir sehen es ebenso bei dem Ukraine-Krieg.
Da ist eine enorme publizistische Macht.
Hinter vorgehaltener Hand reden auch Politiker darüber und sagen,
ja, ich kann das leider nicht machen oder ich kann es leider nicht sagen,
denn sie wissen, was dann am nächsten Tag in der Bild-Zeitung darüber stehen wird.
Also diese publizistische Macht ist eher stärker geworden und wir sehen es im Übrigen auch daran.
Dass die Bild-Zeitung wie keine andere Zeitung es geschafft hat,
diesen Schritt ins Digitale zu gehen. Sie ist damit sehr erfolgreich.
Der Springer Verlag im Ganzen ist enorm erfolgreich. Da ist überhaupt nicht dran zu rütteln.
Und sehr viele andere orientieren sich daran, zudem ja auch viele andere Medienhäuser
keineswegs betrieben werden von Leuten, die dem Sozialismus nahestehen.
Sondern wenn ich jetzt an den Holzbring Verlag denke, dann gibt es da auch eine
klare Richtung, die nicht bedeutet, stärke die Arbeitnehmerrechte oder nehme
das Privatfernsehen, ob das jetzt die Sat.1 Gruppe ist oder RTL,
beide mit einer sehr großen Nähe zur Bild-Zeitung.
Ich teile die Beobachtung, dass man das inhaltlich beobachten kann,
nur die Mehrheit der Deutschen hat eben doch eine andere Meinung zum Ukraine-Krieg
als die BILD und erst recht zur FDP.
Ich rede aber über die, ja genau, da merken wir die Disruption im Ganzen.
Und deswegen bin ich ja froh über die Disruption, dass also immer weniger sich
über die Bild-Zeitung und so weiter informieren, sondern das wegen mir über TikTok machen.
Ich würde sagen, im Zweifel eines Falles ist man über TikTok besser und ehrlicher informiert.
Ja, da bin ich absolut von überzeugt. Es kommt drauf an, was man auswählt.
Es gibt sehr gute TikTok-Karten.
Der Algorithmus wählt aus.
Nein, man ist auch selbst mit daran beteiligt.
Also?
Doch, man ist selbst mit daran, lass mich das sagen, wir werden gleich Taylor
Lawrence dazu hören und sie sagt ziemlich gute Dinge auch.
Ich will nochmal hier deutlich unterstreichen, das stimmt, dass die Bevölkerung
trotz dieser medialen sehr homogenen Berichterstattung trotzdem noch anderer Meinung ist.
Das ist ein Zeichen von Medienpluralität, die durch die digitale Disruption stattgefunden hat.
Nur die Politik leitet oder ist noch sehr stark ausgerichtet auf die klassischen Medien.
Und wenn die Bild-Zeitung verkündet, Postpistorius ist der Kanzler,
dann schreiben das erstmal alle nach.
Es gibt eine ganz große Pfadabhängigkeit, das ist ja kein Wort, das wir mal verwenden.
Zur Bild-Zeitung. Ja, wir haben jetzt diesen Abend gehabt, in dem Olaf Scholz
mit allen bisherigen Gewohnheiten und auch, sagen wir mal, so medialen Regularien brach und sagte,
erstens, ich entlasse überhaupt mal einen Minister und zweitens,
ich mache es, um Schaden vom Land abzuwenden und weil er mich zu oft, zu oft, zu oft, zu oft,
Im Vertrauen missbraucht hat und so weiter. Was ja bei sehr vielen Leuten dazu
führte, krass, kennt ihr diesen Scholz? Nö.
Und so hat er Nickemeyer gleich gefragt. Oder eben in diesen ganzen Chatgruppen, alles ist voll.
Was für mich bedeutet, es lauert
eine ganz große Gefahr für den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk, nämlich,
dass diese Art von Ansprache auch bei Berlin Direkt oder Berlin Mitte oder wie
das da heißt, was CDF und ARD da so Sonntagabends veranstalten,
dass ein Politiker am Tisch des Interviews steht und auf eine Frage reagiert
mit, na sie sind ja total bescheuert.
Oder können Sie sich mal bitte vorbereiten auf das Gespräch?
Also wirklich eine vehemente, auch im sozialen Nahkampf unerhörte Ansage macht,
ohne die Angst haben zu müssen, dass er damit seine Wählerschaft verliert,
sondern genau im Gegenteil mobilisiert.
Was haben wir aber dann gesehen in der medialen Berichterstattung darüber,
was wir eben gesagt haben, nämlich wann wird gewählt und ist die FDP nicht das eigentliche Opfer?
Das war doch ganz interessant. Das muss man sehr differenzieren.
Warst du bei Bild Online In der Zeit, als Scholz diese Rede gehalten hat und
danach. Bei Bild und Welt und sonst wo.
Bei den Springer-Medien hat man sofort Scholz als das Feindbild auserkoren.
Ja, absolut.
Zwei Sphären, die hier ganz hart getrennt werden müssen. Das Interesse der CDU
als Opposition im politischen Betrieb und das Interesse von Journalisten,
auch etwas hier mit, eine Rolle mitzuspielen, sich dem politischen System zu führen.
Das ging nun überein, denn die CDU hatte ein großes Interesse,
relativ zügig zu wählen, weil die Umfrage gerade entsprechend war und man noch
nicht so ganz in den Trump-Schock dann reinregieren muss und so weiter, das ist ja beschrieben.
Aber trotzdem finde ich, wir sollten das analytisch trennen,
denn die CDU konnte damit eine Debatte bestimmen.
Schon allein, indem sie den Kanzler als der Zögernde, der will jetzt nur irgendwas.
Ich finde auch, Scholz hat einen echten Fehler gemacht, indem er sagte,
was ich mit der FDP nicht konnte, will ich jetzt mit der CDU machen. Das ist ja absurd.
Da sitzt natürlich Jens Spahn im Podcast bei wo auch immer der FAZ oder also
Corona-Butras habe ich da gerade im Ohr, wie sie da darüber reden und Jens Spahn
einfach nur die ganze Zeit so halt uphated über Scholz.
Nicht mehr denke, ja schade, macht er halt schon zurecht irgendwie.
Aber angenommen, die CDU hätte jetzt dieses Interesse nicht gehabt.
Also wir hätten jetzt wirklich mal nur die mediale Reaktion.
Meine Vermutung ist, wenn Scholz sagt, ich entlasse.
Den Finanzminister, um Schaden vom Land abzuwenden und dieser heißt Christian
Lindner und er hat mich zu oft, zu oft, zu oft, zu oft und so weiter. Meine These ist.
Die Journalisten hätten das ohne die Unterstützung der CDU niemals geschafft,
den Leuten einzureden, dass das ein blöder Move war, dass man so mit Lindner
nicht umgeht und wie auch immer, sondern ganz im Gegenteil,
umso mehr noch die Journalisten versucht hätten, uns diese Unerhörtheit dieser
persönlichen Ansprache, wir haben es ja, es wurde ja überall diskutiert,
bei Harder Barfer, bei Maischberger, überall ist da Scholz nicht so hart gewesen und so.
Also meine Vermutung ist, die Leute hätten genauso verwundert vom Fernsehen
gesessen und gefragt, hä, wieso stellt die Maischberger die Frage, warum und so weiter.
Das ist doch, klar muss man den dann halt rausschmeißen, das kennt doch jeder.
Am liebsten würde man mal jemand rausschmeißen. Also wenn die CDU gerade nicht
ein eigenes Interesse der Agenda-Setting und Agenda-Serving gemacht hätte.
Würden wir niemals, glaube ich, sagen, oh ja, stimmt.
Also Maischberger hat ganz schön die Stimmung gedreht, als sie Scholz dann Vorwürfe
machte. Weil ich glaube, die Leute denken mittlerweile wirklich nur noch in
so einem, und ich sage das auch, weil ich selber so denke.
Für mich ist es kein Unterschied, wer gerade Kanzler ist, wer Opposition ist
und wer im Fernsehen das kommentiert.
Für mich sind Sandra Maischberger, Friedrich Merz und Olaf Scholz dasselbe.
Das ist einfach eine Soße. Und wenn die irgendwelche Konflikte miteinander klären,
sind das nicht meine Konflikte.
Wenn aber Olaf Scholz plötzlich ausbricht aus diesem Ding und mir sagt,
um Schaden vom Land abzuwenden, habe ich den Typen, den du am meisten hatest,
ich habe deine Podcasts gehört, den habe ich jetzt vor die Tür gesetzt,
würde mich niemals ein Merz, eine Maischberger, ein Louis Klamroth,
ein Kubicki davon abbringen, ich fand das richtig, was Scholz da gemacht hat.
Dich nicht, einige andere auch nicht, nicht die Mehrheit. Die Umfragen zeigen es ja ganz eindeutig.
Eindeutig zeigen sie uns, dass eher dieser Kurs gefahren wird,
wenn man fragen würde, soll Lindner nochmal Finanzminister werden.
Hat netto verloren durch dieses Ding stattgebrochen. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Scholz hat netto dadurch verloren, aufgrund, sicherlich der CDU,
die da berechtigt Interesse hat, aber auch aufgrund einer medialen Berichterstattung,
die sich sehr stark am Springerkurs orientiert.
Scott Galloway sagt jetzt in
Amerika, zehn Jahre vorausgedacht von uns aus gesehen, alles ganz anders.
Nicht nur spielen die Redaktionen keine Rolle mehr, nicht mal mehr TikTok.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, dass wir über die Verkaufung haben, um sich über die
Verkaufung zwischen local television stations,
die über über, ich glaube, ich habe jetzt hundreds of millions of dollars in
Spenden, eigentlich drei zu einem von der Harris-Campagne, um die Ende,
um die alten Leute zu entscheiden, und sie können sie auf den Weg finden,
um auf Local News zu finden, die ich als ein Bildung von was,
was stupid die Leute heute heute.
Oh, die Leute in einem Auto in einem Baden-Türkern in einem Baden-Türkern haben,
die heute heute getrobbed.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, dass du das Geld nicht mehr verletzt hast,
nicht mehr zu digitalen, es wird über die Podcast-Kara.
Das war die Election der Manosphere, als brought to you by podcasters.
Und wenn du denkst, wenn du das letzte Mal wir hatten, war das letzte Mal ein Political ad?
We haven't. You're about to see a disruption in the local news broadcast television
advertising market, and all of that money is going to go to podcasts.
And if you look at graphs of attention versus revenue, 20 years ago,
it was the internet is a third of time and 8% of revenue, and newspapers were
8% of time and a third of revenue, and it flipped.
Money always follows attention, and attention is skyrocketing.
In 2025, we're going to see podcast revenue accelerate faster than TikTok, Meta, or Alphabet.
And then in 26, we're going to see a massive disruption in transfer of advertising
dollars from local news stations to podcasts, because that's where voters are hanging out.
This was no, amongst seniors, yeah, they voted.
And actually, interestingly enough, seniors was the only age group that went
more Harris, where Harris actually picked up votes versus 2020.
But what they're going to find is the swingiest of swing voters are young people.
They're the ones that are most impressionable and most upper grabs.
And guess what? Where's their medium? Podcast.
Das sind doch unsere Nachrichten, die wir hören wollen.
Wir haben ungefähr dieselben Zahlen. Er kommt jetzt hier auf die Hörer zu sprechen.
Das sind auch unsere, die er beschreibt.
The great white rhino of advertisers is the individual they no longer can reach.
And that's a young, wealthy male. Where are they? Podcasts.
So, the young, wealthy male.
Aber das sind doch nicht unsere Hörer.
Doch.
Also, ich führe ja Gespräche nach zum Beispiel Live-Veranstaltungen.
Da habe ich jetzt nicht den Eindruck von Reichtum.
Keine Verwechslung jetzt. Wir müssen hier wirklich ins Detail gehen.
Unsere, also Hörerinnen, die zu uns kommen, sind ungefähr zehn Jahre jünger
als die Masse unserer Hörer.
Ich weiß, wen du meinst. Die Leute, die zu dir kommen, erzählen dir von ihrem Studium.
Die erzählen, dass in der Kantine jetzt ein Essen ein Euro teurer ist.
25- bis 30-jährige Leute, nicht berufstätig, sondern in Ausbildung,
aber High-Level bei Ausbildung, also sie sind schon das dritte oder vierte Jahr
in Ausbildung, die kommen nicht aus der Schule und rutschen sofort irgendwo
rein, sondern da wird erstmal grundlegend ausgebildet.
Naja, es sind nun mal 90% mindestens Studentinnen, die uns bei Veranstaltungen,
also wenn sie im jungen Alter sind, sind es keine Handwerker.
Entschuldigung, aber ich habe mit einem Hörer und einer Hörerin gesprochen am,
vergangenen Donnerstag im Mittwoch in Köln.
Sie macht eine Ausbildung Gartenbau, eher eine Ausbildung Maurer.
Ja gut, wir kriegen auch häufig Honig geschenkt. Es sind viele Hobby-Imker dabei.
Gut, aber die Leute, die wir sehen, und da rede ich jetzt im Range von,
sagen wir mal, ein, zwei, die uns irgendwo ansprechen, bis zu 800,
die Karten kaufen, um zu uns nach Bockenheim zu kommen.
Klar, das ist ja auch eine gewisse Hürde, es kostet Geld. Erstmal der Eintritt
kostet 24 Euro und dann muss man vielleicht noch die Anreise finanzieren,
beziehungsweise in Frankfurt übernachten.
Das kann man jetzt nur machen, wenn man da ein bisschen Kleingeld hat.
Ja, man braucht aber auch Zeit, denn ich kenne ja unsere Zahlen,
sowohl von YouTube und Spotify, da wird ja sozusagen richtig mitgetrackt,
jeder einzelne und so weiter und so fort.
Unser Durchschnittsalter sind genau die 34 Jahre, die Scott Galloway bei sich
auch sieht in seinen Pivot und Prof G Podcast und so ungefähr 70, 75 Prozent männlich.
Das sind also die Leute, von denen Scott Galloway hier einfach sagt,
das sind die, die starten gerade mit ihrem ersten Gehalt so ein bisschen ins
Leben und die geben das jetzt einfach ohne groß drüber nachzudenken aus.
Die sind also sehr leicht durch Werbung in so Richtung des Konsums zu bringen,
weil sie noch nicht zu gefestigt sind und sich noch nicht zu sehr an,
ich habe jetzt Einkommen, ich müsste auch mal was sparen oder sowas,
gewöhnt haben, sondern da tobt noch so ein bisschen das Leben.
Und wir haben, ich weiß nicht genau, wie bei Pivot, die haben natürlich so eine
Millionenreichweite, allein was diese Age-Range 25 bis 40 und männlich angeht,
kommen wir ungefähr auf 100.000.
Das heißt, dieser Podcast, den ihr hier gerade hört, ist für die Werbebranche
sozusagen das goldene Kalb.
Ja. Niemand Wie gut, dass wir so viel draus machen.
Ja, es gibt kein anderes Medium, das eine für diese Branche attraktiveres Publikum
hat als wir, durch euch, die ihr uns zuhört.
Schön.
Mal gucken, wann wir den ersten Werbeclip hier verkaufen. Seid euch dann sicher?
Da kam dann richtig was bei rum. Wir verkaufen euch nicht für billig.
Wir wissen genau, wie wertvoll ihr seid.
Naja, das ist aber glaube ich auch jetzt also seine Podcast-Erfahrung und das
kann sein, dass sich das hier deckt.
Ich merke ja bei einem Live-Publikum zum Beispiel, dass es zum Teil älter wird,
also dass 60 plus vertreten ist bei Live-Veranstaltungen oder dass wir zum Beispiel
erleben, dass eine Tochter aus Hamburg mit ihrer Mutter, die aus München kommt,
dann sich in Frankfurt trifft und unseren Podcast begrüßen.
Das ist jetzt natürlich nicht die Mehrheit, aber das gibt es tatsächlich.
Und was ich zum Beispiel feststelle bei der Filmanalyse und bei Wohlstand für
alle ist, dass das Publikum jünger und weiblicher wird.
Ich glaube, diese Tendenz bei dem Ökonomischen ist ganz klar zu erkennen,
dass mehr Frauen in ökonomische Studiengänge hineingehen.
Das ist ein Grund. Und der zweite Grund ist, glaube ich,
für das Jüngerwerden ist, dass die Recherche, die heute stattfindet für Hausarbeiten,
für Hausaufgaben und all das sehr schnell über YouTube führt und dass man dann
zu einem solchen Podcast kommt, der einem zum Beispiel erklärt, was ist Freihandel.
Stimmt, absolut. Ich will nur nochmal betonen, sehr viele hören uns jetzt zu
und denken, ich war noch nie bei einer Live-Veranstaltung.
Ich habe nicht mal geguckt, wo das ist und ob es da Karten gibt und so.
Und ich habe auch noch nie einen YouTube-Kommentar geschrieben.
Eigentlich kennen die mich gar nicht. Ich bin nicht auf dem Discord-Server.
Ich habe noch nie Wolfgang angetwittert.
Ja genau, du gehörst zu 90% dieser Hörerschaft,
für die die Werbebranche jetzt so aufgeschlossen ist, weil das einfach Leute
sind, die sich nicht allzu viel jetzt darum scheren, die wollen einfach dieses
100 Podcasts in der Liste und dann hört man die halt so durch.
Also nicht die Hardcore-Superfans, die jetzt irgendwie auf Instagram uns die
ganze Zeit anschreiben und sowas, was wir ja auch mögen, aber es gibt sozusagen
diese dunkle Masse, die für die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen unerreichbar ist.
Die wissen gar nicht mehr, ah, ZDF ist nicht die ARD, gibt es da Unterschiede? So ungefähr.
So, bei uns auch nicht sichtbar, aber halt vorhanden.
Also es geht jetzt nicht sozusagen um die junge Frau, die nochmal ihre Mutter hauen.
Wie können die überhaupt Geschlechterzuweisung machen? Also viele Leute hören
ja zum Beispiel einen Podcast gar nicht angemeldet irgendwo.
Nö, also bei Spotify hat man seinen Account und dann… Gut.
Bei Spotify, aber bei YouTube hören viele Leute ja nicht, indem sie dort bei
YouTube angemeldet sind.
Ja, also ungefähr 20 Prozent der Leute hören über Spotify, was bedeutet,
wir haben sehr gute Aufklärung über unseren, also beim Fernsehen,
die GfK hat so ein oder zwei Prozent der echten Hörer als sozusagen Testpublikum,
aus denen man dann stichprobenartig hochrechnet.
Bei uns sind es 20 Prozent, also genauer kommt man gar nicht sozusagen an ein
Publikum. Ich meine, es werden einfach Plakate aufgehangen mit Werbung und dann
heißt es, ja, ja, da sind jetzt so und so viele Leute vorbeigelaufen und so
weiter, da ist irgendwie eine Berufsschule oder sowas.
Also was das angeht, haben wir wenig, aber sehr viel mehr Wissen über das Publikum als andere Medien.
Dann gehen wir jetzt in die Manosphäre und bleiben bei diesem Podcast-Thema.
Also wir machen das ja, weil so viele jetzt darüber gesprochen haben,
waren die Podcasts am Ende entscheidend für den Erfolg.
Wir hören jetzt den Taylor-Lawrence-Podcast, das ist der Power-User-Podcast. und dort war E.J.
Dixon zu Gast, eine Kollegin von Taylor Lawrence und die sprechen jetzt erstmal
so ein bisschen über die Plattform, denn wir wollen heute ein bisschen über
Meinungsfreiheit auch im Ganzen reden und ich will mal hiermit beginnen.
But I haven't seen anything even close to the amount of outrage and protests
and resistance that happened after 2016.
And I think that really bodes very poorly for us, Especially since Trump has
no guardrails this time around and it could very well be a lot worse.
So I don't know. I kind of think that people are too burnt out and too exhausted
and too depleted to really organize.
And there's also like...
A lot of leftist inviting that is also sort of contributing to it and finger pointing.
Well, also, it's a different platform landscape, right? I feel like Twitter
generally, especially in the early days of the last Trump presidency,
played such a key role for activists, even with the Black Lives Matter movement
or all of these movements, right?
Like they really emerged on Twitter and I would say sort of solidified on Twitter
in ways. Und jetzt Twitter hat sich komplett co-optet, obviously, von Elon Musk.
Ich meine, er hat es. Und pro-Trump-Messagin, in einer Weise,
dass ich nicht kann, wie es die gleichen Hub für Activism ist.
Twitter ist tot für Aktivismus, also für linken Aktivismus. Das stellen sie
erstmal fest. Ich glaube, da würden wir alle nicht widersprechen.
Aber wir haben ein neues Twitter. Ja, Blue Sky. Fühlt sich genau an,
wie es genau das ist, was ich immer wieder gesucht habe, jetzt seit Elon Musk das gekauft hat.
Schon allein, weil es jetzt mit Zill so ein Nassel gibt, wo du einfach deinen
Account zur Verfügung stellst und der sucht dann für dich die Links raus,
die deine, also den Dufoils und deren Blase sozusagen, das ist so toll,
also steigt sozusagen auch den IQ der Salonlektüren jetzt wieder,
dadurch, dass wir jetzt wieder mit Blue Sky endlich mal eine Alternative haben.
Ich bin gespannt. Jetzt spricht DJ Dixon über TikTok.
I would even go so far as to say that the entire social media ecosystem has
been radicalized to a pretty significant degree by the right.
Even if you look on ostensibly leftist or leftist skewing.
Platforms like TikTok, it basically prioritizes the content that you are most
likely to engage with and the content that you're most likely to find interesting.
So it just sort of perpetuates this echo chamber that is happening on the left
and on the right, regardless of what your political affiliation is.
Das ist deine Argumentation, die wir eben schon mal gehört haben.
Ja, da bekommst du immer nur was ausgewählt und dann bist du eher in so einer Echo-Kammer.
Jetzt widerspricht dem Taylor Lawrence.
I guess, to me, TikTok, I always kind of push back on that a little bit.
Because I think the duet feature and the replies feature, like there is a lot
of dialogue that happens on TikTok that, for instance, you never get on somewhere
like Instagram or YouTube.
And TikTok feels much more Twitter-like in that way.
Where it's like, sure, do people go down, you know, follow all the people or
engage with all the people that they want? Yes.
Like, but we all know what it's like to be on the wrong side of TikTok, right?
Or like when your content leaves its little bubble. And it does happen a lot,
especially with posts that have to do with politics, because you immediately
have people from the other side stitching or duetting them.
I've actually noticed that it happens much less than it used to.
Also Taylor Lawrence sagt schon mal, naja, da gibt es aber schon eigentlich
Debatte und Austausch und man sieht doch etwas anders.
Und dann kommt sie auf was für mich ganz Entscheidendes zu sprechen,
wenn wir jetzt über Meinungsfreiheit reden.
Wir haben jetzt diese Debatten noch alle im Ohr aus Deutschland.
Vieles importiert von den USA, dass man sagt, ja, diese sozialen Medien,
die vergiften den politischen Diskurs.
Und ich halte diese Debatte für zum einen richtig, weil wir sie,
ja, die Effekte beobachten können, diese Diskursvergiftung.
Zum anderen möchte ich hochhalten, dass diese sozialen Medien ganz wichtig sind
für die politische Bildung und dass dort oft bessere politische Bildung stattfinden kann.
Nur gibt es jetzt ein anderes Problem und auf das kommt Taylor Lawrence zu sprechen.
Really? Much, much less. Yeah.
I think there's actually less political discussion on TikTok generally.
But also, both political parties have sort of worked together to push these
platforms to censor political speech.
This is why Meta now downrights all speech from journalists and
activists and TikTok is very similar to
where it's I think suppressed a lot of political content like one thing
that I think people in power whether they're Democrats or Republicans
seem to be able to agree on is that they want less online activism and less
speech and we've seen that throughout the Trump and Biden presidencies alike
and I do think it's concerning when we look at our social media landscape these
apps that were originally sort of ushered in with things like The Arab Spring, right?
People talking about their liberatory nature.
Now you can't even say the word feminism on threads without getting downranked.
Das ist eigentlich das, was stattfindet. Politiker sind gar nicht daran interessiert,
dass irgendein Aktivismus dort groß stattfindet, egal von welcher Seite aus
er kommt oder sagen wir besser, die Regierenden wollen dies nicht und wir sehen auch,
wie diese Plattformen, also gerade die politischen Inhalte sehr schlecht ranken,
beziehungsweise muss man in den Einstellungen zum Beispiel bei Instagram erst
etwas ändern, damit man auch politisches angezeigt bekommt,
weshalb zum Beispiel dann unsere Posts auch weniger gesehen werden.
Hier auch nochmal der Aufruf, bitte den Podcast zu posten in den sozialen Medien,
weil das tatsächlich schwer ist, überhaupt mit politischen Inhalten stattzufinden.
Und da sehe ich eine ganz große Gefahr drin, dass man also durch dieses Muting, das da stattfindet,
eigentlich die Meinungsfreiheit ganz, ja, klannendes Team einschränken kann,
ohne dass das als große Debatte wahrgenommen werden kann, weil es ja gar nicht gesehen wird.
Das Runterfahren von politischer Debatte halte ich selber für gar nicht so problematisch.
Aber wenn jetzt zum Beispiel wir schlechter gerankt werden, weil wir über Politik
reden, wenn wir jetzt einen Podcast hätten, in dem wir uns einfach über irgendeinen
Unsinn austauschen würden, besser gerankt werden.
Das ist doch ein großes politisches Problem, wenn man das macht.
Also…,
Frei der antifaschistischen Wirtschaftspolitik, würde ich sagen,
gibt es auch antifaschistisches Medienverhalten.
Nämlich, ich möchte gerne, nur wenn ich einkaufen gehe, mit Lebenskosten belästigt
werden und dann brauche ich ganz viele Sphären, in denen Preis keine Rolle spielt.
Wie zum Beispiel der Park, der Garten, was auch immer, der Stadtteilplatz oder
so, sollte bitte ohne Eintrittskosten einfach zur Verfügung stehen.
Also diese Third Places, was auch immer, das Entökonomisieren des öffentlichen
Raumes ist da so eine Doktrin.
Für mediales Verhalten, ich nutze sehr wenig TikTok. Wenn ich TikTok nutze,
dann wirklich nur, um Zeit zu vertreiben und da stört mich Politik und ich bin
wirklich ein sehr politisch interessierter Mensch und ich rede sehr gerne über
Politik, aber ich will nicht auf TikTok Politik erfahren.
Aber das kannst du dir ja, das kannst du ja in dem Sinne machen,
dass du sagst, ich folge jetzt nur bei TikTok Leuten, die nichts Politisches machen.
Folgen. Also dieses Follower-Prinzip hat sich vollständig überlebt.
Oder auch der Algorithmus erkennt ja.
Wenn du jetzt nur Modern Talking... Ja, und es ist ja auch so.
Der Algorithmus spielt für mich Politik runter.
Nein, aber es ist ja was anderes. Also bei Instagram ist es ja definitiv so
und bei YouTube zum Teil auch und auch bei TikTok, dass politische Inhalte,
also wenn dort gewisse Worte vorkommen, wie zum Beispiel Feminismus,
hat ja Taylor Lawrence gerade erwähnt, dass dann,
grundsätzlich das weniger Leuten angezeigt wird.
Ja, aber wir sind ja in Europa gerade in einer sehr besonderen Situation.
Aber du musst doch darin Probleme erkennen.
Na, ich will mal eine historische Klammer aufmachen. In den 70er Jahren war
völlig klar, für Politik interessiere ich mich eine Viertelstunde am Tag.
Wenn ich überhaupt die Tagesschau wahrnehme oder morgens kurz Zeitung lese.
Der Rest des Tages keine Politik.
In Amerika ist es mittlerweile so, dass die Leute keine Lust mehr haben auf Politik.
Was bedeutet, im amerikanischen Wahlkampf gibt es Szenerien,
dass zwei Menschen miteinander über die kommende Präsidentschaftswahl reden.
Und die ganze Zeit auf so einem Level bleiben wie...
Das wird wirklich krass, oder? Na, mal gucken, was passiert.
Na ja, mal gucken, ob sich dann alles wieder beruhigt, wie auch immer,
weil jetzt gerade finde ich es wirklich, das ist schon, also die Wahl ist echt wichtig, ne? Ja, ja.
Dann gehen die beiden auseinander und keiner hat erfahren, wie der andere eigentlich,
also zu welchem Lager der gehört.
Das heißt, wir haben selbst im politischen Diskurs eine Entpolitisierung,
die im Nahkampf einfach auf diesen Fakt reagiert, dass es sehr unnatürlich ist,
politische Themen, die immer existenziell sind, die ganze Zeit mitschleifen zu lassen.
Das ist ja wie so eine Paarbeziehung, die einfach nie das Paarsein lebt,
sondern in jeder Minute immer gewahr sein muss, dass es jetzt aber gerade um
die Beziehung selbst geht, also so ein Metadiskurs führt und das ist nicht gut.
Aber du sagst doch selbst, dass gewisse Themen größer gespielt werden müssen.
Ja, aber nicht überall.
Ja, aber in den sozialen Medien sind ja die Leute, die werden ja nicht morgen die FRZ abonnieren.
Ja, aber wir sagen ja auch nicht das Fernsehen und meinen dann gleichzeitig
Frauentausch auf RTL 2 am Nachmittag in der Woche und Sonntagabend die politische
Berichterstattung in der ARD.
Ja, aber es geht doch darum, ob man eine Programmierung so gestaltet,
dass generell Inhalte mit politischen Begriffen weniger Klicks bekommen sollen.
Das ist ja die Programmierung von TikTok und Instagram.
Und das ist doch eine schlechte Entwicklung. Dann sollen die Leute doch selbst
entscheiden. Also ich würde, wenn ich zum Beispiel nichts über Ungleichheit
wissen will, dann folge ich nicht Martina Linertas, weil die mich darüber aufklärt.
Nur wenn ich Martina Linertas folge.
Dann möchte ich auch von ihr die Storys angezeigt bekommen und nicht bekomme
ich nur, wenn sie mal ein Foto von sich macht, das angezeigt,
aber wenn sie auf eine Armutsstatistik hinweist,
dann sagt Instagram, oh, das ist aber ein politischer Inhalt,
das braucht der Herr Schmidt jetzt mal nicht zu sehen.
Da sehe ich doch diese Art von Zensur, die stattfindet und das bedeutet dann nämlich,
dass sich der vorpolitische Raum, der scheinbar unpolitisch ist,
aber in Wahrheit nicht ist, wie wir gleich sehen werden, sich immer weiter ausbreitet
und dann brauchen nur die Leute, wie wir jetzt gleich hören werden,
wie Trump und so weiter einmal den vorpolitischen Raum zu betreten.
Einmal zu sagen, hier, ich bin hier im Podcast, mit mir könnt ihr labern und
dann werden sie gewählt.
Es geht ja eigentlich darum.
Eine richtige Politisierung stattzufinden, nicht diese komischen Zankereien,
die jetzt medial reportiert werden.
Und das ist nämlich das eigentliche Problem.
Nein, aber das Problem beginnt ja da, wenn ich überhaupt eine solche Reglementierung mache,
dass ich sage, also wer nochmal das Höschen auszieht, wird hochgerenkt und wer
aber zum Beispiel über Ungleichheit reden will, der wird schlechter gerenkt,
egal ob Leute da vorher dran interessiert sind oder nicht.
Aber also wenn das das Problem ist, möchte ich es gerne dramatisieren,
in der Hinsicht ganz konkret über Twitter kurz zu reden, denn Twitter gilt ja
bei uns immer noch als das soziale Netzwerk, in dem Kurznachrichten geschickt werden,
was nicht der Fall ist, denn bei Twitter werden eben einige politische Botschaften
runtergerankt und andere hoch, was bedeutet, Twitter, liebe deutsche Journalisten, liebe Politiker,
hat sich jetzt in den amerikanischen Staatsfunk verwandelt.
Wenn Habeck sagt, ich bin jetzt wieder bei Twitter, frage ich mich,
ja, würdest du dir auch einen Account bei RT Deutsch machen,
weil da ist ja auch Publikum und da kann man ja nicht die ganzen Russlandfreunde alleine lassen.
Also da finde ich, wenn es sozusagen, du hast ja eben schon gesagt,
die richtigen und die falschen politischen Themen gerankt werden.
Wenn einfach grundsätzlich das Politikniveau runtergedimmt wird,
um zu sagen, auch über Politik informiere ich woanders.
Jetzt läuft mit denn das. Nein, das ist völlig falsch. Also bei Twitter sehe
ich natürlich das Problem, dass die das Rechte pushen.
Und wir das ja jederzeit schon sehen können.
Aber wenn ich sage, ich dimme politisches runter,
obwohl es existent ist und obwohl Leute denen folgen, obwohl Leute sagen,
ich will Jean-Philippe Kittler hören,
und dann wird es nicht angezeigt, weil dort ein Begriff wie Feminismus vorkommt
in seiner Ansprache, Dann bedeutet das ein Eingriff in die Meinungsfreiheit.
Das stimmt.
Und dieser Eingriff suggeriert auch noch, als wäre das, was man stattdessen zeigt, unpolitisch.
Es ist aber, wie wir jetzt hören werden, eben nicht unpolitisch,
sondern es wird mir dann zum Beispiel was aus der Manosphere angezeigt.
Die ist nicht unpolitisch, auch wenn die sagen, ich erzähle dir heute mal nur
was über Essen oder so, sondern wir merken ja, dass da eine Politisierung entsteht.
Wir hören jetzt im Taylor-Lawrence-Podcast Josh Citarella.
The Manosphere refers to a large variety of channels, primarily male influencers
who are giving advice about how to date women, how to exercise,
business advice, starting your small business, opening up a dropshipping scam, stuff like this.
It's a very large culture. It encompasses a lot of different perspectives,
some of them extremely conservative, misogynistic, too big of a space to really
summarize all together.
Yeah, there's a lot of, I feel like, cast of characters around here.
We've got Andrew Tate. He's sort of the perennial, like, male lifestyle influencer,
of course, accused of sex trafficking. He's super misogynistic.
But then it also trickles down to people like the Nelk Boys,
right, who are like prank YouTubers.
And then you've got the comedy world that I think is sort of adjacent to this,
the Joe Rogans, the Theo Vons.
Ja, alles ist diese Sphäre dieser Männer, die sich dort treffen.
Citarella, der sich seit Jahr und Tag mit dieser Sphäre auseinandersetzt,
problematisiert mal den Begriff.
This is part of the problem with the term Manosphere, because a few years ago
that meant people who were part of the like capital A, capital R,
alt-right, people who had really reprehensible worldviews.
But now it kind of extends to the soft cultural stuff, including like the Nelk
Boys and comedians and stuff like this.
I would say that we're kind of watching a shift into something that the writer
Max Reed has described as the Zinternet,
which is just a subculture of young men who are interested in sports and betting
and light beer and those Zin nicotine pouches. und sie lieben wirklich Comedy-Stuff.
Es ist nur ein Mannes Interesse und es ist nicht besonders eine klare,
explizite Ideologie, einfach ein generelles, commonsense-Konservatismus.
Es gibt also eine reale Gradierung von Stuff-System, das ist in der Overton-Winnow,
regularer Politik, und dann Stuff-System, das ist extrem.
Und das Problem ist, dass wir die Single-Term-Man-Sphere nutzen,
um alle Gemeinden, die sehr unterschiedlich sind.
Das finde ich schon mal sehr gut, dass er da differenziert, dass man jetzt also
nicht so tut, dass alle Männer, die sich irgendwo treffen, ein Problem darstellen.
Aber er zeigt jetzt, wie man erstmal in diese Sphäre gelangt.
What draws people into the manosphere? I mean, is it ideology?
Is it a sense of community? Like, what makes this broader group of content creators,
podcasters, etc., appealing to young men?
A lot of them get into it through self-help, oddly enough.
You know, it's a very reasonable thing, looking into self-improvement,
into workout advice, into presentation, how to groom yourself, how to dress.
Da gibt es sehr wenig content, die sich geärende an Young-Menn betrifft,
aber das nicht auch diese politischen Positionen gibt.
So, die Leute in die Kultur sind durch eine Art Kulturelle, wo sie sich für
Selbst-Help oder Ausgleichs-Advice suchen.
Und dann, nachdem das ein paar Jahre später, da gibt es all diese Dinge,
die sie auf den Weg picken.
Das ist noch kein politischer Raum erstmal. Man fragt sich, was soll ich essen?
Wie kriege ich mehr Muskeln?
Das sind die Fragen, die sich dann stellen. Aber dann geht das so weiter.
Dann gibt es irgendwann eine Beschäftigung damit, warum kriege ich keine ab
und an wem wird es wohl liegen.
Und dann sind auch immer keine Politikernamen oder irgendetwas gefallen.
Aber es geht schon in so eine gewisse Richtung.
Nun kommt Trump als Akteur.
Trump tapped into the manosphere so heavily during this campaign.
How much do you think it really helped him?
I mean, it's kind of impossible to tell. I certainly feel like it did have a big influence.
We would be, I think, hard-pressed to find the total number of people who decided
to change their vote one way or another or decided to come out and vote as a
result of hearing him on a podcast.
We have an enormous amount of data for how many people that they reach.
My perspective on this stuff is that if you're looking for the gate over whether
someone makes their voting decision towards option A or option B,
you're missing the forest for the trees.
These are processes that start eight, ten years before where people are slowly
acculturated to political ideas.
So it's not like they heard it from an influencer and then decided to go out
and vote that afternoon.
They have been listening to these opinions for almost a decade and that has
shaped their worldview as a result.
It's a very kind of soft and slow approach if you're looking through the cultural lens.
Trump hat es nur noch eingesammelt. Also das wurde vorbereitet.
Wir können das jetzt ehrlich sehen, wenn Christian Lindner bei Tim Gabel ist.
Tim Gabel ist mit Fitnessvideos berühmt geworden oder irgendwelchen anderen Beratungen,
die er jungen Männern gibt und dann wird er hin und wieder mal so eine politische
Note setzen und sagen, die Steuern sind ja auch viel zu hoch und so ein paar
Punkte machen und das sickert so über Jahre bei den Hörern ein.
Und jetzt tritt Christian Lindner auf und sagt, ich bin einer von euch,
ihr habt euch immer gefragt, wen sollt ihr wählen, wählt doch einfach mich. So funktioniert es.
Insbesondere, da gibt es ja die interessanten, wie ist sein Name,
ich weiß nicht genau, aber er hat ein Buch über Sucht geschrieben,
über Isolation und so weiter und da ging es um Connection.
Also Sucht ist das Gegenteil von Connection. Man gibt sich einer materiellen
Sucht hin, also Tabletten oder so, weil einem eigentlich das soziale Aufgehebensgefühl fehlt.
Und diese Manosphere ist sozusagen die immaterielle Sucht.
Also man hängt sich so an eine Idee an, sobald man YouTube aufmacht,
sind da einfach acht Empfehlungen für Videos aus dieser Richtung,
man ist so richtig Rabbit Hole und so. Aber man darf immer wieder,
also ich finde die acht Jahre, die ihr jetzt genannt habt, sind mir ein bisschen zu lang.
Denn typischerweise, glaube ich, haben wir es hier mit einer Art Jugendkultur
zu tun, aus der man auch wieder rauswächst, nämlich dann, wenn sich die Lebensumstände ändern.
Also wenn man plötzlich auf Kollegen trifft, auf einen Chef oder auf einem Datingmarkt,
wo man merkt, es funktioniert irgendwie anders.
Also die Erfahrung scheint doch zu sein, man hat eine erste Beziehung und dann
eine zweite und bei der dritten fragt man sich schon, warum man die erste so
geführt hat, wie man sie geführt hat, weil einfach ein Lernprozess stattfindet.
Also die Wege in die Menno Sphere sind sehr gut nachgezeichnet,
aber es gibt wohl auch Wege aus der Menno Sphere, bei denen diejenigen,
die hier versuchen, die Leute zu halten, doch sehr viel machen müssen,
von dem sie noch nicht genau wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Ich habe das gestern im Büro gehört von Mary, die hat aus ihrem Freundinnenkreis
eine kurze Szene, ich schildere sie mal, ich glaube nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwelche
Sachen oder so, aber es ist wohl so.
Dass mittlerweile so 34-jährige Frauen nicht mehr im gleichen,
sagen wir mal, Generationsmilieu daten, wenn sie eine feste Beziehung suchen,
weil sie eher so bei den 26-Jährigen jetzt Männer finden.
Die in ihr Dating-Profil schon reinschreiben, ich suche eine feste Partnerschaft.
Statt irgendwie die ganze Zeit, ah nee, ich kann mich nicht binden,
keine Ahnung, ich will irgendwie und so weiter, weißt du? Was so 35-Jährige anscheinend machen.
Was ich interessant fand, weil wenn hier immer von jungen Männern gesprochen
wird, würde ich als Soziologe sagen, es macht einen ganz großen Unterschied,
ob man mit jungen Männern jetzt 34-Jährige oder 26-Jährige oder 22-Jährige meint.
Je nachdem, welche Erfahrung die auch mit dem anderen Geschlecht jeweils gemacht haben.
Denn die Manosphere heißt nicht ohne Grund Manosphere, weil die Frauen darin keine Rolle spielen.
Die Frauen finden aber im Alltag, spielen die eine ganz wichtige Rolle,
selbst wenn sie nicht die Freundin sind, sondern nur ich schwärme für irgendwen
oder keine Ahnung, ich wünsche mir auch mal eine Freundin, es sollte doch jetzt mal klappen.
Weil die Enttäuschung darüber, dass die YouTube-Videos anscheinend nicht den
richtigen Weg leiten, der stellt sich relativ zügig ein.
Also nicht nach acht Jahren und dann, oh keine Ahnung und überhaupt und so,
dann ist man erst richtig drin.
Nach acht Jahren bleiben vielleicht die Hardcore-Leute hängen,
aber da sind schon 70% wieder rausgespielt aus dieser Menos 4,
weil sie dann feststellen, wenn ich abends auf eine Party gehe und ich wünsche
mir, dass da noch andere Leute sind.
Insbesondere des anderen Geschlechts komme ich hier mit meiner Menosphäre-Attitüde
einfach gar nicht weiter.
Nicht nur im Sinne von, ich komme hier nicht weiter, sondern ich muss sie wirklich verstecken.
Also wenn du da Andrew Tate als Namen nennst, wirst du sofort rausgeschmissen.
Das ist die Party für dich einfach zu Ende. Und das darf man hier nicht unterschätzen.
Ja, ich habe den Eindruck aber, dass die doch länger hält, diese Menosphäre-Phase.
Für diesen radikalen Kern, ja. Aber bedeutet eben… Naja.
Joe Rogan, die Joe Rogan-Hörer, ist das ein radikaler Kern? Das scheint mir
zumindest ein sehr großer Kern zu sein.
Nein, aber 10% der Joe Rogan-Hörer sind ein radikaler Kern. Und 10% der Joe
Rogan-Hörer sind schon mehrere hunderttausend Menschen.
Und die können ein Phänomen so prägen, dass man in Podcasts unendlich lange
darüber spricht, obwohl man damit noch keine Aussage über die 85 Prozent der
anderen Männer diesen Alters irgendeine Aussage trifft.
Naja, das gilt selbstverständlich jetzt nicht für alle, aber du hast ja eben
gesagt, du findest das gar nicht schlimm, wenn das Politische runtergedimmt wird.
Wir hatten hier mal Mark Zuckerberg gespielt, wie er sagte, er will nicht mehr
das Politische so stark haben.
Und da sehen wir ja schon die Ideologie, die da drin steckt,
nämlich Mark Zuckerberg ist jemand, der sich jetzt als Trump-Anhänger zeigt
und für die ihn bedeutet, dass wir machen, wir sind unpolitisch,
aber wir sind Trump-Anhänger.
Ja, das ist so, ich, also das gibt es ja nicht.
Also man kann nicht unpolitisch sein und Trump-Anhänger sein.
Und das ist aber genau das, was da passiert.
Und Joe Rogan stellt tatsächlich hier das Richtige fest. Oder er fragt es zumindest.
Nämlich ist J.D. Vance ja bei ihm zu Gast. Und dann sagt Joe Rogan Folgendes.
Well, Zuckerberg has gotten really into mixed martial arts. He's gotten really
into Jiu-Jitsu and really into training.
And there's very few things that will turn you into a conservative more than martial arts training.
There's no way to get ahead other than Also.
Der vorpolitische Raum wird hier über Sport hergestellt und der ist dann politisch hoch aufgeladen.
Also Mark Zuckerberg macht jetzt da diese Kämpfe und damit ist das aber auch
gleich ein Ausdruck dessen, dass er jetzt politisch sich in eine andere Richtung entwickelt hat.
J.D. Vance pflichtet dem bei.
Well, have you seen all these studies that basically connect testosterone levels
in young men with conservative politics?
Oh, yeah. So maybe that's what's going on. Well, there's a certain amount of
it. Maybe that's why the Democrats want us all to be, you know,
poor health and overweight is because that means that we're going to be – no,
it means we're going to be more liberal, right?
Right. If you make people less healthy, they apparently become more politically liberal.
Das ist der Dispurs.
Der da geführt wird. Der Testosteron-Gehalt ist Thema von tausenden YouTube-Videos
und das muss dann nur ganz latent verknüpft werden mit etwas Politischem,
nämlich der Aussage Kamala Harris.
Die raubt dir dein Testosteron, Donald Trump steigert es und dann ist die Wahlentscheidung da.
Ja, all diese Selbstoptimierungsthemen der Menosphäre sind Themen,
die mich total interessieren.
Trotzdem würde ich mich jetzt nicht als Opfer der Menosphäre sehen.
Richtig.
Ich will nochmal Zahlen nennen.
Aber weil du eine andere Sozialisierung hast, weil du einen ganz anderen Background hast.
Ja, ich bin schon ziemlich genau Menosphäre zwischen 30 und 45.
Aber von deinem ganzen Werdegang. Also die Leute haben ja nicht das studiert,
was du studiert hast, die sind dann nicht Podcaster geworden und waren bei der FAZ.
Das ist ja, du ragst da ja raus. Deswegen kannst du wahrscheinlich ohne größere
Sorge dir zehn Videos ansehen, da wirst du danach nicht Donald Trump gut finden,
wirst aber vielleicht wissen,
wie man Eierspeisen zubereitet, um den Proteingehalt zu steigern.
Also, ich höre dich und ich fühle auch sehr viele Hörerinnen und Hörer,
die sich gerade so ein bisschen hier einem Phänomen ausgeliefert fühlen,
weil das sind ja nicht nur Leute, die ein Medienspektakel machen,
sondern die sind ja jetzt auch Präsident.
Nur, lass mich trotzdem dieser, die haben eine Selbstbeschreibung von sich,
die wir gerade über diese Podcasts vermitteln, hören und die wir besprechen,
lass mich trotzdem eine Fremdbeschreibung dem gegenüberstellen.
Denn wir haben es hier mit einem Phänomen zu tun, das droht,
die ganze Gesellschaft zu übernehmen.
Wir hören ja J.D. Vance, wir hatten das auch bei dem Parteitag der Republikaner,
die sind ja rausgegangen auf die Bühne und haben gesagt, der Zeitgeist ist unser.
Wir müssen hier gar nichts machen, nur abwarten.
Das Testosteron regelt den Rest. Wir müssen gar nicht debattieren,
selbst wenn wir auf der Bühne sind und sagen, they are eating our cats and dogs
und so, ist das sozusagen ein zu kräftiges Argument.
Aber die Wahl in Amerika ging so aus, 48,35 zu 49,96 Prozent.
Was bedeutet, hier steht es auf der Kippe. Hier lohnt sich auch politische Diskussion,
denn hier kann man durchaus, wenn man nur 5 Prozent intellektuell erreicht und
damit eine Meinungsänderung herbeiführt, reicht das schon, um hier etwas zu drehen.
Und jetzt möchte ich gerne sagen, worüber zu diskutieren ist und zwar so.
Dass die Diskussion von alleine funktioniert, dass sie nicht,
der Lehrer steht vorne und sagt, komm jetzt lass uns mal über Politik,
ich weiß es ist nervig, sondern nein, es ist so, dass es von alleine funktioniert.
Wir haben jetzt das Phänomen, dass in Amerika, gut, neue Präsidenten,
deswegen auch dieser riesige Auswahlprozess, da kommt dann irgendwie,
ich komme aus Arizona und jetzt räume ich in Washington auf.
Also dieses gegen das Establishment sein funktioniert immer. Das ist zu kräftig.
Das Establishment ist jetzt Donald Trump und zwar kann er sich wirklich nicht dagegen wehren.
Er hat den Kongress auf seiner Seite, alle thematisieren das,
vor allem die Typen selbst.
Die Selbstgewissheit, die wir hier gerade raushören, ist ja,
wir sind das neue Establishment.
Dass sie eigentlich als Schwungfeder den Kampf gegen das Establishment brauchen, es ist keins mehr da.
Und die Amerikaner stellen jetzt gerade fest, ich wollte auf die Straße gehen
und protestieren und ich weiß gar nicht gegen wen. Es ist ja nur noch Trump da.
Es sind ja gar keine Demokraten da. Wir haben ja aus den Ländern dort schon,
wie die Demokraten schon gar nicht mehr antreten und so.
Also politischer Protest wird sich in den nächsten Jahren automatisch gegen
die Republikaner richten.
Und zwar vor allem gegen die, die man nur aus dem Fernsehen kennt,
was nochmal ein Katalysator ist.
Zweitens, wir haben, so, das war nur erstens. Jetzt kommt zweitens.
Wir haben eine politische Diskussion, wir haben sie eben auch schon geführt,
wo wir sagten, und wir werden es strapazieren mit der antifaschistischen Wirtschaftspolitik
von Isabella Weber, die vor allem über Preiskontrollen läuft.
Es stimmt, das zu kräftigste Argument war, den Leuten ist es im Laden zu teuer.
Die Ideologien darüber, scheißegal, wenn das Essen zu teuer ist,
ist das Essen zu teuer. Wenn die Miete zu hoch ist, ist die Miete zu hoch.
So, die Republikaner stellen sich jetzt gerade den Auftrag, den Leuten zu vermitteln,
weil billiger wird es ja nicht werden.
Also dafür sind einfach die Profitgedanken in Amerika zu groß.
Die werden sich immer gegenseitig ausrauben.
Es ist sozusagen eine Verkäuferangebotsinflation, wie Isabella Weber sagt.
Jemand hat die Preise so hoch gemacht.
Die Republikaner stellen gerade nur Milliardäre in der Regierung ein.
So, von mir aus kann man 2024 sagen, Trump hat gewonnen, weil die Butter zu teuer war.
Aber wenn jetzt vier Jahre lang Milliardäre für den Butterpreis verantwortlich sind,
politisch und jeden Tag im Fernsehen, in allen Podcasts präsent,
in allen TikTok-Videos, kann man wirklich glauben, dass die in vier Jahren,
falls es dann eine neue Wahl gibt, das Argument aufrechterhalten,
wir Milliardäre haben es leider nicht geschafft, die Butter billiger zu machen,
aber glaubt uns, wir wollten es wirklich, gebt uns nochmal die Chance.
Das will ich erstmal sehen.
Ne, das glaube ich ja gar nicht, aber das widerspricht ja nicht den Thesen,
die hier vorgebracht werden. Also die These, die ja hier vorgebracht wird, ist ja eine ganz simple.
Wir stehen für Testosteron.
Alle Männer, Und ich sage, die Subkotanen sind widersprechend.
Ja, dass das nicht ewig funktioniert, das ist ja vollkommen klar.
Das möchte ich gerne betont haben, dass das nicht vollkommen klar ist,
dass das ein Selbstläufer ist, diese Menospiere, die es jetzt gesehen haben.
Nein, aber dass das jetzt gerade funktioniert, Wir hatten folgenden Diskurs,
ich habe es sehr genau beobachtet auf Twitter von Journalisten in Deutschland, zur Diskussion.
Krönung von Kamala Harris, seht
her, da ist sie. Und jetzt gibt sie die Interviews, sie ist in der Burg.
Das alles. Und was hat man dann über Trump gesagt?
Ja, Trump sitzt nur noch mit so komischen Twitch-Streamern und Podcastern zusammen.
Aber das war am Ende sehr ausschlaggebend, wie ja gerade Scott Galloway nochmal betont hat.
Also das ist ja nicht zu leugend, was da in vier Jahren sein wird und dass da
Enttäuschungen sein werden. Gewiss, anders kann es ja gar nicht kommen.
Nur jetzt hat es funktioniert. Und ich glaube, es funktioniert durch diese Art von Ansprache.
Lass uns mal springen nochmal zu Citarella und dieser Fehleinschätzung auch der Liberalen.
Vielen Dank. ist, dass sie überwunden sind, dass sie überwunden sind,
und dass sie nicht bemerkt, oder zu retten, oder zu bringen,
oder zu einem politischen Koalitionskollegen haben.
Ich habe viele Jahre gesagt, dass wenn Sie nicht diese Entwicklungen in Internet-Culture
gefallen sind, dann ist es Ihr job, und versuchen diese Leute zu überzeugen.
Sie müssen sie mit ihnen engagieren.
Wenn Sie die Gemeinschafts-De-Platformen, sie werden wirklich schlimmer.
Und wir können quantitativlich prove das durch Studien, an dieser Stelle.
Ja, De-Plattforming hat dazu geführt, dass dann sowas wie KICK und wie das alles
heißt entstanden ist, wo es noch viel verrückter zugeht als bei Twitch zum Beispiel.
Jetzt kommt Taylor Lawrence auf Andrew Tate zu sprechen und betont das Ökonomische.
Especially with Andrew Tate, who sort of...
The pinnacle Manosphere-Influencer in the sense that he's just the most misogynistic
and maybe the most awful.
But in 2021, he started this thing called Hustlers University,
where he was sort of teaching people, allegedly, how to make money online.
And so much of this Manosphere world is not just about betterment in terms of
working out in the gym or getting ripped. It's also about making money.
Do you think economic insecurity among young men and teenagers also feeds people
into this more like radicalized section of the internet.
I mean, I feel like a broken record because I've been saying that for eight years.
Yeah, I would say that's one of the primary drivers.
You know, people are like, okay, Andrew
Tate is teaching people how to do dropshipping scams on the internet.
And then they forget to ask the primary question that even brings people to
look for that material in the first place, which is like, why can't you find
dignified, high-paying work in the richest country in the world? Give me a break.
Ja, also was hier drinsteckt ist, bevor du dich auf einem Feld gut bewegen kannst,
ist mein Ratschlag aus der Menosphäre, also ich bin jetzt Andrew Tate,
erklär es mal die anderen zu Gegnern. Die Frauen sind deine Gegner.
Versuch nicht auf einer sozusagen, sondern wende Tricks an.
Spiele mit ihnen und so weiter. Und das korreliert ganz scharf mit diesem,
ach du bist politisch unzufrieden, ja dann erklär erst mal die anderen zu den
Gegnern, die Demokraten, der beiden, das Weiße Haus.
Nur der Wahlkampf und die Politik danach muss man hier wirklich getrennt beobachten.
Denn das, was wir jetzt besprechen, ja, so kann man Präsident werden.
Oder von mir aus eine Frau erobern, diese eine Nacht. Aber so kann man nicht
eine Beziehung gestalten.
Und so kann man auch nicht selber das Establishment in politischen Systemen
sein, ohne Gegnerschaft.
Ja, mir brauchst du das nicht zu sagen. Ich höre mir das ja an.
Ich will nur die Zäsur markieren.
Als eine Warnung vor dem, was uns hier droht. Also das, ich höre das ja jetzt gar nicht.
Mich interessiert ja das Schicksal der Amerikaner ein bisschen weniger als mein eigenes.
Und ich sehe ja einfach hier, dass es in so eine Richtung immer stärker geht
und so ein Auftritt von Lindner bei Tim Gabel ist erst der Anfang und wir sehen
ja auch, wie Maximilian Krasig bei TikTok,
präsentieren konnte und diese Sachen werden weiterhin zunehmen.
Ja, aber der Unterschied ist ja, Lindner kann ja wirklich,
Das politische System zu seinem Gegner erklären, was die nicht mehr können.
Ja, das weiß ich ja, aber die sind jetzt aber dummerweise an der Macht.
Ich will ja nicht, dass hier auch ähnliche Gestalten an die Macht kommen.
Und was ja hier noch mit drin steckt und das ist für mich das Entscheidende ist,
Taylor Lawrence sagt, ja, das ist ein ganz schlimmer Frauenfeind,
aber der hat ja dann neben diesem frauenfeindlichen Inhalt irgendwelche Businessmodelle
den Leuten, den Männern angeboten, Dropship-Verfahren und so weiter.
Und dann sagt ja Citarella, ja, das ist das, was ich seit acht Jahren sage.
Man kann nicht nur über Dropship-Verfahren lachen, sondern man muss sich erklären,
wie kann es denn eigentlich sein, dass so etwas überhaupt beliebt wird,
dass Leute wissen wollen, wie sie so Geld verdienen. Und er sagt folgendes.
So, the inability to talk about the class question that is destroying the lives,
the upward mobility of many of these young men, the degree to which the legacy
media is uncomfortable in talking about that, like, this is the problem.
We've put the cart in front of the horse if we're going to blame these people
for harnessing an audience that is interested in their material because they've
been disappointed by the legacy structures.
So I think there is a larger political economic shift that is far more effective
in de-radicalizing or persuading people than trying to de-platform these horrible
influencers, which I completely disagree with and have no sympathy for them.
Das System hat ihnen nichts anzubieten und wir haben hier mal im Podcast sehr
ausführlich über Roblox gesprochen. Wer will, kann das nochmal nachhören.
Das ist eine Plattform, auf der junge Leute sich tummeln, so ab elf,
zwölf Jahren. Dort können sie eigene Business-Modelle entwerfen,
sie können dort Unternehmer werden und hier kommt auch der richtige Punkt von Citarella.
Also man ist erst schon mal Unternehmer, so ist die Ideologie.
Und wenn du es nicht bist, dann sympathisierst du aber zumindest mit Unternehmern
wie Montana Black oder Tim Gabel.
Und dann erst später wirst du Wähler sein. Und als Wähler wirst du unternehmerisch
entscheiden, also Trump wählen oder Lindner wählen. In diese Richtung geht das.
Und jetzt, glaube ich, ist auch nochmal eine Kritik an den Linken angebracht
und Taylor Lawrence bringt es mit ein.
I guess when we also think about Democrats and young men, I want to go back
again to 2020, because this is when you had Bernie on Rogan, right?
I think he went on actually end of 2019. But you had this moral panic in the
media of the Bernie bro, right? where there was toxic young men are supporting
progressives and Bernie and they're toxic and they're male.
And a lot of young progressives felt alienated from the Democratic Party.
These sort of cisgender straight men felt that they were being pushed down or
their voices weren't supposed to be heard. This is this critique.
How much of that critique do you think is real? And do you think the Democratic
Party kind of abandoned young straight men?
I mean, it is a extraordinarily weird period because I've gotten shit for being
a Bernie bro for eight years,
basically up until last week when the predominant narrative became that we need
more left wing podcasters who are going to talk to young men.
So it's a pretty big narrative flip that's kind of hard to grasp.
I would say that young men are quantitatively one large demographic that are
not being spoken to by the current iteration of the Democratic Party.
If there were a labor constituency in the Democratic Party, it would be speaking to them.
You don't have to message to people just based on their identity or their race or whatever.
If you're trying to reach young white men, you can talk to them in the workplace.
Like the thing that unifies everyone in society is that we all need to work.
Es muss nämlich nicht darum gehen, jetzt Männerrechte einzuklagen oder sowas,
wie das dann von der anderen Seite geschieht, sondern man müsste eigentlich
nur die Arbeit in den Mittelpunkt stellen, müsste über Löhne sprechen.
Über Mindestlöhne sprechen und dann hätte man diese Männer auch alle mit angesprochen.
Was aber stattdessen stattfindet und das sehen wir auch hier in vielen linken
Kreisen, gerade in der akademischen Linken und der theoretischen Linken,
dass dort man genau darüber nicht sprechen will und tatsächlich sich immer noch
in diesen ganzen Identitätsfragen verrennt und wenn das ökonomische ausgeklammert
ist, man nicht nur dies tut,
sondern auch sich noch so lustig macht über die, die sich engagieren oder die
jetzt Bernie Sanders gut finden.
Und bezeichnet sie dann so als, ja, die Bernie Bros, das sind wieder so dumme
Männer, jetzt machen sie irgendwie was, nachdem sie Gaming gemacht haben mit Politik.
Und diese Verachtung, die diesen Männern entgegenschlägt, und das können wir
sehr gut von so Berlin-Mitte-Podcastern und so weiter erleben,
das ist etwas, was glaube ich sehr viele sehr wütend macht.
Und wir dürfen auch nicht vergessen, Joe Rogan war jemand, der Bernie Sanders
gut fand, unterstützt hat und Bernie Sanders war jemand, der im Joe Rogan Podcast
saß und mit dem auch quatschen konnte und der auch bei Twitch zu Gast war.
Und das aber hier, glaube ich, eine gewisse Tendenz und zwar nur bei einem kleinen,
aber medial mächtigen linksliberalen Kreis besteht, dass man sagt.
Männlichkeit an sich ist ein Problem und muss eigentlich bekämpft werden.
Das führt den anderen, die Wählern zu.
Und das ist ja etwas, was Joe Rogan immer wieder auch in seinem Podcast mit J.D. Vance betont.
Und ich glaube, dass das etwas ist, wo noch lange hier kein Lernprozess eingesetzt hat.
Und ich finde erstaunlich, dass wir das jetzt hier bei einem Tech-Podcast,
der das ja eigentlich ist, oder ein Social-Media-Podcast hören und dass Taylor
Lawrence da so ein gutes Gespür hat zu sagen, ja Moment mal,
aber erstmal gab es da mal immer diese Business-Modell, warum machen die das
und was ist eigentlich damit, dass immer so über die Bernie Bros die Nase gerümpft wurde.
Oder sind die jetzt auch alle ein Problem oder was?
Und das ist eine gewisse Tendanz, die können wir auch in der Kulturszene ganz gut beobachten.
Und das sind aber alles Szenen, in denen man nicht über die ökonomische Ungleichheit reden will.
Würde man über die ökonomische Ungleichheit reden und über Reallohnverlust und
all das, würde man automatisch alle mit inkludieren, die davon betroffen sind,
in Klammern auch natürlich Männer.
Das ist viel zu vorsichtig gesagt, ich möchte es strapazieren.
Wir haben jetzt die erste Generation nach Jahrhunderten, die die Bildungssysteme
verlässt und ins Berufsleben startet, bei denen die Frauen strukturell besser
aufgestellt sind als die Männer.
Bessere Studienabschlüsse, bessere Empfehlungszeugnisse, frühere Eintritte ins
Berufsleben, mehr Berufserfahrung und so weiter und so fort.
Gender Pay Gap gibt es so eh nicht, sondern es ist ein strukturelles und ganzheitliches
Phänomen, dass nämlich nur, wenn die Mutter, also die Frau kriegt ein Kind, mit eingerechnet wird.
Es gibt ein Child Penalty, so heißt übrigens die neue Losung,
ich habe es im Buch ausführlich, Child Penalty.
Also nicht Gender Pay Gap, im Sinne von Lücke zwischen Mann und Frau,
sondern nein, Menschen werden bestraht, wenn sie für Kinder zu Hause bleiben
und das sind nun mal die Mütter, weil das Kind wird geboren und danach,
das erste Jahr, ist die Mutter zu Hause.
Alle politischen Versuche, den Männern auch noch mal so einen Monat oder ein
paar Wochen abzuringen, sind sozusagen nicht unwichtig, aber eben auch gescheitert,
das muss man einfach so sagen.
Was bedeutet, wir haben jetzt ein Phänomen, dass wir.
Es ist, was soll ich sagen, eine Zäsur wir hatten ein Bildungssystem das nur
für die Männer da war die ersten Jahrhunderte Universität war die Universität eine männliche Domäne,
dass Frauen da eine Rolle spielen ist angesichts von 6-700 Jahre alten Universitäten
ein Vogelschiss der Geschichte so vor 100 Jahren oder so irgendwann über 200
Nobelpreise für Frauen für Männer,
13 für Frauen Dieses Verhältnis ist sozusagen das Verhältnis.
Wir haben also ein Denken aus dieser Pfadabhängigkeit,
das die Frau als förderungsbedürftig ab der ersten Klasse sieht und heute fallen
aber die Männer aus diesem Bildungssystem raus und kommen nicht weiter.
Sie kommen sowohl im Arbeitsleben nicht richtig an und mit nicht richtig meine
ich schon objektiv beobachtet, nicht richtig.
Aus subjektiver Sicht scheitern sie ab Tag 1. Also das ist einfach die flächendeckende Obachtung heute.
Plus, und das ist noch dramatischer, sie kommen auf dem Dating-Markt,
auf dem Mating-Markt nicht vorwärts.
Es klappt einfach nicht. Das, was wir hier sehen mit der Menosphäre,
ist eine Kompensation, vielleicht die erste große sichtbare Kompensation dieses Phänomens.
Es wird aber nicht die einzige bleiben, denn es wird zu weiteren kommen.
Was bedeutet, wenn man jetzt einen jüngeren Bernie Sanders halt hätte,
und es gibt ja einige, die dieses Erbe antreten können, die einfach stundenlang
in Podcasts über das Leiden der jungen Männer so reden,
dass die sich angesprochen und repräsentiert fühlen, ohne in eine Opferrolle gedrängt zu werden.
Im Sinne von, dir wurde etwas angetan, du hast dich nicht genug gewährt, selbst schuld.
Und ohne die Frauen zu diskriminieren.
Und ohne die Frauen wiederum zu diskriminieren, genau. Sondern wenn eine Förderungsstruktur
im Bildungswesen stattfindet, das so ein bisschen wie der Soli funktioniert.
Zuerst sagt man, oh wir machen jetzt, wir erweitern Deutschland um sechs neue
Bundesländer oder fünf und die sind strukturell benachteiligt,
also päppeln wir die auf, schaffen ein System der Aufpäppelung und stellen dann
fest, Mist, das Ruhrgebiet ist noch viel schlimmer dran.
So, jetzt hat man ein Förderungssystem, bei dem man sich fragt,
lassen wir es weg, weil der Osten ist jetzt aufgepäppelt, läuft ja jetzt vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht.
Dabei hat er ja schon mal sein großes Thema geändert von Unterstützung Irakkrieg
zu Aufbau Ost und jetzt eben Aufbau strukturschwacher, also sozusagen Folge der Urbanisierung.
Wenn wir ein Förderungssystem haben auf diesem Wege, das mal die Frauen gefördert
hat aus historisch nachvollziehbaren Gründen und den Umschwung schafft,
jetzt grundsätzlich zu fördern, auch wenn es Jungs sind, die gefördert werden müssen,
dann besteht hier eine gewisse Hoffnung, wenn es nicht klappt,
haben wir nur noch Menos 4 im Quadrat.
Aber ich glaube trotzdem, diese Menosphäre hat jetzt die amerikanische Präsidentschaft
übernommen und jetzt müssen sie auch liefern.
Also das ist jetzt kein Selbstläufer, nur weil die so fröhlich und stolz ihre
Menosphäre und ach das Testosteron, das ist ein Selbstläufer und so weiter.
Also diese Selbstläufer wird es so nicht geben, sondern die sind große Änderungen.
Und in meiner Arbeit jetzt das Jahr zum Thema Familie, will ich nochmal diese Rede von Olaf Scholz.
Olaf Scholz stand also da und hat gesagt, ich entlasse den Finanzminister.
Weil das Schaden für Deutschland bedeutet, wenn er weiter auf die Schuldenbremse besteht.
Denn wir brauchen den Staat jetzt wieder als, ja was eigentlich?
Und da kann man genau nachlesen, wortwörtlich, wofür Scholz den Staat braucht.
Um nämlich das Entweder-Oder aufzukündigen.
Er sagt es mehrfach. Er betont mehrfache Felder im Krieg, in der Sozialpolitik,
in der Wirtschaftspolitik. Nicht Entweder-Oder.
Also die FDP sagt einfach, also wenn wir jetzt Flugzeuge für die Ukrainer kaufen,
muss aber das Bürgergeld gestrichen werden.
Und gegen dieses Entweder-Oder stellt sich Scholz und positioniert den Staat
wieder als dritte Säule für Konsumenten und Produzenten, für Eltern und für
Kinder, für Arbeitnehmer und für Arbeitgeber und nicht im Entweder-Oder.
Und so wie Olaf Scholz eigentlich in dieser Rede, er hat es danach selber schon
wieder vergessen, was er da gesagt hatte, aber es ist halt bedeutsam,
wie er an diesem Tag in dieser Rede den Staat als dritte Säule neben den freien
Kräften der Wirtschaft und so weiter wieder positioniert.
Genau so, im Gleichschritt muss man jetzt nicht nur den Staat neu erfinden,
sondern auch die Familie, die ihn komplementiert.
Ja, ich wünschte, man würde es dann bei SPD-Politik auch sehen.
Lass mich noch einen Satz zu diesem Entweder-Oder sagen.
Es gab immer von Strack-Zimmermann und so weiter die Rede und auch von linksliberalen Medien vorgetragen,
Alice Weidel und Sarah Wagenknecht spielen die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge gegen
die deutschen Rentner aus.
In Wahrheit war es ja so, dass Alice Weidel und Wagenknecht damit nicht alleine waren.
Deren Argumentation war, wir wollen weniger Flüchtlinge, damit wir mehr Geld
für die Rentner haben. So in etwa.
Das ist schelbig, so etwas zu machen.
Die Sache war aber, die Ampelregierung hat gesagt, es gibt nicht mehr Geld,
der Kuchen wird nicht größer, also spielt man ja die einen gegen die anderen aus.
Es ist ja natürlich eine Illusion zu glauben, dass wenn jetzt weniger Geld an
die Flüchtlinge geht, dass automatisch dann an die Rentner weitergeleitet wird,
so ist es dann auch nicht.
Aber man hat dieses entweder oder ja betrieben und das war für Wagenknecht und
weil natürlich ein leichtes, dann sich genau darauf zu konzentrieren und sagen,
seht her, dafür ist Geld dafür, das andere nicht.
Weil die Regierung die ganze Zeit gesagt hat, wir können nicht das eine und das andere.
Ja, und deswegen ist es so erstaunlich, dass Olaf Scholz explizit aus den richtigen
Gründen, er hat sie uns erklärt, in der wichtigsten Rede seines Lebens,
dargelegt hat und fünf Minuten später war alles vergessen.
Ja, guck mal, jetzt kommt so viel Sonder rein, jetzt sind wir fast schwarz-weiß.
So, jetzt spielen wir diesen einen Clip, der mir ganz wichtig ist.
Scott Galloway erklärt jetzt hier, warum man Harris wählen sollte.
Wir sind also noch kurz vor der Wahl.
Und jetzt hast du schon wieder im Hinterkopf, ah ja, die Harris und so weiter und so.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
So, wir hören jetzt jetzt mal ganz nüchtern einfach, wie lautet die Argumentation
von Scott Galloway an die jungen Männer, warum man Harris wählen sollte?
Und ich möchte, während wir das hören, noch das Argument von ihm erweitern.
Dating klappt dann besonders gut, wenn sich zwei Leute so ein bisschen auf erstens
Augenhöhe ökonomisch treffen,
denn, ja, der Pilot datet auch mal die Stewardess, aber die Stewardess,
also ungeklärt, Umgedreht funktioniert es nicht.
Die Pilotin datet nicht den Flugbegleiter.
Also da haben wir sozusagen eine Schieflage. Wir brauchen also ein ökonomisches.
Augenhöhe-Niveau, um zu sagen, Dating funktioniert.
Also man hat dann einen großen Pool, wenn man sich selber ökonomisch standsicher fühlt.
Also auch deswegen brauchen wir eine neue Ökonomie, nicht nur antifaschistische,
sondern auch eine feministische, ich weiß, das Wort ist verbrannt,
aber eine feministische,
Wirtschaftspolitik, bei denen sich, und mit feministisch ist nicht die Frau
gemeint, sondern die Beziehung, die Frauen bereit sind einzugehen aus freien
Stücken, so dass nicht jemand daneben stehen muss und sagen,
also dir verbiete ich jetzt mal Abtreibung und die Uni und dann bist du mir
bitte your buddy, my choice.
Sondern nein, die Frau soll aus freien Stücken, also Freiheit ganz wichtig,
trotzdem mit einem Mann zusammenfinden, bei dem sie sagt, okay,
ich schaue ein bisschen drüber hinweg, dass ich eigentlich besser ausgebildet
bin, dass ich ein bisschen mehr verdiene, was auch immer und so.
Diese Skiflagen, also das will ich nur erweitern,
Scott Galloway macht schon einen interessanten Punkt, aber ich finde,
der ist noch viel wichtiger und viel weitreichender, als Scott Galloway ihn darlegt.
If I did a survey around would young men like to have more or less sex,
I'm pretty sure the vast majority of them would say I would like to have more sex.
And if you want to have more sex, if you want to have more sex,
then we absolutely need to cauterize, reject, and turn around this ridiculous
notion that women are going to have their bodily autonomy taken.
Because if you want to have random sex, and let's be clear, the majority of
relationships involve at some point maybe a little bit of alcohol and a little bit of random sex.
If the woman is thinking about random sex and then says, you know what,
I might be in an emergency room parking lot unable to terminate a pregnancy,
even if I have sepsis because the doctor might go to jail.
If I have to carry an unwanted pregnancy to term, both you and her are going
to be economically disabled.
The fastest way to have less sex is to let more people get on the Supreme Court
and to take away a woman's bodily autonomy. So guys, you want to get laid more?
Make sure women have bodily autonomy. Let's review. Okay. Your ability to be a provider.
I'm very serious about this shit. I know. I think sex is a wonderful thing.
And the notion of kids, young people are having less sex, it is terrible and
it is a wonderful thing. And the notion that you and your partner have to be
much more thoughtful and scared of actually having sex is terrible for everybody.
One, your ability to be a provider, economic policies that make it easier for
you to be economically responsible for your household.
Two, a default setting around being a provider and three, your ability to form
a family at your pace with economic responsibility through bodily autonomy.
All of these add up to Vice President Harris being nominated and elected for our president.
So if you are a young man, I would encourage you to lean into your code around masculinity.
And that code leads to one place and that is a Harris administration.
Wow, I have not heard that one. If you want to have sex, vote Harris.
I like it. That's what we're saying.
Wenn der Krah kommt und sagt, mach mal das und das, dann klappt es auch mit der Freundin.
Dann würde ich sagen, es ist genau das richtige politische Thema.
Nur, das Gegenteil ist wahr.
Lieber Herr Graf,
Ich will eine Freundin und wenn sie keine Politik machen, bei der mir nach der
Miete 1000 Euro bleiben im Monat, damit ich es sehr hübsch machen kann,
dann wähle ich sie nicht.
Und dann muss der Kran Plan vorlegen, wie dem 23-Jährigen 1000 Euro netto im
Monat zur Verfügung stehen nach Miete.
Ansonsten ist das kein legitimes Angebot, was die AfD macht.
Also diese neue Verknüpfung aus einem eigenständigen Staat, der nicht entweder
oder, sondern für alle da ist, mit dem Absichern ökonomischer Realität,
sodass es mit der Freundin klappt, ist die Lösung.
Weshalb diese antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik, das sind Texte,
Interviews hat sie gegeben, wir kommen im Salon drauf zurück, ganz wichtig sind.
Ja, in der Tat.
Lass uns über Meinungsfreiheit sprechen. Wir haben jetzt eben schon gesagt,
bei den sozialen Medien geht es drunter und drüber, aber im Bundestag ist es
da auch nicht viel besser.
Es gibt eine Antisemitismus-Resolution jetzt.
Sagen wir noch kurz was beim Salonlesen.
Ja, machen wir das zuerst.
Denn ich sehe es da vor mir liegen. Ich sehe es ja immer nur,
wenn du es präsent mitbringst.
Wir lesen von Peter Sloterdijk, der Kontinent ohne Eigenschaften,
Lesezeichen im Buch Europa.
Der große Philosoph legt hier seine Europa-Philosophie vor, beziehungsweise
erklärt uns Europa, versucht es vielleicht für uns zu definieren.
Wir wissen ja auch selbst nicht so ganz, was ist Europa.
Wir haben so eine Ahnung, aber wir brauchen natürlich den Philosophen, der es uns sagt.
Und wir merken, dass Europa jetzt gerade so sehr zerstritten ist,
in so viele Lager zerteilt ist.
Ist das ein gutes Zeichen vielleicht sogar für Europa?
Zeichnet das Europa aus, so plural zu sein oder liegt genau darin das Problem?
Er hat eine Vorlesung gehalten an der Sorbonne in Paris, hat also dort den Franzosen
aus deutscher Perspektive erklärt, was Europa ist.
Macron war so interessiert daran, dass er sich dann auch mit Sotardijk persönlich getroffen hat.
Das heißt, dies ist ein Buch, das im Kopf der Regierenden durchaus vorhanden ist.
Deswegen müssen wir es natürlich auch lesen, damit wir in die Köpfe reingucken
können, derjenigen, die uns regieren.
Ja, ich bin auch schon sehr gespannt. Ich habe noch nichts dazu gelesen oder auch gehört.
Ich auch noch nicht.
Es sind ja natürlich auch gerade Zeiten, in denen halt so Bücher kommen,
die dann irgendwie, also wir werden Merkel jetzt nicht groß lesen.
Wir warten immer noch auf das Merkel-Buch gegen Merkel geschrieben.
Bei dem Thema, es ist die Zeit der Zäsuren, was nicht nur bedeutet die Frage,
was ist Europa, okay, aber was könnte es schon nächstes Jahr sein?
Die stellt sich ja nun insbesondere gerade.
Ja, wir werden also darüber sehr ausführlich sprechen im Salon und weil wir
heute schon so viel über Podcast geredet haben und über die großen Medienhäuser,
was sie alles falsch machen, es besteht die Möglichkeit.
Diesen Podcast zu unterstützen, beziehungsweise es gibt nur eine einzige Möglichkeit,
den Podcast zu unterstützen.
Und das ist die, dass man den Salon abonnieren kann. Im Salon diskutieren wir
dann ausführlich immer ein Buch.
Es sind schon über 60, 70 Bücher, die wir diskutiert haben.
Also gemeinsam, genau. Über 50 gemeinsam und hunderte, die vor allem durch deine
Belletristik-Vorstellung hier Niederschlag fanden bei uns.
Ja und sehr viele Artikel natürlich, also immer noch so zehn Empfehlungen gibt es dazu.
Von mir kommt auch wieder ein Musiktipp, kann ich schon sagen.
Und diesen Salon kann man hören, wenn man ihn abonniert.
Und zwar geht das, wenn man jetzt über Apple uns hört und möchte da gar nicht
auf eine andere Plattform ganz einfach, dass man den bei Apple buchen kann.
Da ist es aber dann ein bisschen teurer, da Apple eine Gebühr verlangt.
Wer schon bei Patreon angemeldet ist, kann auch den Salon dort abonnieren.
Wer allerdings alle Folgen haben will, bei Apple und Patreon sind so,
ich glaube die ersten 14 oder 18, 16 Monate nicht vollständig da.
Wer also wirklich alles hören will vom Januar 2020 an, kann das am allerbesten über Steady tun.
Ab drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei. Es ist ganz simpel und man kann es dann
auch überall hören, so wie man den Podcast immer hört.
Also es gibt keine große Hürde, die man noch einmal nehmen muss.
Man muss kein technisches Genie dafür sein.
Ja, man kann natürlich auf der Steady-Seite einfach hören, aber Steady ist der
Provider des RSS-Feeds und RSS ist die Freiheit.
Damit kann man den Podcast überall hören, wie man möchte. Es gibt unendlich
viele Player, die auf allen Smartphones, egal wer sie herstellt und betreibt,
installiert werden kann.
Und dann kriegt man einfach die Nachricht, Ding Dong, neuer Salon ist da und
man kann direkt auf Play trippen, wie man halt Podcasts so hört.
Ja, also wer den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützen will, wir sind dankbar und freuen uns darüber.
Und wir können auch schon mal sagen, dass wir dann im nächsten Salon nochmal
die Termine bekannt geben für unsere Live-Veranstaltung in der KS.
Also im aktuellen Salon kann man schon die Termine jetzt hören,
wer jetzt abonniert, kann es hören.
Es ist so, dass die erste Veranstaltung schon so gut wie ausverkauft ist,
also die März-Veranstaltung, aber für die anderen drei Veranstaltungen dann
im Juni, September und Dezember gibt es noch Karten.
Genau, für März nur noch sieben, also falls ihr das jetzt gerade hört und die
Termine kennt, weil ihr Salonmitglieder seid und im März kommen wollt.
Ein bisschen muss man sich dann sputen.
Gut. Die Meinungsfreiheit. Du redest über Meinungsfreiheit und ich werde mal
die Jalousie runtermachen. Ich fühle mich hier geblendet.
Wir hören jetzt erst einmal Beatrix von Storch
von der AfD zu dieser Antisemitismus-Resolution, die es im Bundestag gab.
Alle Fraktionen, nein nicht alle Fraktionen, aber viele haben sich da zusammengesetzt
und haben diese Resolution gemeinsam entworfen.
Sprich CDU, CSU, SPD, FDP, Grüne und ja, Linke hat sich enthalten,
BSW hat dagegen gestimmt als einzige Gruppe und AfD hat dafür auch gestimmt.
Gibt es jetzt gemeinsame Sache im Bundestag, ja?
Ja, also ich meine, Sie haben ja das Recht, auch dafür zu stimmen.
Wir hören aber jetzt mal Beatrix von Storch.
Jetzt lesen wir in diesem Antrag, mit eingebracht von den Grünen,
von Antisemitismus, der auf Zitat Zuwanderung aus den Ländern Nordafrikas und
des Nahen und Mittleren Ostens basiert.
Das sind grüne Chiffren für importierten muslimischen Antisemitismus.
Die Realität hat sie eingeholt. Und auch der Lösungsvorschlag in Ihrem Antrag
geht in unsere Richtung.
Zitat, repressive Möglichkeiten ausschöpfen, insbesondere im Straf- und Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
und im Asyl- und Aufenthaltsrecht.
Auf Deutsch, muslimische Antisemiten in den Flieger setzen und ab in die Heimat.
Tschüss und nicht. Auf Wiedersehen.
Ja, sie nimmt das Angebot dankbar auf Antisemiten, also noch diese ganzen Muslime,
die die Merkel hier reingelassen hat.
Ja und so kann man es auch dann im Antrag dann lesen, also dass es diesen Antisemitismus
auch gibt und ich würde auch sagen, ja es gibt natürlich einen solchen importierten
Antisemitismus oder wie die das dann nennen wollen, den gibt es zweifellos.
Interessanterweise aber findet nicht jeder Antisemitismus in dieser Resolution Erwähnung.
Und es ist ja auch die Frage, was soll überhaupt so eine Resolution und wie
kann man überhaupt gegen eine solche Resolution sein? Weil dann erstmal würde
man doch sagen, naja, ein Kampf gegen den Antisemitismus ist doch per se wichtig.
Also was ist dagegen zu sagen?
Nun wird dort auch aufgelistet, was man alles so machen will und Schulbildung ist wichtig etc.
Dass man Gedenkstätten aufsucht, also all diese Dinge, die jeder natürlich sofort unterschreiben würde.
Die Sache allerdings ist bei diesem Antrag, dass es da durchaus um mehr geht.
Und zwar hat man sich darauf geeinigt dann, also alle Parteien haben sich,
die den Entwurf da gemacht haben, also wie gesagt SPD, CDU, FDP, Grüne.
Dass man sich auf eine bestimmte Antisemitismus-Definition festlegt und zwar eine Definition,
die wir jetzt gleich mal vortragen können.
Also es ist die Definition von der International Holocaust Remembrance Alliance
und diese Definition ist nicht unumstritten bzw.
Sie ist heiß umkämpft. Und da heißt es erst einmal, Antisemitismus ist eine
bestimmte Wahrnehmung von Juden, die sich als Hass gegenüber Juden ausdrücken kann.
Der Antisemitismus richtet sich in Wort und Tat gegen jüdische oder nicht jüdische
Einzelpersonen und oder deren Eigentum sowie gegen jüdische Gemeindeinstitutionen
oder religiöse Einrichtungen.
Das ist also das eine.
Außerdem hat die Bundesregierung also schon vor dieser Resolution sich zu dieser
Definition mal bekannt, das war glaube ich 2019 und da gibt es noch eine Erweiterung
dazu und die ist jetzt der Knackpunkt, da heißt es,
darüber hinaus kann auch der Staat Israel,
der dabei als jüdisches Kollektiv verstanden wird.
Ziel solcher Angriffe sein.
Und die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, was ist damit gemeint? Und der gehen wir
jetzt so ein bisschen nach.
Also es geht also offenbar darum, dass es auch einen Israel bezogenen Antisemitismus gibt.
Und ich möchte hier ganz ausdrücklich sagen, ja, ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen,
dass es den gibt und man kann ihn auch erleben.
Also das ist nämlich dann, wenn man plötzlich Doppelstandards anlegt an Israel,
wenn man aber auch zum Beispiel Israel das Existenzrecht abspricht oder wenn man quasi Juden,
die woanders sind oder generell Juden auch in Israel dafür verantwortlich macht,
was jetzt gerade die israelische Regierung tut.
Und das ist ja etwas, was wir jetzt auch erlebt haben,
zum Beispiel, wenn dann jüdische Künstler oder jüdisch-israelische Künstler
irgendwo auftreten und man von ihnen dann einfordert, sie sollen jetzt bitte
sich von Israel distanzieren oder von der israelischen Politik.
Dann erlebt man genau das, man versteht dann alle nur noch als jüdisches Kollektiv
und das ist genau falsch und das finde ich auch tatsächlich sehr skandalös.
Dass das mitunter stattfindet.
Zum Beispiel auch als das Jerusalem-Quartett in den Niederlanden gespielt hat,
ein wirklich herausragendes Streichquartett, wurde dieses Konzert gestört.
Und so etwas darf natürlich überhaupt nicht sein.
Und da gibt es natürlich mehrere Varianten von. Das Problem ist aber jetzt, dass man natürlich...
Eigentlich ja auch Kritik an der israelischen Regierung üben sollen kann,
aber natürlich durch so eine schwammige Definition man ganz schnell jemanden
des Antisemitismus bezichtigen kann, wo eigentlich gar keiner ist und wir werden
uns das jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer ansehen.
Ich habe mir diese ganze zweistündige Debatte im Bundestag angehört und ich
würde sagen, es war nicht eine Glanzstunde,
denn es wurden sehr viele Präambeltexte vorgetragen, sehr viel Betroffenheit
bekundet, aber eine wirklich intellektuelle Auseinandersetzung mit dem Antisemitismusbegriff
hat nicht stattgefunden.
Es spricht jetzt zum Beispiel Konstantin von Notz, Grüne.
Wenn die barbarischen Anschläge vom 7.
Oktober offen bejubelt werden, wenn Vernichtungsfantasien gegen Israel unverfroren
artikuliert werden, wenn davon gesprochen wird, Jüdinnen und Juden ins Meer
zu treiben, dann ist das glasklar antisemitisch.
Es ist menschenverachtend und abstoßend und wir stellen uns dem mit aller Entschiedenheit
entgegen, meine Damen und Herren.
Und was er hier doch sagt, müsste doch sowieso klar sein und war doch auch vorher
klar. Also dafür brauche ich keine Resolution.
Also wer auf den Straßen rumläuft und tot den Juden ruft, dass der strafrechtlich
belangt wird, das ist ja wohl völlig klar.
Und dass da niemand sagt, ach ja, ist auch eine schöne Meinung,
können wir morgen mal eine Talkshow einladen, ist doch völlig klar.
Also da ist ja nicht so, dass wir sagen, das ging bis gestern noch,
aber jetzt haben wir Gott sei Dank die Resolution, die das verbietet.
Wir hören jetzt Lindholz von der CDU.
Es braucht hier Nachschärfungen, ansonsten bleibt dieser Satz nur eine hohle Phrase.
Und es ist wichtig, dass wir die in über 40 Staaten anerkannte Definition der
IRA als maßgeblich für das festlegen, was Antisemitismus ist und keine andere Definition.
Maßgeblich und keine andere Definition. Also wir reden ja hier über ein politisches
Terrain. Ja, wir reden ja nicht hier über 1 und 1 ist gleich 2.
Wie kann man das so verabsolutieren?
Interessanterweise sagt jetzt Konstantin von Notz.
Die IRA-Definition, die Kollegin Lindholz hat gerade darauf Bezug genommen,
ist Grundlage für die Arbeit der Bundesregierung und zwar seit 2017.
Sie ist es des Bundestages seit 2019. Und wir erklären heute in dieser Resolution
diese Definition nicht für absolut, aber als maßgeblich heranzuziehen.
Diese Definition verunmöglicht nicht Kritik an der israelischen Regierung,
denn sie wird ohne Zweifel jeden Tag in Deutschland artikuliert und zwar in Kunst und Kultur,
in der Wissenschaft und hier im Deutschen Bundestag und deswegen benennen wir
auch eindeutig in dieser Resolution die Meinungskunst und Kulturfreiheit, meine Damen und Herren.
Ja, also was denn nun? Jetzt sagt sie, nee, das ist die Definition, die gilt.
Und er sagt, ja doch, die Definition ist ein Maßstab, aber wir wollen es nicht verabsolutieren.
Aber die Kritik an der israelischen Regierung, an Israel ist weiterhin möglich.
Wir hören mal weiter jetzt Konstantin Kuhle, FDP.
Ich habe mich in den letzten Tagen aber über so manche Wortmeldungen in dieser Diskussion gewundert.
So wird etwa vorgetragen, dass die hier vorliegende Resolution die Meinungs-,
die Kunst- und die Wissenschaftsfreiheit verletze,
weil mit der in der Resolution enthaltenen Definition von Antisemitismus rechtliche
Unklarheiten verbunden seien.
Hinter diesem Vorwurf, liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, steckt die in der Resolution,
Ein fundamentales Missverständnis. Denn diese Resolution soll ja die Konflikte
über Antisemitismus in der Gesellschaft nicht beenden.
Diese Resolution soll ja die Diskussionen in der Gesellschaft über das Thema
Antisemitismus nicht beenden, sondern diese Diskussion, die wir in Deutschland
führen müssen, diese Resolution, sie ist gerade dazu gedacht,
Konflikte über das Thema Antisemitismus auszutragen.
Klingt jetzt irgendwie nach einem großen Angebot, jetzt nochmal zu diskutieren.
Eigenartig aber, wie es dann Michael Breilmann von der CDU artikuliert.
Und wenn wir alle gemeinsam Antisemitismus bekämpfen wollen,
das ist vorhin schon mal deutlich geworden, dann müssen wir ihn auch klar benennen können.
Und für uns als Union war von Beginn der Gespräche an immer ganz klar,
dass nur die IRA-Antisemitismus-Definition maßgeblich sein kann. Keine andere.
Denn diese IRA-Definition, sie basiert auf wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen
und sie adressiert vor allem genau den israelbezogenen Antisemitismus,
der als die häufigste Form derzeit bei uns in Deutschland in Erscheinung tritt.
Also, ich habe es noch im Kopf. Ich habe die Clips gerade versucht zu finden,
aber ich habe sie irgendwie nicht.
In der Kulturzeit war vor einigen Jahren alleine Assmann zu Gast,
weil es ein Anliegen gab, die Antisemitismus-Definition zu überarbeiten.
Ich habe jetzt hier nochmal Perplexity gefragt, deswegen wirklich nur grob,
aber sie hat wohl vorgeschlagen, mehrere Ausprägungen von Antisemitismus,
wie zum Beispiel traditionellen, israelbezogenen oder auch neuen.
Zu definieren, um unter anderem, und das weiß ich noch, ganz explizit hat sie
das gemacht in dem Gespräch mit der Kulturzeit, Kritik,
Ausländische Kritik, unsere Kritik zum Beispiel, am Regierungshandeln israelischer
Regierungsverantwortlichen auszuklammern,
weil das nämlich in dieser IHRA-Definition nicht explizit ausgeklammert wird
und dadurch keine Befriedung, sondern einfach nur eine,
wie soll man sagen, Überrumpelung stattfindet, wenn man sagt,
das was Netanyahu dann macht, finde ich gar nicht gut und dafür braucht man
nicht die aktuellen politischen Entwicklungen.
Sondern auch sozialpolitische Entwicklungen in Israel, die Leute auf die Straße
treiben, Umgang mit der Justiz oder was auch immer.
Dass man sich dann erstmal zum Thema Antisemitismus verhalten muss,
obwohl man einfach nur ein, ich habe Freunde in Israel und ich finde es nicht
okay, dass deren Regierung dann durchdreht, einen Punkt machen wollte.
So, das bedeutet, die bisherige Antisemitismus-Definition sah da Antisemitismus,
wo Leute politische Anliegen und zwar in demokratischen Bahnen vorgetragen haben,
was dann einfach nicht ging.
Ja, es hört sich aber hier alles ein bisschen anders an. Wir hören nochmal Konstantin Kuhle.
Als würden sie gerade das erste Mal überhaupt über Antisemitismus reden.
Und es gibt nur die eine Definition.
In der öffentlichen Debatte über den vorliegenden Antrag wird mitunter verlangt,
den Schutz jüdischen Lebens in Deutschland und die außenpolitische Debatte über
den sogenannten Nahostkonflikt voneinander zu trennen.
Aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, diesen Luxus können sich viele Jüdinnen
und Juden in Deutschland gar nicht erlauben.
Denn für die Juden in Deutschland ist diese Trennung nicht möglich.
Seit dem Terrorangriff der Hamas haben die antisemitischen Angriffe in Deutschland
dramatisch zugenommen.
Seit einem Jahr haben Vertreterinnen und Vertreter jüdischer Institutionen mehr
Personenschutz als vorher und seit einem Jahr müssen die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen
für jüdische Institutionen drastisch verschärft werden.
Was ist das jetzt für ein rhetorisches Spiel, das hier getrieben wird?
Also der Antisemitismus ist gestiegen, beziehungsweise auch die antisemitischen
Bedrohungen, weshalb die Sicherheit hochgefahren wird.
Davon sind Juden in Deutschland betroffen.
Wenn hier davon geredet wird, dass man aber die Außenpolitik nicht trennen könne
von dem Schutz des jüdischen Lebens, dann wird doch hier etwas miteinander vermischt.
Es geht doch um eine Kritik der Außenpolitik, also zum Beispiel der deutschen
Außenpolitik, die Waffen an Israel liefert.
Und mit dieser Waffenpolitik ist nicht das jüdische Leben in Deutschland geschützt,
sondern wird ein Staatsinteresse verfolgt etc.
Jetzt zu sagen, nee, das hängt ja alles beides miteinander zusammen,
würde ich sagen, widerstrebt ja eigentlich diese IRA-Definition,
denn die sagt ja wie gesagt,
darüber hinaus kann auch der Staat Israel, der dabei als jüdisches Kollektiv
verstanden wird, Ziel solcher Angriffe sein.
Was hier jetzt passiert ist eigentlich, dass man alle Juden als Kollektiv begreift,
dass in eins gesetzt wird mit Israel und der israelischen Regierung.
Ja, ganz genau. Was ja auf vielen anderen Gebieten sehr viel Anlass für Comedy
bietet, denn man könnte dich zum Beispiel fragen, Wolfgang, du als Deutscher,
du hast ja gar keine Lederhose an.
Ja,
kommt vielleicht auch noch. Denken wir drüber nach. Jetzt können wir überlegen,
was ist dann so eine Resolution?
Was soll denn eigentlich damit bewerkstelligt werden? Nun, man kann dann mal
so eine Stunde im Bundestag abhalten, wird dann auch groß übertragen.
Wurde groß übertragen? Ich habe nichts richtig davon mitbekommen.
Doch, doch, es wurde schon viel darüber geredet. Ja, also klar.
Jetzt Lindholz spricht ein bisschen klarer.
Wenn wir den Satz, kein deutsches Steuergeld, für antisemitische Organisationen
und Projekte ernst meinen, dann
muss bei der Entscheidung über die Vergabe staatlicher Mittel konkret,
ganz klar sichergestellt werden, dass damit kein Antisemitismus gefördert wird.
Das wollte ich jetzt eh kurz anmerken, dass hier wird es ja erst brenzlig.
Ja.
Denn wir haben ja das Problem 2024,
Ich kann mich noch an meine eigenen Gemütszustände erinnern,
dass ich einfach während der ganzen Zeit des Aufwachen-Podcasts ab 2015 oder
danach in den Podcasts immer so, nee, solange Netanyahu regiert,
sage ich dazu gar nichts, weil ich will mir ja nicht die Finger verbrennen.
Mittlerweile, es wird über Antisemitismus, ich sitze so da, bin wirklich ganz
entspannt und denke mir so, ja gut, okay, also wenn Kommentare zum Antisemitismus
oder Semitismus oder wie auch
immer gefragt sind, würde ich was dazu sagen oder wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Also dieser Begriff ist mittlerweile so inflationär und auch verbrannt durch
solche Diskussionen, dass ich mich nicht wundern würde,
wenn auf der Straße demnächst wirklich Leute, ach sie nennen mich Antisemit,
ja keine Ahnung, ich fühle nichts dabei.
Dass man jetzt sich hier auf die Institutionen zurückzieht, zeigt ja nur,
dass man hier die letzten Rückzugsgefechte, also die letzten Kampfgebiete nochmal
ausflaggt, da wo wir Budgets verteilen.
Genau, man will jetzt an die Budgets ran, dass gewisse Dinge nicht mehr möglich sind.
So im Sinn von, wer nicht hören will, muss fühlen. Jetzt geht es ans Eingemachte.
Breilmann, Ihr Parteikollege, führt es weiter aus.
Wir setzen heute aber auch die klare Botschaft, dass eine staatliche Förderung
von Antisemitismus ausgeschlossen sein muss.
Länder, Bund und Kommunen sollen soweit noch nicht erfolgrechtssichere,
haushalterische Regelungen finden, damit Projekte und Vorhaben,
insbesondere mit antisemitischen Zielen, nicht gefördert werden.
Und ich möchte ja auch betonen, Grundrechte wie die Meinungs- und Kunstfreiheit
werden durch unsere Resolution gerade nicht gefährdet.
Denn Kunst und auch Meinungsfreiheit, sie erlauben keinen Antisemitismus.
Strafrechtlich relevante Äußerungen werden schon gar nicht von diesen Grundrechten
erfasst vom Schutzbereich.
Diese Grundrechte gelten auch nicht schrankenlos. Nein, ich sage...
Was ist das für ein Geschwätz? Also da, wo das ohnehin eine strafrechtliche
Verfolgung nach sich zieht, braucht man keine Resolution, weil das ohnehin so gewesen wäre.
Alles, was im Bereich der Kunst dann stattfindet, ist eigentlich Kunst.
Wenn ich aber sage, ja, wir schränken die Kunst nicht ein, wir geben ihr nur
kein Geld mehr, dann bedeutet das was.
Und wir haben hier ein ganz konkretes Beispiel, das er nennt.
Und jetzt wird es wirklich...
Ich finde, bevor wir jetzt die nächsten Clips sind leider nicht mehr so viele
aus der Diskussion, also aus der Debatte direkt im Bundestag,
aber man sollte sie auch immer darin überprüfen,
dreht da einfach nur jemand gerade die Argumentation auf 100,
um sich einen Arsch zu retten, so im Sinne von, die Fraktion hat gesagt,
ich soll heute dazu reden, okay, ich gehe einfach all in und dann ist mir auch
scheißegal, so ungefähr, weil das unterstelle ich hier den meisten.
Die interessieren sich doch einen Scheiß für Antisemitismus.
Ja, die interessieren sich gar nicht für das Thema, nein, überhaupt nicht,
das sind da alles solche Lippenbekenntnisse, die abgegeben werden.
Breilmann redet weiter.
Wir stellen mit diesem Antrag klar, dass wir verhindern werden,
dass unter dem Deckmantel dieser Grundrechte Antisemitismus verbreitet wird.
Wir stellen mit diesem Antrag klar, dass es auch in den Reihen von Kunst,
Kultur und Medien keinen Raum für Antisemitismus gibt und wir stellen mit diesem Antrag,
Dass alle Ursachen und Hintergründe der letzten großen Antisemitismus-Skandale,
insbesondere auf der Documenta 15 und der Berlinale im Februar 2024,
umfassend aufgearbeitet und Konsequenzen gezogen werden.
Dieses Versprechen geben wir mit dieser Resolution heute ab.
Zur Documenta haben wir hier mal ausführlich gesprochen und ich habe da auch viel Kritik geübt.
Jetzt kam aber die Berlinale und dann habe ich in der Resolution nachgelesen,
so ein vierseitiger Text etwa. Da heißt es, Meinungsfreiheit und die Freiheit
von Kunst und Wissenschaft sind hohe Güter und werden durch unser Grundgesetz
garantiert und geschützt.
Auch in den Reihen von Kunst und Kultur sowie der Medien darf es keinen Raum
für Antisemitismus geben.
Die Ursachen und Hintergründe der großen Antisemitismus-Skandale der letzten
Jahre in diesen Bereichen, insbesondere auf der Documenta und der Berlinale
im Februar 2024, müssen umfassend aufgearbeitet werden und es müssen Konsequenzen gezogen werden.
Dort, wo die Bundesregierung dies bereits in Angriff genommen hat,
zum Beispiel durch Sensibilisierungsmaßnahmen und Codes of Conduct für die bundesgeförderten
Einrichtungen in Bezug auf Antisemitismus, begrüßt der Deutsche Bundestag dies.
Und jetzt überlegen wir nochmal, gab es auf der Berlinale einen Antisemitismus-Skandal?
Und ich will es jetzt hier ganz deutlich machen.
Wahrscheinlich, oder nee, ich sage es anders. Es geht jetzt um diesen Film No Other Land.
Dieser Dokumentarfilm läuft gerade in den Kinos, ich empfehle ihn.
Dieser Dokumentarfilm ist sehr gut.
Er zeichnet das Bild von der israelischen Armee, wie sie im Westjordanland besetzt, Häuser,
Schulen einreist und wie dann auch noch mitunter gewalttätige Siedler auftauchen.
Dieser Film ist im Kollektiv gedreht von zwei Palästinensern und zwei jüdischen
Israelis, die mit diesem Film einen großen Erfolg weltweit haben,
der sehr viele positive Kritiken hat.
Wer das anders filmkritisch einordnen will, kann das jederzeit tun.
Nun, dieser Film ist an sich natürlich ein Blick auf die Dinge,
nämlich aus dieser Perspektive heraus, also von der palästinensischen Bevölkerung drauf geblickt.
Und ich will auch sagen, dass das legitim ist. Man kann auch andere Filme darüber
drehen, aber es gibt diesen.
Du meinst, der Film folgt einem Blick, also die Kamera kann immer nur aus einer
spezifischen Perspektive, das ist ja ganz sonderbar.
Ist ganz sonderbar und wir haben auch nicht nochmal die Position von Netanyahu in diesem Film drin.
Und ich will nochmal betonen, dieser Film wird nicht nur jetzt von Leuten wie
mir oder auch von Ronan Steigenke empfohlen,
sondern Steffen Seibert hat als auf einer Berlin-Plattform, DE-Plattform von
der Stadt gesagt wurde, dies sei ein antisemitischer Film gesagt,
bei Twitter, also hört mal.
Es ist wichtig Antisemitismus zu bekämpfen, aber bitte dort wo er auch stattfindet
und da findet er nicht statt.
Also jetzt Steffen Seibert, der
deutsche Botschafter in Israel muss jetzt schon mal dazu Raison bitten.
Und jetzt hören wir uns die Rede von der Berlinale, die Dankesrede an,
von der eine Sparistinenser, der andere jüdische Israeli und man muss jetzt
diesen Aussagen nicht komplett zustimmen.
Ja, also ich habe auch mein Problem mit dem Begriff Apartheid in diesem Zusammenhang.
Aber wir müssen uns, wenn wir das uns jetzt anhören, folgende Frage stellen.
Darf so etwas künftig noch in Deutschland auf einer Bühne gesagt werden oder
sagen wir, das ist absolut verpönt, das darf es nie mehr geben?
Denn die Resolution sagt, das darf es nie mehr geben. Sie schreiben es explizit
rein. Wir hören uns das jetzt komplett an.
Das sind 100 Sekunden.
Good evening, everybody. We're glad to be here and grateful.
It's our first movie since many years.
My community, my family has been filming our community being erased by this brutal occupation.
I'm here celebrating the award, but also very hard for me to celebrate when
there are tens of thousands of my people being slaughtered and massacred by Israel in Gaza.
Masaf Riyatta, meine Gemeinde, ist auch von Israeli-Bildozers gegründet.
Ich frage eine Sache für Deutschland, als ich in Berlin bin,
hier, um die UN-Kolle zu respektieren und zu stoppen von Wäbenen zu Israel.
Applaus Wer hat denn da alles applaudiert?
Und Claudia Roth sagt ja tatsächlich, sie hätte nur für den Israeli applaudiert.
Also das ist der, der jetzt spricht. Und ich glaube, er ist auch der,
der von Apartheid spricht, interessanterweise.
Ich lebe unter einem Zivilisten, und Basel ist unter Militär.
Wir leben 30 Minuten von einem anderen, aber ich habe die Voterspots,
und Basel ist nicht die Voterspots. Ich bin frei, wo ich in dieser Lande bin.
Basel ist, wie Millionen Palästinien, in der Ockupieden Westbank.
Diese Situation der Apartheid zwischen uns, diese Inequalität, muss es enden.
Wir fragen, wie wir eine Veränderung machen können, um die Ockupation zu enden,
um für eine politische Lösung zu gehen.
Und wir haben nicht wirklich die Antwort, aber ich denke, eine Antwort ist,
dass die Menschen wirklich aufstehen.
Es gibt viele körperliche Leute in diesem Raum, viele MinisterInnen und Leute,
deren Voraussetzungen gehört werden.
Wir müssen ein Zitat, eine politische Lösung, um die Ockupation zu enden.
Das war es jetzt.
Und das ist der Antisemitismus-Skandal. Und so etwas soll nicht mehr stattfinden.
Wo ich mich auch frage, wie findet so etwas dann nicht mehr statt also die Sache
ist ja, die wählen einen Film aus der gewinnt jetzt,
aufgrund einer Juryentscheidung und dann kommen Preisträger auf die Bühne und
sagen irgendetwas was ja nicht abgesprochen ist also man muss also dann immer schon vorher fragen,
entschuldigen Sie wenn Sie den Preis gewonnen haben sollten,
welche Rede werden Sie dann gehalten.
Haben wir haben hier eine Liste mit Sachen die Sie bitte nicht sagen, Kunstfreiheit.
Also das ist doch der reinste Wahnsinn. Es gibt also gegen diese Resolution,
die dann durchgewunken wurde, auch Widerstand.
Da haben sich einige Wissenschaftler zusammengesetzt.
Unter anderem Barbara Stolberg-Rillinger, junge Naiv, hat diese ganze Pressekonferenz übertragen.
Sie ist Rektorin des Wissenschaftskollegs zu Berlin und sie sagt nun folgendes.
Das Hauptproblem, was passieren würde aus meiner Sicht als Leiterin einer Wissenschaftsinstitution
ist, dass die Wissenschaftsfreiheit massiv bedroht wäre nach Grundgesetz Artikel 5.3.
Warum? Weil die Kernfrage des ganzen Papiers ist, was ist denn eigentlich Antisemitismus?
Was unterscheidet ihn, den sogenannten israelbezogenen Antisemitismus,
von Israelkritik, von legitimer Kritik an der israelischen Regierung und so weiter?
Und vor allem, wer bestimmt eigentlich darüber, wie man Antisemitismus definiert
und identifiziert? Und das ist vollkommen unklar.
Die Definition, die man hier festgelegt hat, die sogenannte IHRA-Definition,
ist absolut vage und lässt einen riesigen Spielraum und führt deshalb zu Rechtsunsicherheit.
Ja, weißt du an, was mich das erinnert? Wir hatten lange Jahre Diskussionen,
vielleicht kennst du noch Zensursolar, Ursula von der Leyen als Familienministerin,
weil es einfach, aber wir wollen doch nur die Kinder schützen vor Pornografie.
Wir müssen das ja alles hier und so weiter.
Und dann war einfach die Frage, woran erkennen wir jetzt Pornografie?
Also Kindermissbrauch, der pornografisch ausgebeutet wird, erkennt man daran,
dass die Kinder jung sind. aber wir wollen ja auch die Kinder vor Pornografie
schützen und dann ist die Definition einfach wenn man es sieht, sieht man es,
Und darauf bauen wir jetzt alles auf. Aber eben mit einer Argumentation,
dass man im Bundestag steht und die ganze Zeit sagt, aber die Kinder.
Also klar, Artikel 1 und so, aber die Kinder.
Und das erinnert mich dann, deswegen diese Gleichheit hier mit dieser Diskussion, der Antisemitismus.
Die Kinder sind immer mobilisierbar in so einer Argumentation.
In der Realität finden aber 10% des Schulunterrichts in Containern statt, für 1% hat man gar keine.
Schulplätze, jedes vierte Kind lebt in Armut, aber im Bundestag,
aber die Kinder, aber die Kinder, aber die Kinder, dafür müssen wir jetzt auch
mal Artikel 1 und so überdenken.
Und so ist das hier auch. Aber der Antisemitismus.
Wir können es ja ganz klar sagen, wir haben ja schon Studenten kennengelernt,
die nicht ihre Projekte gegen Antisemitismus gefördert bekamen,
weil man sagt, es ist kein Geld mehr da.
Wir erleben jetzt gerade in Berlin Kürzungsorgien ohne gleichen.
Zum Beispiel sind da von Häuser betroffen, die dafür stehen,
dass jüdische Kultur in Berlin einen Platz hat, nämlich zum Beispiel die Komische
Oper, die dort die großen jüdischen Operettenkomponisten in den 20er Jahren
hat und dann hat man daran wieder angeknüpft.
Man schlägt alles kurz und klein.
Wir haben lauter Projekte, die darben müssen, weil es nicht mehr weitergeht.
Wir haben Bildungseinrichtungen, die zum Beispiel auch dazu da sind,
über Antisemitismus aufzuklären und dagegen zu arbeiten. All das wird weggekürzt
und zugleich macht man dann irgend so eine Resolution, die jetzt Leuten das Leben schwer macht.
Denn ich war jetzt so in den letzten zwei Monaten ja auf vielen Veranstaltungen
oder auch sonst so privat noch unterwegs und habe immer mal wieder mit Leuten,
die Veranstaltungen organisieren, gesprochen über diese Resolution.
Und das waren alles Leute, die da überhaupt keinen Skin in the Game haben,
aber die sich gar nicht mit einem Ostkonflikt näher auseinandersetzen oder so.
Aber die sagten natürlich folgendes.
Also Förderentscheidungen auf einer kleineren Ebene, Kulturebene,
wo man jetzt ein Literaturfestival oder sonst irgendwas bewilligt haben will,
funktionieren so, dass man versucht einen guten Draht zur Politik zu haben,
dass man sagt, hier wir machen hier das Festival, hat letztes Jahr gut geklappt,
würden wir gerne dieses Jahr wieder machen.
Brauchen etwa dasselbe Geld. Wir brauchen mal 3000 Euro.
Und brauchen mal 3000 Euro. So, das funktioniert.
Wenn man auf dieser Ebene, wenn man jetzt diese Definition hat,
dann findet die Zensur vorher statt.
Man sagt nämlich dann, ja, ich würde ja eigentlich gerne den Autor einladen,
aber ich glaube, der findet die deutsche Außenpolitik in Bezug auf Nahost nicht gut.
Und der redet auch davon, dass das Mord in Gaza sei.
Ich will den zwar einladen, dass der auch seinen Gedichten vorliest,
aber wenn das jetzt jemand mitbekommt von der AfD oder von der CDU,
dann sagen die, nee, dann skandalisieren die das, dann sagen die am Ende noch,
mein Festival ist antisemitisch, also lade ich den lieber gar nicht ein,
weil wer will in diese Diskussion gehen, denn es gibt keine Debatteneröffnung
darüber, sondern es ist eine Schließung, die stattfindet.
Und das ist etwas, was wir da beobachten können.
Und ich sehe auch ja immer diesen Domino-Effekt bei all solchen Resolutionen.
Das ist jetzt das eine. Hier sagt man ja, das ist.
Unsere Staatsräson, das müssen wir hier alles einhalten. Da brauchen wir mal
eine Resolution und da darf nichts gefördert werden.
Wir haben jetzt diese Kürzungsorgien in Berlin und in vielen anderen Städten.
Es gab dann einen RBB-Bericht von einer Berliner Demonstration.
Ich habe den jetzt hier nicht mitgebracht, da werden verschiedene Schauspieler,
unter anderem auch die wunderbare Konstanze Becke interviewt,
warum Theater wichtig ist, etc.
Diesen Bericht postet Ulf Poschert bei Twitter und schreibt darüber Defund the Elfenbeinturm,
Diese Leute verachten in der Regel die Steuerzahler, die ihren Kram finanzieren müssen.
Dann Beatrice Achterberg, NZZ, schreibt, die politische Linke versteht weitaus
besser als liberale oder konservative, wie entscheidend kulturelle Hegemonie ist.
Umso heftiger reagiert sie, wenn es darum geht, dass ihr ureigenes Vorfeld mit
etwas weniger Staatsgeld auskommen soll.
Das heißt, was hier passiert ist, dass man jetzt Kürzungsorgien hat,
die zugleich auch noch von den Rechten beglückwünscht, assistiert werden,
dass man sagt, ja das war eh immer alles so ein linkes Terrain,
wo ich dann auch sagen würde,
also seit wann ist jetzt Oliver Rehse vom Berliner Ensemble oder ist Christian Thielemann links.
Sie machen Kunst, also sind sie links.
Ja, das wird jetzt von den Konservativen da unterstützt und ich will auch mal
und jetzt merkt man natürlich, wenn die Töpfe eh kleiner werden,
werden alle versuchen zu kuschen, damit nicht noch was geschieht und dann werden
jetzt im Vorhinein wird diese Selbstzensur immer stärker stattfinden und die
Resolution ist der Anfang.
Was ist, wenn die nächste Regierung auf die Idee kommt, also ja diese linke
Politik, da hat der Ulf Poschert und die Achterberg, die haben da doch recht,
diese linke Kultur, das müssen wir mal einhegen.
Also es geht doch nicht, dass wir jetzt unsere Eigentumsordnung auf den Kopf stellen lassen.
Wie jetzt noch weiter Berthold Precht im Theater bringen und sollten wir überhaupt
noch Geld geben, wenn Stefan Schulz an eine Volkshochschule eingeladen wird,
denn der will ja Milliardäre abschaffen.
Das heißt, der bedroht die bürgerliche Eigentumsordnung und bedroht doch damit
eigentlich schon die bundesrepublikanische Demokratie und den Frieden.
Den sozialen Frieden.
In diese Richtung geht das alles. Deswegen, ich bin ja ein absoluter Free-Speech-Anhänger
und das zeigt sich nochmal hier so deutlich, weil die Leute,
die sonst für Free-Speech sind, wie Ulf Poschert oder Elon Musk,
sind diejenigen, die sofort zensieren, sobald ihnen was nicht in den Kram passt.
Denn Springer jubelt natürlich über diese Resolution und findet das toll,
dass das endlich umgesetzt wurde.
Theresia Enzensberger hat eigentlich die gute Verknüpfung hergestellt bei einem
Post, bei einer Story auf Instagram.
Da schrieb sie, ich frage mich die ganze Zeit, wie man die Kulturkürzungen und
die Resolution nicht zusammendenken kann.
Es ist doch ganz offensichtlich, was das Ziel ist, alles, was links,
universitätsnah, queer, klimaaktivistisch oder antirassistisch ist,
zu diffamieren und zurückzudrängen, um Diskurs und Deutungshoheit nach rechts zu verlagern.
Die Werkzeuge sind unterschiedlich, aber sie sind alle derselben Strategie rechter Kulturkämpfe.
Schon allein deshalb wäre es sinnvoll, sich nicht auf eine Logik einzulassen,
in der die wenigen verbliebenen Mittel nach politischen Kriterien von Staatsdienern
verteilt werden. Und das findet aber jetzt statt.
Wolfgang, bist du für Filmfestivals, dann bist du antisemit.
Du willst ja nur, dass da deine antisemitischen Filme besprochen werden.
Wir entziehen dir dein Budget.
Ich wurde ja auch, konnte nicht eingeladen werden.
Ich war in der Stadt eingeladen, ich will das nicht sagen, weil ich die Leute da schützen will,
das organisiert werden sollte, das über einen Jugendring heißt das und die machen
hin und wieder Veranstaltungen,
also neben der anderen Arbeit mit Leuten und ich sollte dort aus dem Kinderbuch
vorlesen und mit den Jugendlichen dann ja reden und so einen Vormittag da verbringen.
Und dann wurde von CDU und FDP, die das dann auch im Stadtrat genehmigen müssen,
gesagt, nee, das sei nicht politisch neutral.
Und ich meine, ich kann damit leben, wenn ich wohl nicht eingeladen werde.
Nur das ist ja ganz klar, was jetzt folgt.
Für die Leute, die mich eingeladen haben, die wissen jetzt, okay,
also so Art Leute kann man nicht einladen.
Und was ist dann bitte politisch neutraler?
Ist das dann, irgendjemand von der CDU ist natürlich politisch neutral.
Politisch neutral, was ist denn das bitte für ein Merkmal?
Ja.
Die Veranstaltung ist nicht langweilig genug. Sie darf nicht stattfinden.
In diese Richtung geht das. Und ich finde, da, weil wir über Zäsuren reden,
finde ich, kann man auch nochmal deutlich was sehen, weil ich eben schon sagte, ja,
die Institutionen an sich werden infrage gestellt oder auch die Freiräume,
die Spielräume, die man hatte, wurden infrage gestellt.
Ich habe jetzt mir kürzlich diesen Film angesehen, der jetzt nicht überragend
ist, aber doch ein paar interessante Aspekte hat, über John Krenko.
Das war ein Choreograf, der kam Ende der 60er Jahre aus London nach Stuttgart.
John Krenko musste England quasi verlassen, er hatte da keine berufliche Chance
mehr, er hatte quasi Berufsverbot, weil er schwul war und dann gab es da.
Also hat man ihn in so eine Affäre verwickelt, damit man das groß, damit man ihn los wird.
Nun waren ja die homosexuellen Gesetze in Deutschland nicht viel besser zu der
damaligen Zeit, aber interessanterweise John Krenko wird dann an Stuttgarter
Haus geholt, reformiert dort das Ballett,
was den Stil anbelangt, konfrontiert in einem Stück dann die dort anwesenden
im Publikum mit ihrer Nazi-Vergangenheit, wagt sich weit vor und lebt auch so liberal sein Leben.
Dann habe ich nochmal darüber nachgedacht, dass ich das so sah und das wurde
im Film nicht so klar. Wer hat da eigentlich regiert?
Naja, wer hat das Theater also bezahlt? Baden-Württemberg?
Natürlich CDU regiert von Filbinger, also wirklich rechte CDU.
Stuttgart regiert von der CDU. Man hatte aber diese Freiräume ermöglicht,
weil man die Institutionen an sich wertschätzte und es hat sich wahnsinnig ausgezahlt,
denn Stuttgart erhielt so Weltgeltung als Ballett und hat sie bis heute behalten.
Und da kann man jetzt mal sehen, was da gerade alles zerstört wird,
ohne dass man jetzt sieht, da wird was eingerissen, sondern es findet einfach etwas nicht mehr statt.
Und das ist eine allgemeine Tendenz, die wir beobachten können und die zeigt
sich besonders jetzt hier.
Und für die Wissenschaften ist es dann auch ganz problematisch,
zumal ja, wie Stolberg-Rielinger uns jetzt hier deutlich macht,
die Aufgabe der Wissenschaft eigentlich eine andere ist, als eine Definition zu akzeptieren.
Vor allem aber, und das ist noch viel grundsätzlicher aus der Perspektive der
wissenschaftlichen Autonomie,
Definitionen sind grundsätzlich Gegenstand wissenschaftlicher Auseinandersetzung und Kontroverse.
Und das ist bei der Definition von Antisemitismus erst recht der Fall.
Und eine Definition politisch vorzugeben und damit schon eine bestimmte Partei
in dieser Debatte zu ergreifen,
in dieser wirklich intensiven Kontroverse zu ergreifen und sich auf eine bestimmte
Position festzulegen, ist mit wissenschaftlicher Autonomie unvereinbar.
Wissenschaftsfreiheit, wie gesagt, grundgesetzlich garantiert,
bedeutet ja in ihrem Kern, dass Kontroversen mit den Mitteln der Wissenschaft ausgetragen werden.
Ja, eigentlich so logisch. Wir hören sie jetzt nochmal.
Als Antisemiten diffamiert werden, um ihre Regierungs-, also kritisch gegenüber
der israelischen Regierung ihre Haltung zu diffamieren und zum Schweigen zu bringen.
Und das funktioniert auch bereits sehr, sehr gut, nämlich in Form vorauseilender Selbstzensur.
Und wir haben alle noch vor Augen den sogenannten Fördergeldantrag,
den ich jetzt hier nicht im Einzelnen ausführen muss, den ich als bekannt voraussetze,
wo mit wünschenswerter Deutlichkeit von dem Staatssekretär Philippi genau das
formuliert worden ist, nämlich es ist wünschenswert, dass Leute,
die er als verwirrte Gestalten bezeichnet, die aber weltweit renommierte Holocaustforscher sind,
dass die von sich aus schon bestimmte Themen vermeiden bzw.
Bestimmte Positionen nicht mehr artikulieren.
Das heißt, die Kontroverse wird unterbunden, also dort, wo sie eigentlich beginnen sollte.
Ich habe selber damals jahrelang gesagt, solange Netanjahu regiert,
sage ich nichts dazu. Das ist quasi diese Selbstzensur.
Und ich war noch nicht mal budgetabhängig davon, sondern ich hätte wahrscheinlich
ein gutes Podcast-Fundament schaffen können, indem ich sage,
jetzt mal, was ich wirklich denke.
Ja, Matthias Goldmann kommt jetzt zu Wort, der ist Lehrstuhlinhaber für internationales
Recht an der EBS-Universität Wiesbaden.
Dort werden Länder, Bund und Kommunen aufgefordert, haushältische Regelungen
zu erarbeiten, ich zitiere, die sicherstellen sollen, dass keine Projekte und
Vorhaben insbesondere mit antisemitischen Zielen und Inhalten gefördert werden.
Und hier stellt sich die große Frage, wie kann man das feststellen,
auf eine Art und Weise, die unseren Rechtsstaat und unsere liberale Demokratie nicht beschädigt.
Denn man kann sich denken, in solchen Anträgen würde ja nicht drinstehen,
wir verfolgen ein antisemitisches Ziel.
Goldman sagt jetzt.
Der Grund ist, dass es extrem schwierig ist, für ein Projekt,
das im Zeitpunkt der Antragstellung regelmäßig noch nicht existiert,
festzustellen, ob es antisemitische Inhalte enthält oder nicht.
Wie wollen Sie es feststellen?
Hier kommt jetzt meine Erfahrung mit Schleswig-Holstein in das Spiel.
In Schleswig-Holstein gibt es einen Gesetzesvorschlag, wie das denn umgesetzt werden könnte.
Dort heißt es, die Zuwendungen sollen unter die Voraussetzung gestellt werden,
dass nur Empfängerinnen und Empfänger gefördert werden,
von denen bekannt ist oder bei denen offensichtlich ist, dass sie sich zu einer
vielfältigen Gesellschaft bekennen oder und gegen jedwede Diskriminierung und
Ausgrenzung stellen und jede Form von Antisemitismus ablehnen.
Das heißt, es muss schon bekannt sein.
Also muss man es bekannt machen.
Wie wollen Sie das feststellen? Das steht nicht im Gesetz drin.
Wie wollen Sie es feststellen?
Was man dann macht, ist, man knüpft sozusagen an die Person an oder an die Organisation.
Sprich, wir haben es hier wieder zu tun mit Listen.
Ja, dann sagt man einfach folgende Liste, die dürfen gefördert werden,
die anderen nicht und die müssen sich bekennen und das ist genau das Falsche,
was ich ja eben sagte, deswegen machen mich diese, also diejenigen,
die pro-palästinensische Protestler sind, auch ebenso wütend,
die von israelischen Künstlern einfordern, dass die sich bitte dazu positionieren sollen.
Nein, es ist die Freiheit der Kunst und es ist die Freiheit der Wissenschaft
und es muss nicht jeder vorab ein Bekenntnis ablegen.
Und mich macht das wütend, dass wir jetzt in diesen Tribalismus überall verfallen.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt jetzt auf diese Nan Golden Ausstellung in Berlin,
werde ich sie mir ansehen.
Und ich finde auch gut, dass das stattgefunden hat.
Ich finde die Rede auch, die sie gehalten hat, nicht skandalös,
sondern sie macht eine Schweigeminute für alle. Und zwar auch für die Opfer des 7.
Oktober. Und dann fängt sie an, darüber zu reden, was falsch läuft und wie Deutschland
sich schuldig macht an diesen Verbrechen dort in Gaza.
Und sie wird dann da angegangen und natürlich der Leiter der Galerie muss sich
dann davon distanzieren, weil der auch schon ahnt, dass ihm sonst irgendwelche
Fördermittel weggehen und da ist ja auch privates Geld drin,
dass da auch aus gewissen Richtungen.
Der Springerleute kommt, wie ich weiß. Und so merken wir dann,
dass da also, das nochmal so, einmal darf das sein, aber wer wird sich das nochmal
ahnen, Wer wird sich das nochmal geben, so jemand einzuladen, wo dann sowas passiert?
Und hier können wir auch nicht, und ich will jetzt nochmal sagen mit dieser
Bekenntniskultur, ich gehe in diese Nengoldenausstellung, weil mich diese Kunst interessiert.
Ich würde aber auch in diese einen goldenen Ausstellung gehen,
wenn sie glühende Netanjahu-Anhängerin wäre, weil sie gute Kunst macht.
Und das ist etwas, was immer mehr verloren geht.
Es geht nur noch darum, zu welcher politischen Ideologie oder sonst was bekennt
sich irgendein Künstler.
Ich will es nochmal zuspitzen, denn wir kennen das ja, dass irgendwelche Gesetze
oder Resolutionen Titel tragen, aber eigentlich anderes in der Box lauert.
Wir haben zum Beispiel in Frankfurt eine Waffenverbotszone im Bahnhofsviertel
und jetzt denkt jeder, na klar, Waffen verboten ist doch gut, kein Leid.
Nur die Waffenverbotszone ist natürlich, wenn man sie ernsthaft benamen würde,
nach der Funktion, die sie hat,
eine, die Polizei darf dich hier anlasslos überall kontrollieren, Zone.
Was hier bedeutet, der stolze Kampf gegen Antisemitismus ist ein Unterdrückungskampf
gegen palästinensische Meinung.
Und zwar alle palästinensischen Meinungen, da jedes palästinensische Leben von
dem, wie es uns heute interessiert, das nämlich in einem Konflikt gerade zu Hause ist,
uns eine Mitteilung macht zum Thema israelische Politik.
Und es geht darum, alle zu unterdrücken. Das ist ein Unterdrückungsgesetz, diese Resolution.
Eine Meinungsunterdrückungsgesetzgebung.
Jetzt werden manche sagen, ja, aber es gibt doch israelbezogenen Antisemitismus
und ich würde sagen, ja natürlich.
Und der hat auch zugenommen und der nimmt auch noch weiter zu, so mein Verdacht.
Und der wird auch von pro-palästinensischen Aktivisten mitunter artikuliert.
Aber wenn ich jetzt alle über einen Kamm schere, dann tue ich denen ja allen
Unrecht und will eigentlich Meinung generell unterdrücken.
Worum es doch gehen muss, ist, dass man in der Sache dann darüber streitet und
dass man auch ganz klare rote Linien, und die sind schon längst da,
nämlich im Strafrecht, dass man diese benannt hat.
Aber sobald wir darüber hinausgehen, schränken wir ja den Diskurs und die liberale
Demokratie in einem ganz erheblichen Maße ein.
Also ich verstehe gar nicht, also das ist so ein Fanatismus und ich sehe den
Fanatismus auch bei anderen und ich sehe auch natürlich wie gerade in einer
Künstlerszene einer internationalen plötzlich Hamas-Leute als Widerstandskämpfer
dargestellt werden. Und das empört mich auch.
Ich fand es schon erstaunlich, als sich Tanahesi Coates,
einer der Lieblingsschriftsteller von Obama, bei Esra Klein im Podcast hörte,
der dann von Esra Klein für einiges kritisiert wird, bei vielen sind sie sich
einer Meinung und dann aber darauf angesprochen wird.
Dass ja doch dieser Terroranschlag der Hamas, beziehungsweise dieses Pogrom der Hamas vom 7.
Oktober doch auch mal entsprechend eingeordnet werden müsse.
Und Tanahesikos dann so ganz zurückhaltend bleibt und man irgendwie so denkt,
ja, aber das ist zu verurteilen, da muss man jetzt nicht lange rum lavieren und zögern.
Das finde ich schon skandalös, dass das auf der internationalen Ebene so stattfindet
und dass das so an sich anerkannte Schriftsteller tun.
Und da muss ich aber auch sagen, das würde jetzt mich nicht dazu führen,
irgendeine Resolution zu verabschieden, sondern man muss dann,
und Israel Klein macht das in diesem Gespräch ja auch dann, man muss dann dem
gegenüber treten und sagen, so nicht.
Und das ist ja etwas, was doch diskursiv ausgehandelt werden kann und da kann
man auch sagen, nee, bis hierhin noch nicht weiter.
Aber ich finde, also für sich kann man das sagen und das kann man auch in der
Diskussion sehr deutlich machen und ich werde auch gleich noch eine kritische
Anmerkung zu Susan Neiman liefern,
aber da muss man doch nicht mit solchen Präambeln davor gehen und erst einmal
gar nicht mehr die Diskussion aufkommen lassen.
Ich finde es eigenartig. Goldman weist dann auch mal darauf hin,
dass diese Aira-Definition ja auch mal für was anderes gedacht war.
Ich glaube, diese Definition sollte man nicht unterschätzen.
Ich glaube, es ist eine Definition, die hat einen Wert für das,
wofür sie geschaffen war. Das ist nämlich Bildungsarbeit.
Sie soll Gedenkstätten, die ja auch sehr präventiv tätig sind,
sehr langfristig tätig sind, sensibilisieren für antisemitische Inhalte und
auch ihre Arbeit leiten.
Die Arbeit einer Verwaltung, die Mittel erteilt, ist aber etwas grundsätzlich anderes.
Eine Verwaltung braucht bestimmte
Begriffe oder zumindest hinreichend konkret bestimmbare Begriffe,
die sich dann auch in einer gerichtlichen Auseinandersetzung sozusagen verteidigen lassen,
also deren Anwendung vorhersehbar sein kann auch für die Betroffenen und deren
Verständnis sowohl durch die Verwaltung als auch die Gerichte feststehen kann.
Und das ist bei einer Definition, die so offen ist wie die IHRA-Definition, leider nicht der Fall.
Sie spricht ja nur ganz allgemein von Antisemitismus als einer bestimmten Wahrnehmung
von Jüdinnen und Juden, die sich als Hass gegenüber Jüdinnen und Juden ausdrücken kann.
Da ist schon was Wahres dran. Also im Kern ist das eine richtige Überlegung,
der ich auch folgen kann.
Aber die Frage ist, wie stellen wir das fest?
Und da kommt man einfach dann nur noch dazu, dass man eine Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahme
für die Gerichte produziert, aber sonst geht das nicht.
Und Goldmann weist noch auf was Interessantes hin.
Und ich denke, um es vielleicht auch damit abzuschließen, ich denke,
die Resolution selbst trägt den Stachel hier in sich.
Die Resolution selbst zeigt, wie schwer es ist, das festzustellen.
Es gibt nicht eine klaffende Lücke in der Resolution.
Die Resolution erwähnt nicht den wohl offensichtlichsten antisemitischen Vorfall
in Deutschland der letzten Jahre.
Das ist der Angriff auf die Synagoge in Halle.
Kommt nicht vor. Aber wir haben die Berlinale drin. Du hast doch ganz erstaunlich.
Ich finde das eh crazy. Also stehen die so als empirische Illustrationen oder
damit man es erkennt oder warum stehen in der Resolutionen überhaupt so?
Um das nochmal deutlich zu machen, daran kann man es einfach so beim Messen
sagen, ist das so eine Rede in etwa wie auf der Berlinale Bühne, dann geht es nicht.
Mit Halle ist ja eh, also der hat damals auf diese Tür geschossen und kam aber nicht durch.
Wenn er durchgekommen wäre, wären das 70 Tote gewesen.
Die Tragweite dessen wird eh ausgeblendet, denn wir haben es ja hier mit einem
Gewaltakt zu tun, der sich nun mal durch Resolution nicht aufhalten lässt,
sondern, das sage ich jetzt ausdrücklich, allenfalls noch anfachen.
Ich habe das schon häufiger betont, dieses Phänomen und es gibt dazu auch wissenschaftliche Literatur.
Wenn Menschen den Staat ablehnen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
die sie so persönlich haben, suchen die sich einen Themeneinschlag,
bei dem sie wissen, der kommt dort an.
Also wenn ich einfach sage, heute ist eine Steinmeier-Rede und ich gehe hin
und brülle den Bundespräsidenten an, dass mir die Butter zu teuer ist,
wird nicht funktionieren.
Wenn der Bundespräsident aber kommt, um eine Rede gegen Antisemitismus zu halten,
verwandle ich mich im Kopf in ein Antisemiten, weil ich damit die Opposition
darstellen kann und weiß, damit werde ich gehört.
Was bedeutet, wenn solche Resolutionen geschrieben werden und die Debatten so
laufen, wie sie laufen, nämlich die Resolution ist weich, nicht aussagekräftig genug,
ihre Zielsetzung ist umstritten und so weiter und so fort.
Und die Bundestagsdebatten zeigen mir einfach nur, dass da Leute all in gehen.
Hauptsache, ich kriege jetzt keine Tweets am Ende des Tages für meine Rede oder sowas.
Ja, nichts falsch machen.
Genau, nichts falsch machen. Bedeutet, dass auf der anderen Seite wird die Zielsetzung unterminiert.
Die Leute stellen fest, ach Antisemitismus ist das, wie ich den Staat ärgern
kann, dann bin ich jetzt Antisemit.
Und diese Gefahr steckt da einfach mit drin, dass man durch eine Resolution,
die man im Bundestag zwischen Häppchen und Feierabendausklang zu weihen und
so weiter, also bewirtete Termine in der Politik, wie wir es ganz häufig haben,
eine Entkopplung haben, die zu Reaktionen führt.
Und wenn man das nicht einpreist, ist das einfach ein Problem.
Ich meine, diese Resolution wurde ja nach dem Bruch der Ampel, also du siehst ja.
Der Staat fällt aus, aber das kriegt er hin. Genau, da siehst du doch eigentlich.
Wie Scholz sagte doch, ja und da müssen wir jetzt so zusammenarbeiten und dann
hast du eben gesagt, naja, das war ja gut gemeint, aber sparen wird das nicht so wollen.
Aber hier hat das ja wunderbar funktioniert.
Pass auf, dann ist die Pointe wie folgt, die Ampel hat ja noch ein zweites Thema
nach ihrem Bruch hinbekommen in einem erfolgreichen parlamentarischen Prozess,
nämlich sich für die Wehrpflicht auszusprechen.
Also die jungen Menschen unter den Bus zu werfen und das jüdische Leben in Deutschland
nochmal zu verkomplizieren durch einen sowieso schon zerstrittenen Haufen in Berlin,
der sie jetzt glaubt über Antisemitismus, also beim Antisemitismus können wir
plötzlich eine Einheit herstellen, obwohl alle wissen, die zoffen sich gerade und da läuft gar nichts.
Das ist wirklich die falsche Rezeptur für beide Themen.
Und jetzt haben wir von Halle gesprochen, was ganz aktuell ist von Twitter.
Der Account Ostthüringer Divan hat darüber berichtet gestern.
Folgendes schreibt er, mit einem Bild dann auch der Protagonisten.
Gestern wurde auf der Nazi-Demo in Gera ein Gedicht der Holocaust-Leugnerin
Haverbeck vorgetragen.
Es ging um die, Anführungszeichen, große Lüge.
Und die Teilnehmer quittierten das Gedicht mit Applaus.
Ruft euch das in Erinnerung, wenn wieder jemand beschwichtigt,
die Teilnehmer wehren nicht rechts und so weiter.
Dann lese ich dazu, habe ich gedacht, Gera, was ist denn da eigentlich los?
Ich lese dann in einem Artikel, auch sehr aktuell, aus der Jungle World folgendes.
Gera ist mit 95.000 Einwohnern die drittgrößte Stadt in Thüringen.
Seit mehreren Jahren finden hier fast jede Woche rechtsextreme Montagsdemos
statt, organisiert von Christian Klar, einem seit langem aktiven Neonazi.
Die Stadtverwaltung beklagte auf Anfrage des MDR, die Montagsdemonstrationen
seien für Gera ein großer Imageschaden und ein Problem für die Menschen.
Die Außenwirkung der Stadt.
Lösen wolle man dies vor allem durch Dialog. Die Stadt plane deshalb einen Termin
mit allen Beteiligten, sagte eine Pressesprecherin im MDR Anfang Oktober.
Auf Anfrage der Jungle World, ob die Stadt auch versuche, mit dem Neonazi Christian
Klar in Dialog zu treten, antwortete eine Sprecherin, man habe explizit nicht
davon gesprochen, dass der Dialog mit Christian Klar gesucht wird.
Man wolle Wollte lediglich, Zitat, mit Partnern und Vertretern aus Politik unabhängig
von der parteipolitischen Farbe ins Gespräch kommen.
Auf die Nachfrage, ob die Teilnahme von Christian Klar in diesem Dialog vorgesehen
ist, gab es keine Antwort mehr.
Also das ist eine Normalisierung von Antisemitismus in einem Maße,
wie man es sich gar nicht vorstellen kann, dass man sagt, die klatschen zwar
in einem Gedicht von Haverbeck, aber wir machen mal einen schönen Dialog.
Und zugleich sagt man Betroffenen aus Israel, die auf einer Bühne sagen,
so geht das nicht und meine Regierung macht hier,
Zweiklassenpolitik und alles mögliche und richtet Verbrechen an,
dass die Antisemiten sind, die dürfen nicht mehr nach Berlin kommen.
Das kriegt man doch gar nicht mehr zusammen.
Du willst ein Filmfestival machen und bist jung und Student.
Antisemit, hier ist unsere Resolution. Ist nicht.
Und dort, kommen Sie bitte zum Dialog.
Lassen vielleicht das Haverbeck-Gedicht zu Hause, aber wir können gerne reden.
Hans Jessen war auch bei dieser Pressekonferenz und hatte dann gefragt,
ob das nicht eigentlich an den radikalen Erlass erinnert, wo ja Beamte damals
nochmal so ein besonderes Bekenntnis zum Staat ablegen mussten.
Liegt eigentlich nah und ich dachte auch daran, Goldmann sagt dann folgendes dazu.
Es gibt aber einen großen entscheidenden Unterschied. Beim radikalen Erlass
ging es um Beamtenernennung.
Von Beamten kann der Staat ein hohes Maß an Loyalität erwarten und muss es auch erwarten können.
Hier geht es um Kunst, Wissenschaft, auch um Presse und Rundfunk oder um Meinungsfreiheit.
Und das sind alles gesellschaftliche Bereiche, die nach dem Grundgesetz staatsfern sein sollen.
Es darf keinen Staatsfunk geben. Der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk ist ja unabhängig.
Es darf keine staatlich verordnete Kunst geben oder Wissenschaft.
Goldman sagt außerdem, dass er davon ausgeht, dass die deutsche Justiz gut arbeiten
wird. Das Problem liegt nur woanders.
Ich habe selbst sehr großes Vertrauen in die deutsche Justiz,
dass sie eine ordentliche Arbeit
machen wird, dass sie überschießende Tendenzen hier beseitigen wird.
Allerdings wird in vielen Fällen, wenn Projekte gar nicht erst zustande kommen,
schon rein rechtlich erst niemals zu einer Gerichtsentscheidung kommen.
Oder in Fällen, wo Förderungen dann entzogen werden zum Beispiel,
wird es Jahre später nach vielen Instanzen, die meistens finanziell nicht sehr
schlagkräftigen Akteure aus dem Kultur- oder Wissenschaftsbereich kaum durchstehen können,
dann irgendwann mal zu einer Entscheidung kommen, wenn das Kind längst in den Brunnen gefallen ist.
Wie würde das dann eigentlich aussehen, wenn man das konsequent durchsetzt?
Stolberg-Rehlinger skizziert es.
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass wenn wir diese Maßnahmen, die hier in dem Antrag
beschrieben sind, wenn wir die streng anlegen würden,
dann könnten wir sehr, sehr viele sowohl jüdische Israelis als auch Juden aus
der ganzen Welt nicht mehr einladen.
Beziehungsweise wenn wir sie einlüden, dann würden sie das im Grunde als Affront
wahrnehmen, wenn wir als deutsche Einrichtung von ihnen verlangen,
dass sie eine nicht antisemitische Gesinnung dokumentieren sollen.
Man muss sich vorstellen, wie grotesk das ist, wenn ich einen jüdischen Israeli
einlade und von dem ein Bekenntnis gegen Antisemitismus verlange, als Deutsche.
Ja, das Problem hier ist so ein bisschen, das Jüdische Museum in Frankfurt zum Beispiel...
Stellt ja die, also nicht nur Antisemitismus gar nicht so in den Mittelpunkt,
sondern auch der Zweite Weltkrieg, der Holocaust und so ist jetzt gar nicht so das prägende Ding.
Die haben ja auch Ausstrahlung zu filmen.
Genau, über jüdisches Leben. Aber sie legen eben sehr viel Wert drauf,
dass die Exponate, die sie haben, gerade wenn es statt in die historische und
ästhetische Richtung geht, dass das jüdische Exponate sind.
Was zum Beispiel bedeutet, dass auch Fotografien zum Thema, wenn sie nicht von
einem jüdischen Künstler oder Fotografen gemacht werden, dort nicht so richtig,
sondern die müssten dann woanders stattfinden.
Was bedeutet, Menschen, die sich für jüdische Themen interessieren,
zum Beispiel durch das reichhaltige Leben in Frankfurt vor dem Holocaust,
fällt es durch solche Aktionen eigentlich zunehmend schwerer,
ihre Aktionen außerhalb des jüdischen Museums oder im Kontext des jüdischen
Museums zu machen, weil sie ja dann ein Projekt haben, an dem auch das Label jüdisch hängt.
Was immer Gefahr bedeutet, dass es da auch um Themen geht oder wie sie jetzt betonte,
ist derjenige denn komplett auf Linie Netanyahu oder nicht, also diese Verknüpfung,
die dann da hergestellt wird,
die ist dem ja wirklich sehr abträglich, was nicht nur bedeutet,
hier finden keine palästinensischen Meinungen statt, sondern man nimmt auch
Abstand vor allem, was irgendwie jüdisch aussieht, weil man dann die ganze Zeit
mit diesem Apparat zu tun hat.
Bekenntnisse hier, Budgetforderung da, dann ist das alles dreimal so aufwendig,
muss fünfmal durchdacht werden und so.
Und das wird auch die Präsentation, Darstellung, wie auch immer.
Ja, Nengolden ist ja schon so ein Beispiel. Die hat jetzt da diese Retrospektive bekommen.
Wir wissen, wenn jetzt darüber entschieden würde, ob die Retrospektive kommt,
dann würde man aufgrund der Resolution sagen,
da sie, ich glaube sogar BDS-Unterstützerin oder so, wird man sagen,
nee, das machen wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Die kann jetzt nicht mehr eingeladen werden. Und gerade da, wo die Zweifelsfälle
sind, wo man nicht so genau weiß, wird man sie eher nicht einladen.
Also ich würde auch da mitgehen und sagen, ja, das ist auch eine Resolution,
die sehr viele jüdische Wissenschaftler und Künstler hart trifft,
die einfach aus so einem Verdachtsfall oder aus so einem,
naja, wollen wir uns mal nicht in die Nesseln setzen, lassen wir mal lieber,
dann einfach rausgenommen werden, bevor man da irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten erhält.
Ich habe noch im Ohr, wie Michael Friedmann gefragt wird, zu irgendwelchen Themen,
Und er dann so nach 10, 20 Minuten einfach mal kurz sagen musste,
sorry, aber nur weil ich jüdische Vorfahren habe und ein jüdisches Leben für,
heißt das nicht, dass ich ihn jetzt Netanyahu erklären kann oder den Gaza-Konflikt.
Ich wollte eigentlich philosophisch zum Thema Sexualität, keine Ahnung,
irgendwas und so. Wir sind doch hier beim Operngespräch.
Und das ist wirklich, jetzt wo ich so drüber nachdenke, doch ein ganz schön großes Problem,
wenn wir so eine Resolution haben, dass wir auch in Deutschland nur noch beispielsweise
mit Juden reden können, wenn wir wirklich wissen, wie die sich bisher lang zu
ihrer eigenen Regierung so verhalten haben.
Das ist ja völlig grotesk. Ja, ich will jedoch mal einen Widerspruch hier artikulieren
und das ist jetzt mein Widerspruch einfach nur,
der soll nicht in der Resolution gegossen werden, aber ich sehe tatsächlich
da eine allgemeine Tendenz, die ich nicht unterstützen würde und zwar Susan
Neimann, wir haben auch mal über ein Buch von ihr, Links ist nicht Vogue gesprochen,
Stefan liebt es, nee, du möchtest es gar nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, bitte hier keine falsche Werte.
Nein, ich habe es ja jetzt auch nicht über den grünen Klee gelobt.
Jedenfalls ist sie da auch mit bei dieser Pressekonferenz und äußert sich da.
Und es geht da um einen gewissen Punkt, nämlich um das Weltnis von Antisemitismus
und Rassismus. Sie sagt folgendes.
Ich weiß, dabei stoßt man gegen ein merkwürdiges deutsches Tabu,
nämlich Rassismus und Antisemitismus irgendwie in Verbindung zu bringen.
Das ist nur in Deutschland ein Tabu, muss ich euch sagen.
Also das ist überall diskutiert von vielen Juden, von vielen Nichtjuden.
Ich kenne die Argumente. Wir hatten Historikerstreit 2.0 vor zwei Jahren.
Es gibt historische Gründe, warum der Antisemitismus anders ist.
Prinzipiell, wenn man eine Gruppe von Menschen aufgrund ihrer ethnischen Zugehörigkeit
diskriminiert oder verfolgt, ist das Rassismus, ob gegen Juden oder gegen Schwarzen.
Es gibt übrigens eine Bewegung in den USA, die ziemlich gefährlich werden konnte, was ich ablehne.
Das heißt Afropessimismus. Und da sind Vertreter, die behaupten wollen,
nein, der Rassismus gegenüber Schwarzen ist älter und schrecklicher und länger.
Man kann diese Opferspiele ausspielen, es bringt aber nichts.
Aus letzterem stimme ich zu. Ich bin jetzt auch nicht dafür,
hier eine Opfer-Hierarchie einzuführen und zu sagen, das ist wirklich zynisch, das jetzt zu machen.
Was ich aber kritisiere und das ist eine allgemeine Tendenz,
die sie jetzt hier nur abbildet, ist tatsächlich die, und das kommt aus einem
internationalen Kontext, ich würde auch sagen sehr stark US-amerikanischen Kontext,
der geprägt ist auch sehr von Postcolonial Studies, dass man Antisemitismus
und Rassismus zusammendenkt.
Ich halte das für falsch. Ich bin für eine Unterscheidung.
Wenn ich natürlich sage, bei Antisemitismus werden Menschen diskriminiert und
bei Rassismus werden Menschen diskriminiert, dann stimmt das natürlich.
Dann können wir noch Homophobie und weiteres dazufügen.
Und das ist auch so richtig. Und wir können auch feststellen,
zumindest hat es die Geschichte gezeigt, dass sehr häufig Leute,
die rassistisch waren, auch zugleich antisemitisch und homophob und so weiter waren.
Das ist auch eine historische Tatsache. Und doch hat der Antisemitismus noch
ein paar andere Gesichter als der Rassismus.
Der Rassismus arbeitet vorwiegend damit, dass es Menschen gibt,
die unter den Weißen stehen.
Also Schwarze, die nicht den gleichen Wert haben.
Und deswegen müssen sie beherrscht werden. Das ist beim Rassismus ganz stark.
Bei dem Antisemitismus ist zum Beispiel oft das Gegenteil der Fall.
Nämlich zu sagen, die jüdische Intelligenz, die beherrscht uns.
Das ist ganz gefährlich. Wir werden von den Juden beherrscht,
wir sind gar nicht frei in unserem Land und so weiter.
Das ist zum Beispiel ein antisemitischer Diskurs.
Das heißt zweitens, dass Antisemitismus schnell ein Welterklärungsmodell wird.
Warum läuft es mit der Wirtschaft so schlecht? Die Antwort der Nazis oder auch
eines heutigen Antisemitismus mitunter lautet, also bei Breivik oder anderen
konnte man das finden, die Juden sind daran schuld.
Und deswegen würde ich auch nochmal sagen, gibt es einen israelbezogenen Antisemitismus,
wenn mitunter alle anderen Ungerechtigkeiten in der Welt ausgeblendet wird und
man nur noch so tut, als sei Israel als Aggresso das einzige Problem in der
Welt und darauf müssen wir uns jetzt ganz konzentrieren und all unsere Aufmerksamkeit dem schenken.
Und das findet mitunter bei einigen Aktivisten statt, gerade so aus dem internationalen
Kontext und durchaus auch aus dem linken Künstlerkontext.
Und deswegen würde ich sagen, muss man es unterscheiden. Und drittens.
Adorno sagt, Antisemitismus, das ist dieses Gerücht vom Juden.
Und das ist auch nochmal was anderes wie beim Rassismus.
Es ist so dieses Unsichtbare.
Überall ist irgendwie der Jude eine Bedrohung für das gesunde Volk oder was auch immer.
Das sind antisemitische Narrative, die so nicht zu finden sind bei den rassistischen Narrativen.
Das sind andere. Womit ich nicht jetzt eine Hierarchie aufmachen will,
womit ich nur sagen will, es ist glaube ich schon hilfreich,
beide Sachen voneinander zu trennen, um zum Beispiel auch zu sehen,
es gibt Leute, die können rassistisch sein und sind nicht antisemitisch und
es gibt Leute, die können antisemitisch sein, sind aber nicht rassistisch.
Aber was sie beide dann eint, diese Gruppen sind, dass sie Menschen diskriminieren.
Aber ich glaube, dass wir diese Trennung von Antisemitismus und Rassismus weiterhin
machen sollten, nicht zuletzt um die Singularität des Holocaust zu verstehen.
Und um daraus dann auch begriffscharf gucken zu können, wo haben wir es denn
tatsächlich mal mit Antisemitismus zu tun, denn den gibt es ja und der nimmt
auch zu und wo haben wir es mit Rassismus zu tun.
Und diese Trennung scheint mir sehr wichtig und wenn man das jetzt alles sonst
nur unter diesem Postcolonial Aspekt sieht und dann wie sie das jetzt beschreibt,
wie Susan Neumann das beschreibt,
so eine Opferhierarchie und all das einführt.
Dann kommt man damit in Teufelsküche.
Und ich halte das für falsch und würde sagen, dass das etwas ist,
wo auch gerade die Antisemitismusforschung in Deutschland große Verdienste hat
und diese auch wieder mehr nach vorne zu stellen und vielleicht ein bisschen
gewisse postkoloniale Theorien,
Diskurse, die sehr überhand genommen haben, vielleicht auch an manchen Stellen,
denen etwas entgegenzusetzen, argumentativ, halte ich für sehr wichtig.
Da helfen uns aber keine Resolutionen und No-Gos und so weiter in irgendeiner
Weise weiter, sondern hier ist es eigentlich wichtig, dass gerade die Diskussion
wieder richtig geführt wird.
Und da glaube ich ist eigentlich der interessante Punkt zu führen,
nicht diese Vermischung jetzt vorzunehmen von ja alles irgendwie Diskriminierung,
dann kommt man nicht mit weiter.
Man muss es auch hier klar benennen, was los ist.
Also ich fand ja auch schon ihren Vorschlag mit Woke ist nicht links, wo ich dachte,
nee natürlich nicht, wer hat das denn vorher verwechselt und dass Rassismus
historisch eher Vernachlässigung, Unterdrückung, Ausbeutung bedeutet und Antisemitismus
eben ein klares Vernichtungsziel hat.
Könnte man ja durchaus als Ausgangspunkt für eine Resolution oder eine Neudefinition
von Antisemitismus nehmen, was aber dann bedeutet…
Eine Kulturveranstaltung, bei dem jemand auf einen tatsächlichen Krieg aus persönlicher
Sicht reagiert und einen Film macht, kann man die Prüfung einfach laufen lassen,
möchte der wirklich alle Juden der Welt vernichten oder wollte er einfach nur einen Punkt machen.
Und dann käme man ganz schnell auf so vernünftigen Pfade, den man dann eben
auch historisch wirklich aus dem Holocaust ableiten kann, ohne dann große Verwechslungen
zu machen im Sinne von naja Juden, es gibt ja auch noch andere Opfer oder sowas,
sondern ne, es sind halt spezifische Opfer.
Dieser Weg wird dann nicht gegangen und das ist nicht gut, was du uns vorgestellt
hast zum Resolutionsding ist wirklich gruselig und insbesondere möchte ich sagen kontraproduktiv.
Das ist wirklich kontraproduktiv, sondern weil hier, ich höre schon wieder so
eine Menosphäre eigener Art, die dann sagt, die Juden haben es schon wieder
geschafft, ihren Kopf aus der Schlinge zu ziehen,
das Establishment und so weiter haben sie dahin gebracht, für sie jetzt so einen
Scheiß zu veranstalten, unsere, die Meinungsweise zu nehmen.
Genau, und das soll ja genau verhindert werden, also das ist ja auch etwas,
wogegen sich dann zum Beispiel Susan Neiman wendet.
Ich hätte noch gerade einen Anschluss, ganz kurz müssen wir noch,
bevor wir zu einem anderen Thema kommen, über Meinungsfreiheit weitersprechen.
Dann müssen wir nochmal zurück zu meinen Clips, denn es ist ja nicht das Einzige,
was jetzt für die Meinungsfreiheit relevant ist, sondern gehen wir mal zu den
Clips, zu den Dreierclips.
Und zwar Trusted Flagger. Hat dich das beschäftigt jetzt in den letzten Wochen?
Ich weiß, dass es jetzt einen gibt.
Ja.
Irgendwer darf jetzt Trusted Flaggen. Ich sag denk mir nur, naja,
bei Blue Sky sicherlich nicht, also ist mir eigentlich egal.
Na ja, doch, bei Blue Sky natürlich auch.
Ja, gut.
Da kann das auch passieren.
Da machen bisher irgendwie 100 Leute Moderation und die EU hat auch schon drauf
hingewiesen, liebe Blue Sky, ihr seid so groß, für euch gelten ja auch Gesetze
und zwar habe ich heute bei Haken dran gehört.
Das ist eine sehr lustige Aufarbeitung, ohne dass wir euch darauf hinweisen müssen.
So im Sinne von der Lehrer sagt, sorry, ich muss dich nicht darauf hinweisen,
dass du die Hausaufgaben machen musst. Also mal gucken, wie es mit Blue Sky
weitergeht. Aber ich glaube, das ist mehr ein Twitter-Ding jetzt.
Ja, aber auch weit darüber hinaus. Also es geht ja um diesen DSA,
den Digital Services Act.
Und dieser gilt nun seit November 2022.
Und der besagt, dass diese Inhalte überprüft werden müssen, die dort auf den Plattformen sind.
Jetzt kann man sich ja erstmal überlegen, warum machen die Plattformen das nicht
einfach selbst, warum brauchen die da nochmal extern was und wer ist das Externe überhaupt?
Und zwar soll es da Trusted Flagger geben, das hat also für viel Furore gesorgt,
gerade bei Rechten, weil da zum Beispiel die Meldestelle Respekt benannt wurde.
Das ist eine Stiftung, die wird gefördert durch Baden-Württemberg, vom Staate.
Und da heißt es also, dass für diese Meldestelle fünf festangestellte Personen
arbeiten und zwölf juristische Fachkräfte auf Honorarbasis, also es ist eine kleine Stelle,
aber man hatte da Clips gesehen aus einer älteren Dokumentation.
Wie also dort Inhalte, wo sie sagen, ja das ist irgendwie problematisch, geflaggt werden.
Trusted Flagger meint, dass dann die Plattformen, wenn sie von diesen Trusted
Flaggern Nachricht bekommen, schneller reagieren müssen, sie können das also
dann nicht einfach mal so aussitzen und die Frage ist,
taucht damit jetzt ein neuer Zensurapparat auf, weil man hat ja quasi ausgeflaggt
jetzt, dass die Behörde einfach,
die Strafbehörde dem nachgeht, sondern dass man nochmal so einen externen,
ja oder sagen wir, ist das sowas wie ein kleines Wahrheitsministerium, das man eingeführt hat.
So weit brauchen wir hier nicht zu gehen, aber ich sehe durchaus Probleme damit,
wenn wir hier über die Meinungsfreiheit reden.
Wir hören uns jetzt erstmal Herrn Müller an von der...
Eine Bundesnetzagentur, der also diese Trusted Flagger betreut.
Das heißt, wenn sie in der Vergangenheit, ich nenne jetzt mal willkürlich ein
paar Namen, mit Facebook, mit TikTok, mit Amazon, mit wem auch immer ein Problem
hatten und das Gefühl hatten,
sie dringen da nicht durch, sie werden da nicht gehört, sie landen in einer
Warteschleife oder im digitalen Nirgendwo,
dann ist die Idee, dass diese Trusted Flagger, vertrauenswürdigen Hinweisgeber,
einen direkten Kanal für sie haben. Das heißt, sie können sich an die wenden.
Vielleicht fühlen sie sich bei diesen in der Regel oft zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen auch wohler, als wenn sie sich bei einer Plattform oder einer
Behörde oder der Staatsanwaltschaft beschweren wollen.
Sie unterstützen sie darin, Hinweise zu geben.
Also hier klingt es ein bisschen so, als sei das einfach nur so bürgernah,
der Bürger kann sich melden, aber wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
sind die Trusted-Flagger auch selbst unterwegs und suchen nach entsprechenden
Inhalten, aber du kannst jetzt auch sagen, zum Beispiel,
ich schreibe jetzt dir morgen unter deinem Podcast einen Kommentar und sage,
du Arschloch, hast wieder, lass und lass, ja.
Ihr habt die Macht, ihr seid Trusted Flagger. Nehmt das mal raus.
Mich stört Müller immer.
Dieser Singsang von Müller, der mir wirklich alles erklärt, ist nicht gut.
Ist nicht gut. Wir hören mal weiter.
Das kann von Plattform zu Plattform sehr, sehr unterschiedlich sein.
Also es geht jetzt um die Beschwerden.
Das kann zum Beispiel der Fall sein, dass sie eine massive illegale Beleidigung
über sich selber dort im Netz lesen müssen.
Das kann zum Beispiel die Frage sein, dass sie rund um die kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen
Russland-Ukraine, Hamas gegen Israel,
dort Videofilme sehen, grausamster Art, die aber etwas unterstellen,
aber aus einem Videospiel zusammengestitten sind. Es kann aber auch banale Sachen sein.
Und dann soll ich die informieren. Also was ist jetzt zum Beispiel mit den,
Videos, die gemacht wurden von pro-ukrainischen Accounts, in denen Zelensky
als Marvel-Held auftritt und Putin kurz und klein macht mit der Armee zusammen.
Soll ich das jetzt melden? Ist das jetzt Fake News oder ist das einfach das, was es ist?
Das ist einfach Teufelsküche.
Wie, dass sie sich angemeldet haben digital, aber gar nicht mehr abmelden können.
Oder, dass sie gar keine Möglichkeit finden, sich auf einer Plattform direkt zu beschweren.
Also die Frage, wie so eine Plattform mit ihnen kommuniziert.
Es kann aber auch der Punkt sein, dass eine Botschaft, eine Nachricht von ihnen
gelöscht wurde und sie das aber nicht als legitim empfinden.
Ja, das kann so alles möglich sein. Und das klingt alles, also für mich ist
so dieses diffuse, wir haben jetzt eben bei dieser Resolution gesagt,
ja es ist alles nicht so ganz klar, was ist denn damit eigentlich gemeint und
das werden wir jetzt hier auch immer haben, also zum Beispiel geht es dann so,
welche Kriterien, worum geht es dann da?
Dann geht es dann zum Beispiel illegale Inhalte, die Beeinträchtigung fundamentaler
Rechte, Schutz persönlicher Daten und sowas.
Okay, aber dann heißt es auch, dabei identifizierte Risiken müssen von den VLOPs
durch sachgerechte und effektive Maßnahmen vermieden werden.
Also da geht es jetzt um diese großen Plattformen, was die selbst machen müssen.
Schließlich können diese Dienste bei außergewöhnlichen Krisen,
zum Beispiel bewaffnete Konflikte, Terrorhandlungen oder Pandemien,
von der Europäischen Kommission zur Zusammenarbeit verpflichtet werden.
Also dann müssen die im großen Maßstab einfach irgendwas leuchten,
der es denen anweist. Ich weiß natürlich darum, dass es Angriffe von außen gibt
und ich weiß natürlich auch um die russischen Trollarmeen und so weiter.
Ich sehe nur eben in diesem Unspezifischen immer das Einfallstor für ganz viel
anderes, wo ich dann sagen kann, das ist mir aber eigentlich gerade Unrecht,
das müssen wir mal flaggen oder da müssen eigentlich die Plattformen dabei sein,
dass das gar nicht stattfindet.
Und das bedeutet dann auch wieder, dass politisches im Zweifelsfall lieber aussortiert
wird, nehmen wir doch lieber noch jemanden in Badehose und Bikini,
damit das schon mal keinen Anstoß erregt.
Das erinnert mich von vor 20
Jahren, als man mal wieder eine Zäsur nicht erkannt hat und nach dem 11.
September die Idee aufkam, dann richten wir doch auf dem Boden so eine Station
ein, von dem aus die Flugzeuge übernommen werden können, für den Fall,
dass der Pilot überwältigt ist.
Ach ja.
Und dann war die Gegenfrage, und was ist, wenn jetzt 10 Terroristen einfach
in diese Bodenstation stürmen und einfach alle Flugzeuge plötzlich unter Kontrolle haben?
Ach so, ja stimmt, nee, ist doch keine gute Idee. Und so ist das hier auch.
Wir haben diese sehr unterschiedlichen sozialen Netzwerke.
Die Pluralität nimmt ja gerade wieder zu, dass auf Twitter ja nicht nur Blue
Sky folgt, sondern auch Mastodon und so weiter und so fort. Threats, Pipapo.
Und jetzt schaffen wir eine zentrale Instanz, also so Trusted Flagger,
die einfach Einflugschneise für alle möglich sind, die irgendwelche Anliegen haben.
Also alle Aktionen zum Thema, die CDU macht eine Umfrage, stürzt euch mal alle
auf die Umfrage. Guck mal, da ist ein Trusted Flagger.
Was glauben die denn, was in drei Jahren mit so einem Trusted Flacker passiert.
Das sind doch Organisationen, wo jetzt irgendwie bislang so 20 Leute irgendwie Content sortieren.
Ja, die werden belagert und verarbeitet in den Mangel genommen.
Also das ist doch völlig absurd, sowas zu machen.
Ein Anmeldeformular, ich wollte
es dir schon ausdrücken. Du bist ja Schuldenbremsenabschaffungsfetischist.
Du kannst dich ja auch bewerben als Trusted Flacker.
Sehr gut, ja.
Und dann musst du zum Beispiel hier, geben sie bitte ein oder mehrere Fachgebiete
an, in welchen sie bei der Meldung rechtswidriger Inhalte tätig sein wollen.
Ich würde mal sagen, das machen wir jetzt bei dir mit Schuldenbremse und Familie Soziales.
Und da würde ich sagen, du machst das, nimmst noch ein paar Mitarbeiter dazu
und flext eigentlich nur konsequent FDP-Inhalte.
Das steht nicht auf dem Nein, das geht nicht, das steht also das ist,
Fake News, also es geht hier um Fake News Fake News sind in meinen Augen,
wenn jemand sagt, die Schuldenbremse ist der Garant für eine gute Zukunft für
unsere Kinder ist für mich Fake News.
Für mich ist es auch totale Fake News.
Würde ich sagen, da kriegen wir
auch sehr viele wissenschaftliche Unterstützung in der Aussage Flecken.
Aber ich bin ja eh dafür, nicht nur die AfD, sondern auch die FDP zu verbieten.
Nein, das macht sie natürlich alleine. Mir reicht es ja völlig,
wenn sie nicht im Bundestag sitzt.
Was passiert jetzt bei so einer Beschwerde?
Die Idee ist ja, dass er dann sie unterstützt. Das bedeutet aber,
dass der Trusted Flagger zuerst überprüft, ob ihr Vorwurf, der kann sich jetzt
ja von Frage des Zugangs bis hin zur Illegalität reichen,
er überprüft erstmal, ob dieser Vorwurf stimmt.
Und dazu müssen das sehr qualifizierte Institutionen sein, die häufig eben auch
eine hohe juristische Kompetenz haben.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal in dem einfachen
Fall sind, also sie haben keine Beschwerdemöglichkeit, keine Abteilung,
eine Meldemöglichkeit, dann sammeln die Trusted-Pfleger das und wenden sich
an die Plattformen und die Plattform muss damit umgehen.
Im härteren Fall, wir sind jetzt in einem illegalen Bereich unterwegs,
dann meldet der Trusted-Pfleger das häufig zum Beispiel beim Bundeskriminalamt,
lässt das auch dort nochmal überprüfen und auch dann reicht er diese Meldung
weiter an die Plattform und informiert zum Beispiel auch die Bundesnetzagentur
darüber, gerade wenn es ein wiederkehrendes Problem ist,
ein sogenanntes systemisches Risiko sich aufzeichnet.
Unterm Strich bedeutet es aber immer, der Trusted Fläger hat selber gar keine
Entscheidungskompetenz, sondern er ist eben ein Hinweisgeber,
ein vertrauenswürdiger Hinweisgeber. Er macht den Menschen das Leben leichter.
Ja, und wenn mir ein Jurist das so erklärt, verstehe ich, das ist alles Bullshit.
Wenn er sagt, wir brauchen ja Menschen mit juristischer Kompetenz,
Jetzt sage ich, na, Menschen mit juristischer Kompetenz brauchen wir den Spruchkörpern der Gerichte.
Wenn wir also feststellen, wir brauchen ja mehr Kompetenz, finde ich,
ja, dann brauchen wir halt mehr Gerichte, die sich darum kümmern.
Es kann ja auch nicht sein in Deutschland, dass jeder einzelne Tweet,
nur weil er mal zur Anzeige gebracht wird, gleich zu einer Hausdurchsuchung führt.
Wieso müssen jetzt fünf Leute wegen einem vier Jahre alten Tweet eine Hausdurchsuchung machen?
Ich finde, ein Richter sollte bei einem Tweet, der, was weiß ich,
klar antisemitisch, Menschenrechtsverachten oder irgendwas ist,
einfach ohne eine Hausdurchsuchung noch am selben Tage der Kenntnisnahme dieses
Tweets einfach zu einer Entscheidung kommen können.
Wenn das deutsche Rechtswesen nicht so funktioniert, muss das umgebaut werden.
Was ich nicht brauche, Trusted Flagger Organisationen, die irgendwie Respekt
in Stuttgart rumsitzen und jetzt Hinweisgeber, aber ohne eigene Kompetenz,
wir wollen ja nicht zu weit gehen, da rumflecken die ganze Zeit.
Das ist doch alles so hirnverbrannt.
Lass uns doch mal gerade zu diesem Habeck-Clip springen, den ich da habe,
weil du jetzt gerade schon die Beleidigung angesprochen hast.
Klick uns den nochmal an.
Ich habe mich am Anfang der Legislatur, als es so hart zuging,
entschieden, Beleidigungen, Bedrohungen zur Anzeige zu bringen. Das sind sehr viele.
Das wird über Agenturen gefiltert und in diesem Fall kam es von der bayerischen Polizei.
Natürlich ist jetzt Schwachkopf nicht die schlimmste Beleidigung,
die jemals ausgesprochen wurde.
Was aber dann passiert ist, dass nämlich die Staatsanwaltschaft daraus dann
den Laptop oder das Endgerät beschlagnahmt hat, also ins Haus reingegangen ist,
mit meiner Anzeige nur als Auslösendes, glaube ich, zu tun.
Denn in der Erklärung der Polizei war ja von rassistischen Hintergründen die
Rede oder antisemitischen Hintergründen die Rede.
Deswegen denke ich, dass das zwar die gleiche Person ist, aber diese Anzeige nur Auslöser war.
Ja, aber können diese Behörden bitte mal ein bisschen angemessener,
niederschwelliger da vorgehen?
Ja.
Statt nach Hausdurchsuchung wegen sowas zu veranstalten. Also da tut mir auch
Habeck leid, ehrlich gesagt. Der hat ja nicht eine Hausdurchsuchung beantragt,
sondern eine Anzeige geschrieben.
Wie kann es sein, dass die überhaupt jetzt mit diesen Anzeigen da ankommen?
Also Habeck ist ja nicht der Einzige und ich finde es auch wieder skandalös,
dass das mit Habeck so groß gemacht wurde.
Merz macht das auch. Da wurde im Stern darüber berichtet.
Das wurde von den Rechten nicht aufgegriffen. Bei Tichys Einblick habe ich es dann gesehen.
Ich habe ein bisschen gesucht, wer hat es noch gemacht. Aber man hat dann nicht
bei der Bild-Zeitung das ganz groß gemacht.
Aber ich lese jetzt hier aus dem Artikel vom Stern vor, letzte Woche.
Die gelernte Krankenschwester aus Hasberge in Unterfranken war wütend an diesem Tag im Oktober 2023.
Gerade hatte Friedrich Merz auf dem Kurznachrichtendienst EX über die Ampelregierung
und ihren Cannabis-Beschluss gelästert. Jetzt Merz Zitat.
Wir als CDU-CSU werden mit aller Kraft dafür kämpfen, dass die von der Ampel
bei ihren letzten Therapiesitzungen auf Schloss Meseburg geplante Legalisierung
des Rauschmittels Cannabis nicht kommt.
Also er schreibt, dass die eine Therapiesitzung hatten auf Schloss Meseburg.
Daraufhin die 50-Jährige, selbst in Psychotherapie und von der Formulierung
aufgebracht, kommentierte, eure Wortwahl ist wirklich unter aller Sau.
Therapiesitzung in diesem Kontext ist für psychisch kranke Menschen ein Schlag
ins Gesicht. Löscht euch, ihr Arschlöcher.
Ein Kommentar, den die Frau noch sehr bedauern sollte.
Anfang Mai 2024 erhielt sie ein Schreiben der Polizei, in der sie zu ihrer Anhörung gebeten wurde.
Friedrich Merz hatte persönlich einen Strafantrag gegen sie gestellt.
In diesem August kam es in der Sache zur Verhandlung. Gegen eine Geldauflage
von 1000 Euro wurde das Verfahren eingestellt.
Ihren Post hat die Frau gelöscht und sich entschuldigt. Ich finde das völlig
kleinkariert, dass Politiker dem nachgehen.
Ja, wenn irgendwo, na lass mich das mal sagen, also wenn Menschen bedroht werden,
wenn Politiker bedroht werden, dann müssen sie dagegen vorgehen,
das ist vollkommen klar.
Aber ich finde, solche Art der Betitelungen, die da stattfinden,
sind nicht schön, sie sind auch nicht nach meinem Geschmack,
aber ich finde, dass das absolut aushaltbar ist und ich finde das skandalös,
dass man Leute, gerade auch dieser Mann, der da Schwachkopf und so gesagt hat,
dass man die jetzt da zur Raison bittet und dass man denen irgendwelche Geldsummen aufbrummt.
Und einige Politiker, dazu gehört jetzt nicht Merz, haben ja da ein richtiges
Geschäft wohl für sich daraus gemacht.
Es ist auch, finde ich, völlig legitim, sich einmal in dieser Weise irgendwo
in den sozialen Medien zu äußern und sich auch in dieser Weise aufzuregen.
Diese Wortwahl ist, wenn man so möchte, auch die Wortwahl der Machtlosen und
ich will das hier ganz ausdrücklich sagen, ich bin seit 2011 im Internet unterwegs,
ich habe schon viele Beleidigungen bekommen.
Jetzt sicherlich nicht so viel wie Habeck, aber auch einige.
Und ich will hier ganz ausdrücklich sagen, wenn jemand hier schreibt,
Wolfgang ist ein Arschloch, ein Schwachkopf, ein Idiot oder ein Vollidiot,
ich würde niemals dagegen vorgehen.
Es wird mich über andere Kommentare mehr vorhin zugegebenermaßen,
aber ich kann es nicht kapieren, dass man damit die Justiz behelligt.
Ich möchte dazu eine alternative Meinung kundtun, die dem widerspricht.
Ich finde, sobald sich jemand beleidigt fühlt, soll er das Recht haben,
diese Anzeige zu schreiben, ohne dass andere dann daneben stehen und sagen,
das gehört sich aber nicht, das musst du aushalten, wie auch immer.
Wie es in den Wald reinruft, so ruft es hinaus oder Merz, so dünnes Fell,
während er gleichzeitig alle in die Armut schickt oder also dass da keine Verhältnismäßigkeit ist.
Nur, ich finde, wir brauchen jetzt, da alle auch aktiv am Mediengeschehen teilnehmen
und nicht einfach eine Tagesschau irgendwas sendet und dann hören sich das 8
Millionen an und schweigen dazu.
Brauchen wir ein anderes Justizwesen.
Grundsätzlich. Wir brauchen keine Trusted Flag oder irgendwas,
sondern wir haben schon ein Justizwesen.
Nur, es muss möglich sein, dass ein Richter feststellt, hier wurde jemand wirklich beschimpft.
Habeck muss Schwachkopf nicht erdulden.
Die Strafe ist 72 Euro und nicht tausend konfiszierte Geräte und fünf Leute,
die den ganzen Tag mit einer Hausdurchsuchung zu tun haben.
Die Unangemessenheit liegt nicht in der Anzeige und nicht im Verhalten derjenigen,
die irgendwen beschimpfen. Jeder soll von mir aus Schwachkopf sagen dürfen,
nur er muss mit einer realistischen, angemessenen Strafe rechnen.
Das bedeutet, wenn jemand Merz oder Habeck irgendwie beschimpft als Schwachkopf
oder wie auch immer, muss man halt damit rechnen, dass es am Ende 72 Euro kostet.
Und wir brauchen ein Rechtswesen, das in der Lage ist, das zu organisieren.
Allerdings, ich will dieses große Fass nicht aufmachen und ich sehe auch schon,
dass du reagierst, aber mir geht es darum,
für alle Menschen die gleichen Rechte auf die Justiz zuzugreifen und die Justiz
für sich arbeiten zu lassen, anzuwenden.
Und zwar aus einer einfacheren Sicht.
Aber es sind ja nicht die gleichen Rechte. Du siehst ja, dass die Politiker
da, wenn die was verfolgen wollen, da viel mehr Möglichkeiten haben.
Ja, weil da einfach, finde ich, von Seiten des Rechts eine unangemessene Eier,
der ist wichtiger als andere Menschen.
Naja, es gab eine Änderung im Gesetz. Das ist ja das Interessante.
Ich sage ja, das Recht. Also hier ist einfach das Recht das Problem.
Denn, ich weiß, ich steche jetzt in ein Westennest, das wird gleich mega explodieren.
Aber wenn wir der Meinung sind, die Politiker haben das gefälligst auszuhalten,
ja, dann bekommen wir halt nur Merzens und Habecks und nicht mal die halten es aus.
Ich möchte aber nicht Merzens und Habecks da haben, sondern ich möchte,
dass U35 Frauen im Bundestag irgendeine Rede, eine politisch relevante Rede
und wenn sie danach beschimpft werden, haben sie jedes Recht der Welt gegen
alle 10.000 Leute, die meinen, sie jetzt abhaken zu müssen im Internet, vorgehen.
Und wenn dann 10.000 automatisierte Strafanzeigen geschrieben werden,
die darin münden, dass jeder dieser Typen, der eine schreibt Arschloch,
der andere schreibt Fotze und der nächste kommt mit noch einer Beleidigung,
dann muss ich das aufsummieren und dann wirft jeder die 72 Euro,
die das an Wiedergutmachung der Ehrverletzung bedeutet, in den Ring, was bedeutet,
für diese jungen politischen Frauen oder auch Männer würde sich das rechnen.
Ich möchte also hier dafür werben, dass man dieses dicke Fell,
nein, nichts dickes Fell, man hat kein Recht, jemanden zu beschimpfen und man hat keine Pflicht.
Das zu ertragen. Also hier geht es ja um Sachen, hier werden ja Agenturen teils
beauftragt, ich weiß das jetzt nicht im Falle hier von Schwachkopf und sonst
was, hier werden das finden die ja nicht selbst.
Was ja nicht, jemand schreibt mir eine E-Mail, ich lese die und sagt dann, du bist ein Idiot.
Du meinst, das ist jetzt ein Anzeigenabmahnwesen und das stimmt ja auch.
So, und das trifft niemanden, wenn jetzt ich, also dieser Podcast erscheint
auf allen Podcast-Plattformen und diese ganze Podcast-Plattformen haben auch
nochmal Kommentarfunktionen.
Wenn jetzt da jemand was, ich bin zum Beispiel nicht bei Apple,
wenn jetzt jemand bei Apple mich beleidigt, dann kann mich das gar nicht treffen,
da brauche ich gar kein dickes Fell, weil ich das nicht sehe bei Apple.
Wenn das jemand an die 29er auf die Seite schreibt, dann würde ich es ja wenigstens noch sehen.
Also nur ein ganz kleiner Hinweis mal.
Und deshalb muss ich sagen, ist das ja nicht diese Beleidigung.
Und ich will einen Merkel-Clip spielen, ohne ihn einzuleiten.
Genau in diesem und in keinem anderen Verständnis und genau in diesem und in
keinem anderen Gesamtrahmen wird die Bundesregierung im vorliegenden konkreten
Fall hinsichtlich des Moderators Jan Böhmermann die von mir eingangs vorgetragene
Ermächtigung erteilen.
Darüber hinaus möchte ich Ihnen mitteilen, dass unabhängig von diesem konkreten
Verfahren die Bundesregierung der Auffassung ist,
dass § 103 Strafgesetzbuch als Strafnorm zum Schutz der persönlichen Ehre für
die Zukunft entbehrlich ist.
Wir werden deshalb einen Gesetzentwurf zu seiner Aufhebung vorlegen.
Der Gesetzentwurf soll noch in dieser Wahlperiode verabschiedet werden und 2018 in Kraft treten.
Er hat sich gut aus der Affäre gezogen.
2018 wurde dieser Paragraf gestrichen.
Der lautete 103 folgendermaßen, wer ein ausländisches Staatsoberhaupt beleidigt,
wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe im Falle der
verleumderischen Beleidigung mit Freiheitsstrafe von drei Monaten bis zu fünf Jahren bestraft.
Das ist entfallen. Jetzt haben wir ja es nicht mit ausländischen Majestäten zu tun.
Da greift Paragraf 188. Dieser Paragraf besagt,
gegen Personen des politischen Lebens gerichtete Beleidigungen über Nachrede
und Verleumdung wird gegen eine im politischen Leben des Volkes stehende Person
öffentlich in einer Versammlung durch Verbreiten und so weiter und so weiter
Beleidigungen gemacht.
Dann droht eine Freiheitsstrafe oder Geldstrafe, um das mal ein bisschen zu verkürzen.
Das Strafmaß ist absurd. Also ich meine, wir haben doch Beleidigungen.
Pass auf. Woher kommt überhaupt dieser Paragraf?
Der ist überhaupt erst ins Strafgesetzbuch eingeführt worden 1951.
Da hatten wir also schon die Bundesrepublik.
Inhaltlich, und das ist jetzt hier von der Seite des Bundestags,
Inhaltlich ging dieser Artikel zurück auf Artikel 48 Absatz 2 aus der Weimarer Reichsverfassung.
Erlassen wurde diese Verordnung 1931 von ….
Paul von Hindenburg, von dem wir ja wissen, welche Rolle er noch spielen würde.
Und damit wollte er den Ehrschutz stärken, Zitat, um der zunehmenden Vergiftung
des öffentlichen Lebens durch Verunglimpfung anderer und der wachsenden Verhetzung
im politischen Kampf entgegenzuwirken.
Also dieser hat ein Geschmäckle.
Nun aber hat man dann im Zuge von Corona-Protesten im Jahr 21 diesen Paragrafen ausgeweitet.
Und zwar heißt es dort auf der offiziellen Seite, die Ausweitung von 188 zog
sich auf Fälle der Beleidigung,
erfolgte erst mit dem Gesetz zur Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus und der Hasskriminalität.
Zwar hatte der damalige Gesetzentwurf der Regierungskoalition,
CDU, CSU und SPD eine derartige Erweiterung auf den Beleidigungstatbestand nicht vorgesehen.
Da heißt es, die Ausweitung von § 188 StGB auch auf Fälle der Beleidigung erfolgte
erst mit dem Gesetz zur Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus und der Hasskriminalität im Jahr 2021.
Das heißt, man hat also da diesen Paragrafen deutlich verschärft,
um jetzt also mehr Handhabe zu haben und mehr ahnden zu können.
Und das, finde ich, ist keine gute Entwicklung.
Das finde ich auch. Ich wüsste nicht, warum jetzt Politiker anders zu handeln sind als alle anderen.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Politiker können sich das eben erlauben, weil die Rechtskosten für sie einfach
übernommen werden, auch im Fall der Niederlage.
Das ist für andere eben anders. Weshalb ich sage, wir brauchen hier keine Trusted
Flacker, wir brauchen keine herausgehobene Stellung der Politiker,
wir brauchen einfach nur ein Rechtswesen für alle, das diese Art von Gewalt minimiert.
Und zwar auch durch kleine Strafen, die zack, zack, zack, zack,
zack, es ist halt nur mal ein Tweet, bitte keine Hausdurchsuchung,
bitte keine große Analyse, bitte keine,
Gutachten, sondern einfach nur feststellen, dieses Wort geht nicht.
Das ist beleidigend, das war schon immer beleidigend.
Der Täter wusste, es ist beleidigend. 72 Euro.
Und jetzt möchte ich noch einen Clip zum Abschluss spielen über Trusted Flagger,
weil das, glaube ich, noch deutlich werden sollte.
Oder ich will zwei Tabea Rösner von den Grünen hatte sich im Frühjahr bei der
Bundestagsdebatte auch dazu geäußert.
Politische Meinungen bilden sich immer stärker im Netz. Der Diskurs ist aber
zunehmend vergiftet. Das sieht man ja hier.
Viele Menschen ziehen sich aus Debattenräumen zurück.
Deshalb sollen Hass, digitale Gewalt und gezielte Desinformation,
also illegale Inhalte, keinen Platz mehr auf Plattformen haben.
Das reicht im Prinzip erstmal, um zu hören, ja, aber Hass, was ist denn Hass?
Es gibt dann so eine Liste mit unzulässigen Inhalten, die nicht vollständig
ist, aber man hat sie einmal so veröffentlicht jetzt im Zuge von DSA,
also was da geahndet werden kann.
Und interessant ist, bei jedem einzelnen Punkt steht immer nochmal,
also sowas wie Betrug, Täuschung und so weiter, stehen dann immer aufgelistete
Punkte und als letztes immer andere.
Und man auch denkt, ja interessant.
Und dann steht zum Beispiel bei unerlaubter Rede Verleumdung, Diskriminierung.
Hassrede.
Ist zum Beispiel Hassrede, wenn jemand sagt, ich halte die Ehe für alle für einen großen Fehler.
Ist das Diskriminierung? Ja, also natürlich, ich würde das sagen,
wenn mir jemand sowas sagen würde, würde ich sagen, das ist aber diskriminierend,
nur ist das ein Tatbestand, dass man sagt, naja, das ist gerade diskriminierend gewesen.
Interessanterweise natürlich auch so Sachen wie Verletzung des Urheberrechts
und so, also da wird man, da gibt es jetzt auch eine Verschärfung,
da werden auch viele interessiert sein, Trusted Fläger zu werden,
bin gespannt, wer da welche Anwaltskanzlei zuarbeitet.
Dann geht es darum, nicht einvernehmliche Inhalt, die Deepfake oder ähnliche
Technologien enthalten und die Merkmale eines Dritten nutzen.
Wir haben jetzt bei Twitter die Woche immer gesehen, dass irgendwelche Politiker
sich küssen, das hat man so animiert mit der AI.
Wäre also hier etwas, was man sofort flaggen muss. Dann Gefährdung der öffentlichen
Sicherheit, da heißt es zum Beispiel Gefahr von Umweltschäden,
würde ich sagen, Trusted Flagger an den Porsche.
Ich verstehe das.
Ist ganz klar Umweltschaden. So und jetzt für mich das Interessanteste,
Rubrik negative Auswirkungen auf den zivilen Diskurs und Wahlen.
Also ich würde erstmal sagen, jemand wie Christian Lindner hat wirklich negative
Auswirkungen auf den zivilen Diskurs.
Ja, vor allem, wenn ich doch...
Also ich finde Podcasts nur interessant, wenn sie, und ich weiß ja,
da sitzen ohnmächtige Leute, aber wenn sie mir Argumente bringen,
die Turbulenzen im Nahverkehr verursachen, also die sozusagen alle gefleckt werden müssen.
Und jetzt heißt es dann noch als Unterpunkt, Informationsmanipulation mit dem
Ziel, die Integrität oder den Ausgang von Wahlen zu beeinflussen.
Und jetzt, ich weiß, es wird viele aufregen.
Das ist Wahlkampf. Das ist die Definition von Wahlkampf.
Ich weiß, es wird viel aufregend, aber wir spielen es jetzt trotzdem,
weil ich es nur dort noch neben, also wir haben es jetzt, du hast es gerade
schon miteinander, aber wir spielen es jetzt, auch wenn es weh tut und wir hassen
sie, aber wir spielen sie jetzt trotzdem.
Wir spielen jetzt eigentlich, ja wir werden jetzt gefleckt, wir spielen jetzt
Alexander Kistler ehemals, Cicero jetzt bei Nios, wie er das kommentiert.
Der Leitfaden der Bundesnetzagentur, die von dem grünen Klaus Müller geleitet wird, von Mai 2024.
Dort werden Anforderungen an die Trusted Flagger zusammengeführt und da steht
unter anderem, als unzulässiger Inhalt gelte auch eine Aussage,
Zitat, die negative Auswirkungen auf den zivilen Diskurs oder Wahlen habe.
Da werde ich natürlich unfassbar hellhörig.
Nachtigall, ich höre dir trapsen. Also unzulässig soll es sein,
negative Auswirkungen auf Wahlen. Da kann ich sagen, was bitteschön sind negative Auswirkungen.
Also aus Sicht der Grünen ist vielleicht mit Sicherheit negativ,
wenn sie aus dem Bundestag fliegen.
Für viele andere wäre das wunderbar. Für die eine Partei ist es gut,
wenn dieses Ergebnis eintritt. Für das andere ist das Gegenteil der Ergebnis negativ.
Da werde ich extrem hellhörig und außerdem steht noch dabei,
unzulässig sei auch eine Zitat Informationsmanipulation mit dem Ziel,
die Integrität schrägstrich den Ausgang von Wahlen zu beeinflussen.
Das machen wir doch letzten Endes alle.
Ja, das machen wir doch letztens alles alle. Also das ist traurig und deswegen
habe ich es jetzt hier nochmal ganz bewusst gespielt, ich kann das Argument
natürlich auch ohne Alexander Kistler machen.
Ich finde das von der, sagen wir jetzt einfach mal, linken Seite nicht artikuliert.
Es gab einen Artikel, der ganz gut war von Lars Weisbrot, der beschrieben hat,
dass das eigentlich auch so ein neoliberales Staatsverständnis ist.
Naja, der Staat soll sich mal selbst nicht direkt drum kümmern müssen,
flaggen wir das mal so aus, da soll mal irgendwie so eine hippe Agentur das machen.
Das war eine der wenigen kritischen Texte, die es dazu gab, die nicht von diesen
Rechten vorgetragen wurden.
Und sonst großes Schweigen im Walde.
Und ich halte das für ein großes Problem.
Also die Meinungsfreiheit wird uns, glaube ich, als Thema doch wieder mehr beschäftigen.
Ich hätte es nicht gedacht.
Ja, vor allem diese Versuche hier Meinungsfreiheit, also Meinungen einzufangen,
Meinungen lassen sich nicht immer einfangen.
Am Ende, das ist doch die große Lehre aus Amerika.
Alle juristischen Versuche, alle publizistischen Versuche, alles gescheitert.
Man hat einfach die Wähler gefragt, hü oder hot. Ganz einfach Entscheidung,
A oder B. Und die haben gesagt B. Und jetzt haben wir den Salat.
Und alle Versuche vorher haben vielleicht einfach nur B noch bestärkt.
Also es ist wirklich sehr kontraproduktiv alles.
Ich habe, und ich weiß, es ist sehr spät, aber wir müssen das jetzt noch gucken,
denn es ist spektakulär gut. Das ist der Fernsehmoment des Jahres.
Ich fand es einfach herausragend, vor allem in der Art und Weise,
also zurückhaltend, da einfach all in zu gehen.
Ich möchte es wie folgt framen. Wir haben eine Mail von Frederik bekommen.
Ich lese die Mail vor, ihr erinnert euch. Vielleicht bin ich zu sehr Marxist,
um den Witz in Linnemann argumentiert marxistisch zu verstehen,
aber nach einigen Hin- und Herüberlegen
geht der Witz irgendwie immer noch nicht auf. Kann wer helfen?
Daraufhin schleppt Florian. Absolut richtig, Stefan verwechselt hier Empirie und Theorie.
Ich lese diesen Kommentar und denke mir, ja genau, ich verwechsel Empirie und Theorie.
Jascha schreibt nochmal drunter, danke, habe schon überlegt,
ob ich was schreibe, nachdem der Witz wiederholt vorkam und sogar in der Episodenbeschreibung steht.
Ich muss also tatsächlich den Humor nochmal erklären.
Die ich nicht verfasst habe, die Episodenbeschreibung. Also das bezieht sich
jetzt für alle, die den Salon noch nicht abonniert haben, darauf,
dass wir über das Buch von Philippa Siegel-Klöckner gesprochen haben.
Siegel-Klöckner beschäftigt sich dort mit Marx und zwar vor allem geht es darum,
dass Marx von der Reservearmee der Arbeitslosen spricht.
Das heißt, der Kapitalismus produziert immer wieder eine Reservearmee,
ihm geht es gar nicht darum, eine Vollbeschäftigung oder sowas herzustellen,
diese Reservearmee von Arbeitslosen signalisiert jenen, die am Arbeiten sind,
Vorsicht, die Situation der Arbeitslosigkeit willst du nicht haben,
also kusch mal lieber, sei brav und so weiter.
Und zugleich sagt aber diese Krisentheorie von Marx auch, dass der Kapitalismus
das unaufhörlich immer wieder produziert, dass das also etwas ist,
was ein Systemimmanentes dem Kapitalismus.
Jetzt, um das wirklich ganz kurz zu machen, Marx setzt sich da kritisch mit
Malthus auseinander oder Malthus und er sagt,
Das liegt seine Theorie da, das ist aber noch alles bevor es Geburtenkontrolle
und sowas gibt, deswegen muss man das glaube ich eigentlich stärker kontextualisieren,
als das gemeinhin stattfindet und auch bei Siege Klöckner stattfindet.
Sie jedenfalls aus einer keynesianischen Perspektive sagt, sehr wohl können
wir sowas wie Vollbeschäftigung machen.
Es hapert an Schuldenbremse etc. Und durchaus würde ein Kapitalismus funktionieren,
der nicht eine solche Reservearmee hat.
Deine Argumentation oder deine Pointe sieht jetzt so aus, dass du sagst,
wenn ein Linnemann oder andere CDU-Leute sagen,
wir müssen Austeritätspolitik machen, dann halten sie sich eigentlich an die
Diagnose, die Marx gemacht hat, nämlich zu sagen, der Kapitalismus braucht diese Reservearmee.
Du sagst dann, die verhalten sich wie Marxisten. Nun war ja Marx jemand,
der nicht die Reservearmee wollte, sondern du weißt es.
Den Kapitalismus überbinden wollte.
Aber die Pointe kommt deshalb, glaube ich, bei manchen ein bisschen schief an
und die Linnemann-Diagnose ist natürlich eine,
dass er sagt, und das ist ein guter Kapitalismus, dann während Marx uns sagt,
das ist das Problem am Kapitalismus.
Und die keynesianische Position, die ist natürlich immer eine,
dass man eigentlich volkswirtschaftlich agieren muss und dann kann man zum Beispiel
sowas wie Vollbeschäftigung für alle schaffen.
Genau. Es ist ganz einfach. Zum einen muss man verstehen, Marx ist kein Politiker,
der etwas fordert. Von mir aus steckt er in den Texten drin.
Marx ist einer, der eine Diagnose stellt.
Nämlich, dass der kapitalträchtige Eigner einer Fabrik eine Reservearmee braucht,
damit sein Laden funktioniert.
Und wir haben die Diskussion aus Amerika.
Adam Tooze hat sie aufgeschrieben.
Die Amerikaner hatten zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder Massenarbeitslosigkeit oder
eine Absenkung des Lohnniveaus, also einen Reallohnverlust durch,
wir haben eine Inflation und gleichen sie aber nicht durch Lohnerhöhung aus.
Und die Amerikaner haben sich dafür entschieden, keine Massenarbeitslosigkeit,
also man hat eine Zinspolitik gemacht, die einen Reallohnverlust bedeutet,
aber eben keine Massenarbeitslosigkeit.
So, Massenarbeitslosigkeit ist dieses Reservearmee-Ding, was für mich wieder
bedeutet, ah ja, die Politiker können es also auch heute steuern,
indem sie eine Zins-, also eine Fiskalpolitik machen, die zu Massenarbeitslosigkeit oder nicht führt.
Eine Zinserhöhung ist ausdrücklich dafür da, ein überhitztes wirtschaftliches
Geschehen zu dämpfen, also auch Arbeitslosigkeit zu produzieren.
Und da war ja für uns die Einflugschneise.
Biden ließ die Ökonomie heiß laufen, weil er sagte, wir wollen keine Arbeitslosigkeit
und die Löhne sollen mitsteigen und deswegen haben wir dann eine andere Konstellation.
Da sind ja die Löhne, die Reallöhne gestiegen in den USA.
Aber verspätet und wir wissen heute auch zu spät, die Butter war zu teuer.
Klar, ist ein Problem, aber in Deutschland ist es ja noch verrückter gewesen,
noch ehe überhaupt irgendeine Lohnerhöhung kam, sagte man, nee,
jetzt ist Inflation, Jetzt darf aber keiner mehr höhere Löhne haben.
Das bedeutete also übersetzt, in Deutschland dürfen alle Preise steigen.
Nur nicht der Preis für Arbeit.
Das geht nicht.
So, und jetzt ist es ganz einfach, wenn ein Politiker da sitzt und sagt…,
Ich höre sie, sie sagen, wir sollen uns aus der Misere raus investieren,
indem wir jetzt Geld in die Hand nehmen. Nein, da bin ich dagegen.
Ach, sie möchten, dass wir ein besseres Bildungssystem machen,
damit wir innovativere Produkte machen. Nein, da bin ich dagegen.
Das, was wir machen müssen, ist Druck auf die Reservearmee. Wenn jemand da sitzt
und sagt, wir müssen den Weg mit der Druck- und der Reservearmee wählen, ist er ein Marxist.
Weil er dieser Idee, der Diagnose, also nicht den politischen Marxismus,
sondern die Diagnose des Marxismus, der Kapitalist braucht eine Reservearmee.
Wenn man dafür optiert, wenn man diese Optionen selegiert, ist man in dieser
Humorigkeit, die ich mir erlaubt hatte, ein Marxist.
Aber du wirst zugeben, diese Pointe verlangt schon, dass man einige Ecken und
Winkel schlägt, um dann dort anzukommen.
Die Pointe ist vor allem sehr gut, weil sie Carsten Linnemann zum Marxisten
macht. Das ist das, was er am wenigsten will und die Argumentation ist relativ… Stell dir gerade vor.
Wie du bei Land sitzt und 20 Minuten ausführst, wie das funktioniert,
damit Linnemann auch die Pointe begreift.
Wenn jemand sagt, Druck auf Bürgergeldempfänger, ist das für mich ein marxistisches
Denken, weil das dieses technische Reservearmee drin hat.
Ja, aber du weißt, marxistisches Denken gemeinhin wird so verstanden.
Ich weiß, aber das ist ja der Witz an der Sache, dass ich Linnemann damit mache.
So, und jetzt haben wir den folgenden Fall, dass wir diese Pointe einfach nochmal
machen können. Und zwar mit Philippa Siegel-Knöckner.
Endlich, ja.
Mit Thorsten Frei, also Linnemann-Spezi CDU, bei Lanz. Und wir achten jetzt
genau drauf, was hier gesagt wird.
Und wir haben den ganz großen Kontext. Die deutsche Volkswirtschaft retten wir
über zwei Arten, zwei Alternativen.
Entweder wir sorgen morgen durch Druck für ein schlechteres Leben der Bürgergeldempfänger,
sodass die übermorgen arbeiten gehen.
Oder wir investieren langfristig in eine neue Generation von Lehrern,
sodass die nächsten geborenen Kinder in 20 Jahren ein Erwerbspersonenpotenzial
herstellen, das ganz weit weg ist
von Reserverarmee, sondern das nur aus innovativen Ingenieuren besteht,
die sich freuen auf das Leben und die Zukunft. Das sind die zwei Alternativen.
Verwägene Idee.
So und jetzt hören wir das, wie das ausgearbeitet wird hier in der Sendung. Wir fangen an.
Wenn Sie es so eilig haben und sagen, auch wenn Sie starten,
sollten Sie die Wahl gewinnen, dann wollen Sie gleich mit voller Kraft loslegen.
Dann können Sie meiner Ansicht nach eine Sache tun und die bringt Ihnen zehnmal
mehr und bringt diesem Land zehnmal mehr, als die Wahl jetzt zwei Wochen oder
vier Wochen oder sogar sechs Wochen vorzuziehen.
Ihr Verhältnis zur Schuldenbremse klären.
Mein Verhältnis ist geklärt zur Schuldenbremse.
So, also Schuldenbremse gegen Reservearmee.
Bürgergeld gegen, nein, wir brauchen Innovation und Investitionen und nicht
einfach nur einen Tagelöhner, der morgen einsatzbereit ist.
Thorsten Frei wurde jetzt hier angesprochen. Ihr Verhältnis zur Schuldenbremse, pipapo.
Aber wie kriegt man das hin? Wie kriegt man das hin mit den haushalterischen
Zwängen, die Sie momentan haben? Deswegen ist das, glaube ich,
die zentrale offene Frage im Raum.
Und die ist noch nicht ganz... Über die, aber nur, wenn man unterstellt,
dass wenn man etwas tut, dass das immer Geld kostet. Und das meine ich nicht.
Also wir haben Rekordsteuereinnahmen immer noch. Wir haben das zweite Jahr in
Folge eine schrumpfende Wirtschaft und immer noch steigende Steuereinnahmen.
So, sie fragt ihn also nach der Schuldenbremse, weil sie genau weiß,
an die Superreichen komme ich eh nicht ran.
Also dann bitte Kredit, Innovation, Investition, Geld. Er sagt,
muss ja immer alles Geld kosten.
Ich habe doch Arbeitslose, kann ich doch mobilisieren. Muss nur Druck machen.
Brei rechnet jetzt mal vor und wir denken uns so, okay, der Investitionsbedarf,
der irgendwie aufgelaufen ist in der Merkel-Zeit, 800 Milliarden oder irgendwas.
Also es ist ja wirklich, ja, er versucht jetzt mal zu erklären,
nee, mit richtigem Druck auf die Bürgergeldempfänger schaffen wir.
Das heißt, die Einnahmen des Staates in verschiedener Hinsicht wollen sie ja reduzieren.
Aber zugleich ist unklar, bedeutet das dann auch, wo soll dann das Geld herkommen,
das sie ausgeben wollen? Also zum einen ist es so, wenn wir 1% mehr Wirtschaftswachstum
hätten, dann hätten wir 12 Milliarden Euro mehr Steuereinnahmen.
Und wenn wir darüber hinaus, kann man natürlich an ganz vielen Stellen Einsparungen vornehmen.
Also ein Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum bedeutet zwölf Milliarden.
Wenn wir 700, 800 Milliarden im Defizit sind, das auf zehn Jahre verteilt,
also sagen wir pro Jahr bräuchten wir jetzt 80 Milliarden, um in zehn Jahren
dann auf dem Stand der Dinge zu sein, um im Rahmen der Jährlichkeit und Jährigkeit,
wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagte,
der Staat hat wie eine Hausfrau zu funktionieren, es muss im Jahr erarbeitet
werden, was danach ausgegeben wird.
Ja, wir brauchen einfach neun Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum.
Genau, wir brauchen einfach so fünf bis neun Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum. Wo kriegen wir die her?
Also er versucht ja jetzt uns zu erklären, das schaffen wir durch Wirtschaftswachstum,
wir brauchen ja nur fünf bis neun Prozent mehr.
Wo kriegen wir die denn eigentlich her? Wir nähern uns so langsam den Fragen,
aber ein Clip aus Tollerei noch, auch Philippa Siegel-Klöckner kriegt kurz die
Frage, wie fanden Sie das denn, wie der Scholz mit dem Lindner umgegangen ist?
Ist das denn zwischenmenschlich okay?
Und die Art und Weise, der hat so oft mein Vertrauen missbraucht und so weiter,
diese ganzen harten Sätze, die da gefallen sind, wie fanden Sie das?
Schauen Sie sich mal die Haushaltsverhandlungen im letzten Jahr an.
Also es ging eigentlich los mit dem Urlaub.
Sie versucht jetzt diesen Männern in der Runde zu sagen.
Das war vollkommen angemessen, was da stattfand. Das war ein toller Moment.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut, als ich das im Fernsehen sah.
Das war das Bundesverfassungsgericht. Dann musste letzten Winter sehr kurzfristig
ein Haushalt aufgestellt werden. Da ging es zehnmal hin und her.
Dann gab es eine Haushaltseinigung im Sommer, wo man sich darauf geeinigt hat,
dass man für die Bahnfinanzierung und für Autobahnen einen Mechanismus in der
Schuldenbremse nutzt, der angelegt ist.
Und kaum hat man das beschlossen, geht der Finanzminister wieder davon zurück.
Also insofern, das finde ich sehr nachvollziehbar. Und Sie würden nicht sagen,
da ist ein Bundeskanzler, der sich dann, wenn Sie sagen, das ist okay,
zumindest die Frage gefallen lassen muss, wenn das alles schon so lange geht,
warum guckt man dann so lange zu?
Also alle Fragen muss er sich gefallen lassen und ob das richtig war oder nicht,
im Sommer auch nochmal weiterzumachen, ich fand das im Sommer sehr schwer.
Sie hätten es da schon beendet.
Sich in seine Schuhe rein zu versetzen, ich glaube, das kann man nicht so richtig
einfach im Kopf durchspielen.
Aber ich hatte im Sommer große Zweifel, ob das nochmal gut gehen kann.
Ich möchte daran erinnern, dass ich am 16.
November 2023, also einen Tag nach dem Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil im Fernsehpodcast
gesagt habe, wir brauchen eine neue Regierung, denn diese Regierung kriegt es nicht hin.
Und falls sie doch durchhält, hinterlässt sie eine Trümmerlandschaft.
Es war also für nur wirklich leicht mitdenkende Menschen sofort klar,
unter diesem Verfassungsdiktum ab jetzt nur noch schwäbische Hausfrau wird das nichts.
Wenn Lanz hier einfach sie fragt, als hätten sie das früher beendet.
Meine Antwort auf die Frage wäre am Tag 1. Ich hätte das Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts
gelesen, hätte gesagt als Kanzler, sorry, das geht nicht.
Aber gut, es hat halt 385 Tage gedauert, bis es soweit war.
Jedenfalls, der Ampel wurden damals 60 Milliarden Euro genommen.
Und das Verfassungsgericht hat gesagt, Jährlichkeit, Jährigkeit,
ihr müsst es in diesem Jahr erwirtschaften, sonst könnt ihr es nicht ausgeben.
Was für Thorsten Frei für uns nochmal bedeutet, das sind diese und jetzt konkret
5% mehr Wirtschaftswachstum.
Wir hören uns das nochmal an, wie er das sagt. Danach fragen wir uns, wo kommt es her?
Alles, was darüber hinauskam im Bereich der Energiepolitik, im Bereich der Verteidigungspolitik,
hat man über Schulden finanziert.
Und als dann das Bundesverfassungsgericht Ende letzten Jahres dem den Stecker
gezogen hat und plötzlich 60 Milliarden Euro nicht mehr zur Verfügung standen,
da wusste die Koalition nicht mehr weiter.
Im Grunde genommen, Sie haben es ja gesagt, Herr Lanz, es ist eine schwierige
Ausgangslage mit drei Partnern, die sehr unterschiedlich sind.
Und diese Unterschiedlichkeit, die hat man nicht entschieden,
sondern diese Unterschiedlichkeit hat man mit Milliarden von Schulden zugedeckt.
So, wir haben also eine Lücke im Haushalt.
Und wir haben eine demografische Schieflage. Wir haben keine Reservearmee.
Tatsächlich gehen fast doppelt so viele Leute in Rente, Jahr für Jahr jetzt, wie unten nachwachsen.
Also hier ist niemand, den man mal durch und so weiter.
Eigentlich gibt es nur diesen einen Ausweg, jetzt langfristig denken, investieren.
Deutschland Schuldenkorde gerade bei 65 Prozent. Komm, wir machen mal 130.
Wir mobilisieren jetzt mal 5, 6 Billionen Euro. Das wäre eigentlich die Ansage.
Jetzt hören wir in zwei Clips, die jeweils über zwei Minuten lang gehen,
wie dieser Vulgärmarxismus von frei mit der Reservearmee und dem Druck und den
Bürgergeldempfängern durchgeprügelt wird.
Ich möchte jetzt, dass sich jeder Mühe gibt, das Argument zu verstehen.
So geht es nicht. Wenn das die Linie der CDU ist, sind wir in Teufels Küche.
China verschuldet sich ad hoc um 1,7 Billionen. Trump sagt gleich von Anfang
an, ich mache hier 7 Billionen, mir ist mein Staatsdefizit völlig egal.
Und das ist dann die deutsche Haltung, wie man darauf reagiert.
Reden Sie darüber, wie Sie tatsächlich den Haushalt finanzieren würden.
Herr Linnemann war ernsthaft in seinem Interview.
Der hat konkrete Sachen genannt. Kann ich gerne auch machen.
Beim Bürgergeld will er 10 Milliarden einsparen.
Wo man das tun will, wenn wir ein verfassungsrechtlich abgesichertes Extensminimum
haben, weiß ich nicht, aber bin ich gespannt drauf.
Dann sagt er, bei Migration will er 10 Milliarden einsparen.
Mit Wachstum 12 Milliarden erzielen pro Punkt. Da lässt er schon mal aus,
dass die Schuldenbremse einem weniger Spielraum gibt. gibt, wenn es mehr Wachstum gibt.
Und dann will er von dieser Formel irgendwie auf 50 Milliarden kommen.
Geben Sie uns doch mal eine klare Antwort darauf, wie Sie die Geldfrage lösen.
Wie sparen Sie beim Bürgergeld 10 Milliarden?
Wie machen Sie das? Beim Bürgergeld haben wir die Situation,
dass wir heute 5,6 Millionen Bürgergeldempfänger haben.
Davon sind 1,7 Millionen gesund und im arbeitsfähigen Alter.
Also es gibt keinen Grund dafür, warum die Bürgergeld beziehen.
Und deswegen geht es darum, zu aktivieren, dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Menschen
in den Arbeitsmarkt kommen.
Wenn von diesen 1,7 Millionen Menschen eine Million Menschen in den Arbeitsmarkt
integriert werden können, und wir haben ja Arbeitskräftebedarf.
Dann würde der Staat etwa 30 Milliarden Euro sparen.
Und zwar 15 Milliarden auf der Einnahmen und 15 Milliarden auf der Ausgabenseite.
Nicht die Diagnose und nicht der Befund, sondern die Frage, wie Sie es machen,
die Therapie interessiert uns. Ja, indem wir den Druck erhöhen.
Wie machen Sie das? Das bedeutet einfach, dass wir dafür sorgen, dass diejenigen,
die sich entscheiden, obwohl sie arbeiten könnten, nicht zu arbeiten,
das kann man in einem freiheitlichen Land machen wie Deutschland,
aber dann darf man eben umgekehrt nicht erwarten, dass man dafür die Leistungen
durch die Allgemeinheit bekommt. Was machen Sie dann konkret?
Also wir werden das Bürgergeld in dieser Form abschaffen.
Wir werden daraus eine neue Grundsicherung machen, also es auch so benennen, wie es ist.
Wie hoch ist die? Dass die diejenigen bekommen, die wird so sein,
dass die Menschenwürde gegeben ist.
Wie hoch? Sie haben das doch bestimmt durchgerechnet. Ja, aber das sagt im Grunde
genommen auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht.
Aber sagen Sie es doch einfach mal, das Bundesverfassungsgericht ist gerade nicht da.
Wie hoch wird das sein? Also das sind Voraussetzungen, die sich der politischen
Entscheidung entziehen.
Haben Sie eine Idee, wie hoch das ist? Ja, aber ich will Ihnen...
Ich kann es ja kurz durchrechnen. 1,7 Millionen Leute und man will 10 Milliarden
sparen, das heißt man nimmt jedem ungefähr so 470 Euro weg.
Bei 470 Euro, bei 550 Euro Grundsicherung.
Also man reduziert den monatlichen Betrag auf ungefähr so 80 Euro oder was und
ich erinnere daran, wir haben von Bettina Vegoni vor einem Jahr diesen Text über die Needs gelesen,
wo die Sozialarbeiter sagten, 630.000 Leute aus eigener Kraft schaffen die das nie.
Aber in einer, Zitat, harten 1 zu 1 Betreuung kriegen wir jeden von denen innerhalb
eines Jahres für den Arbeitsmarkt fit.
Eine 1 zu 1 Betreuung bei 1,7 Millionen Leuten bedeutet nicht,
man kürzt die alle auf 70 Euro runter, sondern man stellt den einen vollen Bezugsträger daneben,
der einfach als Sozialarbeiter mit einem ordentlichen Gehalt sozusagen nur für
den zuständig ist, in der Hoffnung, dass der ihn ertüchtigt,
die nächsten 40 Jahre Beitragszahler in der Sozialkasse zu sein.
Der schildert das ja auch so, dieser allgemeine Fachkräftemangel oder Arbeitskräftemangel
sehe so aus, als würden die Bürgergeldempfänger aus Ingenieuren und so weiter
bestehen, die einfach noch keine Lust haben zu arbeiten.
Das ist 1850er Denker Reservearmee. Das kann einfach gar nicht wahr sein 2024.
Ich will Ihnen beispielsweise sagen, was politische Entscheidung war.
Ich würde gerne wissen, wie hoch das sein wird.
Diese neue Grundsicherung, sagen Sie doch mal den Begriff, neue Grundsicherung.
Grundsicherung statt Bürgergeld, weil Bürgergeld ja so etwas suggeriert,
als wäre das ein staatlicher Rechtsanspruch. Wie viel ist Bürgergeld jetzt?
Die Leute wollen das wissen.
Ja, aber der entscheidende Punkt ist nicht die Höhe.
Wir hätten zum Beispiel...
Kopf und Kragen, das ist wirklich...
Und wenn das Bürgergeld nicht 573, sondern 562 wäre, dann würden die alle zur Arbeit rennen.
Weil ja auch überall die Arbeit ist, suggeriert.
Und es ist auch gar kein Matching-Problem oder so. Die Leute müssen einfach
nur von ihrem Schlafplatz vor der Fabrikhalle reingebracht werden,
wo sie am Band stehen und Schrauben sortieren oder was auch immer die Vorstellung ist.
Also die Handwerksbetriebe betonen das ja auch.
Sie bekommen Kinder aus der Schule, die eigentlich aus funktionierenden Familien,
keine Ahnung, es wurde noch ein Abschluss geschrieben, aber sie sind unfähig
mit denen irgendwas zu machen. Die müssen so viel kognitiv mobilisieren.
Wenn jemand zehn Jahre aus dem Arbeitsleben raus war, ist da einfach gar nichts
von Definition Reservearmee und so weiter.
Wir hören uns aber trotzdem ein bisschen weiter, denn wir müssen verstehen,
daraus ist kein Programm zu stricken.
Die CDU, das wird eine Bauchladung, das wird schlimmer als bei der Ampel.
Das ist ja Voodoo, wenn man sagt, doch, doch, das ist der Zaubertrick von Jens Spahn.
Wenn man sagt, am Ende sparen wir zehn Milliarden, aber wie viel wir vorne einsparen,
sage ich euch erst gar nicht.
Wie hoch ist diese Grundsicherung? Überhaupt gar nicht. Ich habe ja jetzt vorhin
eine Zahl genannt. Es wären 30 Milliarden, wenn Sie eine Million.
Statt 563, das versteht jeder. Aber Herr Lanz, das ist für uns nicht der entscheidende Punkt.
Doch für uns, aber für mich auch gar nicht. Sie sind ja kein Bürgergeldempfänger.
Darum geht es doch gar nicht.
Aber ich bin Steuerzahler, so wie alle anderen auch. Genau, und deswegen wollen
Sie, dass nicht Menschen, die eigentlich arbeiten, könnten Bürgergeld beziehen.
Das müssen wir ändern. Ich will nur verstehen, wie seriös sozusagen zu sagen
ist, wir sparen 10 Milliarden.
Können die Summe nicht sagen? Wollen Sie nicht sagen? Doch, ich finde,
ich habe Ihre Frage ziemlich konkret beantwortet.
Das Entscheidende ist, die Zahl der Bürgergeldempfänger zu reduzieren.
Und daraus ergibt sich die Einsparung von der, Carsten Winne-Mann,
gesprochen hat. Okay, dann übersetze ich es mal.
Sie gehen davon aus, dass das Verfassungsgericht wird Ihnen sagen,
müssen wir auf diese 500, sagen
wir mal grob 550 Euro, die könnt ihr nicht anfassen. Das bleibt. Oder?
Wollen Sie drunter gehen? Aber das Bundesverfass... Ganz kurz,
wollen Sie drunter gehen oder höher gehen? Nicht für diejenigen, die bedürftig sind.
Nicht für diejenigen, die bedürftig sind. Ne, nochmal, jetzt erst mal nur um
die Höhe. Ja, für diejenigen, die bedürftig sind, ist es völlig in Ordnung.
Im Übrigen in der sozialen Marktwirtschaft ist es essentiell,
dass wir diejenigen, die nicht so leistungskräftig sind, auch tatsächlich unterstützen.
Widerstürzt ja gar niemand.
Okay, also Sie können es im Grunde nicht sagen, weil da auch viel Verfassung mit drin ist.
Ach ja. Ja, aber die Frage der 1,7 Millionen, von denen Sie sagen, wir könnten alle.
Also, 1,7 Millionen könnten, wollen nicht.
Genau, und jetzt nennt Thorsten Freigleich die Zahl, also den Betrag,
auf den er deren Unterstützung absenken will.
Wie machen Sie das? Wie bauen Sie den Druck auf? Sie haben vorhin das schöne
Wort aktivieren benutzt, das gefällt mir.
Wie aktivieren Sie? In dem einfach ganz klar gesagt wird, wer nicht arbeitet,
obwohl er arbeiten kann, der kriegt diese staatliche Leistung nicht. Also null?
Null? Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat es im Übrigen auch...
Null.
Wer glaubt, er nimmt 1,7 Millionen Menschen, die monatliche finanzielle Möglichkeit
überhaupt zu leben und dann stehen sie plötzlich dem Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung?
Die kommen dann mit hungrigem Bauch wie in Germinal von Emil Solard dahin.
Gefragt, wer Termine nicht wahrnimmt, wer Arbeitsangebote nicht annimmt.
Und da geht es auch um die Frage der Zumutbarkeit.
Der dokumentiert damit im Grunde genommen, dass er diese staatlichen Leistungen
nicht braucht. Okay, ich will es nur verstehen. Bitte, kein Angriff.
Dann null. Ich empfinde das auch nicht als Angriff. Ist das rechtlich machbar?
Ist das ähnlich? Aus meiner Sicht, ja. Nein. Aus ihrer Sicht nicht wachbar.
Frau Amann ist auch Juristin, aus ihrer Sicht nicht wachbar.
Keine Verfassungsrechtlerin, aber ein Streichen auf Null wäre verfassungsrechtlich nicht zulässig.
Man muss das Existenzminimum vorhalten. Ob das Existenzminimum die 563 Euro
sind, darüber kann man streiten.
So, ich erspare uns jetzt, dass es die nächste halbe Stunde um Migration ging.
Wir können uns alle vorstellen, wie die CDU ist.
Melanie Ammann sagt, glaube ich, sogar in dieser Runde, dass sie das Bürgergeld
zu hoch empfindet, wo man sich auch wundern muss.
Was wird sie verdienen? 250.000 Euro im Jahr?
Genau, eine gute Chefredaktion.
Die Chefredaktion sitzt da und sagt, Bürgergeld ist zu hoch.
Genau, also die CDU ist so radikal, die sagt einfach, Bürgergeld null und Asyl gibt es nicht mehr.
Es werden alle abgewiesen. Es kann niemand mehr hier kommen, weil Schengen und so.
Wir hören nur ganz kurz, nur um kurz zu verstehen, okay, es war jetzt so Bürgergeld,
jetzt kommt es zur Migration.
Aber können wir vielleicht zu dem Ausgangspunkt zurückgehen?
Sie haben ja gesagt, okay, es kommt eigentlich, kommen diese Einsparungen darüber,
dass sie all diese Menschen in Arbeit bringen.
Finde ich super. Können wir sofort da zusammenarbeiten, das hinzubekommen, aber wie?
Das finde ich auch gut, dass sie bei Thorsten Frey noch sitzt.
Das ist auch diese feministische Ader, die ich mehr sehen will.
Also nicht feministische, sondern diese neue, nicht patriale Ader.
Patriarchale, ach das ist nicht.
Herr Frey, also ich beschimpfe sie jetzt nicht und ich versuche jetzt auch nicht ein Arrogantes und so.
Gut, können wir ja gerne. Ich suche jetzt die allerletzten Anknüpfungspunkte,
die irgendwo noch zu sehen.
Machen Sie das. Wenn Sie jetzt ganz schnell eine Wahl wollen,
dann brauchen Sie da eine Antwort drauf.
Ja, da gehört neben dem Fördern eben auch das Fordern. Okay,
also mit stärkeren Sanktionen. Ja, mit der Anrunde Sanktionen. Hat er ja klar.
Mit Druck, wenn Sie so wollen. Wir schauen jetzt, ob das hier...
Alles gut. Lass uns weitergehen.
Die zweiten 10 Milliarden kamen aus der Migration, richtig? So, wie machen Sie das?
So, wir reden jetzt nicht über Migration. Ich will nur noch einen Clip spielen.
Ich habe jetzt über Monate betont, langfristiges Denken, Familie einbeziehen.
Ich habe schon in der Alten Republik aus der 100 Tage im Amt Joe Biden-Rede
zitiert, wo er sagte, Wir befinden uns in einem für Amerikas Existenz relevanten
Systemstreit mit China.
Und die Speerspitze in dieser Auseinandersetzung ist die amerikanische Familie.
Wenn die amerikanische Familie keinen Nachwuchs liefert, der,
welches ihr auch immer, in die Investitionsbranche, in die Ingenieurs,
in die Informatik geht, wird das hier nichts.
Einfach nur mit großen ökonomischen Kennziffern sind wir ausgeliefert.
Wenn die amerikanische Familie weiterhin leidet, wird das nichts.
Mein Programm ist und dann Betreuungsgeld, Kindergeld, Kindererziehung,
Recht und so weiter und so fort.
Das wurde ihm alles von Joe Manchin damals kurz und klein geschlagen.
Es war genau dieser eine Senator in einer 50-50 Senatoren-Auseinandersetzung,
in der es nicht funktioniert hat, das zu machen.
Jetzt hören wir Philippa Siegel-Klöckner, wie sie das betont,
dass wir hier langfristig und ausgehend von Integration und Bildung an den nächsten
Arbeitnehmerjahrgang denken müssen und zwar groß.
Nicht der kleine Bürgergeldempfänger, sondern der nächste zivilisatorische Schritt.
Wenn die Schule ausfällt und die Familien leiden, wird das nichts mit dem nächsten
Arbeitnehmerjahrgang.
Jetzt gerade ist alles, alle sind verteilt, die Leute bauen immer noch Autos,
warum auch immer und wir haben keine Reservearmee.
Das ist kein Zustand, in dem wir vorgehen wollen.
Es geht ungefähr drei Minuten, es ist ein Spektakel und ich will betonen,
von Männern, die im Wahlkampf sind, hören wir sowas nicht.
Und das ist ein Problem, weshalb ich nochmal sage, dann müssen diese Männer
da aussortiert werden. Wir brauchen jetzt Leute, die vernünftige Argumente bringen
und zweitens, sie müssen wählbar sein.
Das habe ich gleich nochmal auf die Linkspartei kurz zu sprechen kommen,
aber das ist im Grunde das Programm für die nächsten 30 Jahre.
Das ist das Programm für die alten Republik.
Würdest du uns das retten? Nein, das ist gut zu machen und zu diversifizieren
ist gut, aber sie klammern sich an ein Geschäftsmodell, das so nicht sicher ist.
Und wir sollten uns darauf konzentrieren, unser Geschäftsmodell besser auszubalancieren.
Das ist ja auch die Frage, wieso müssen wir eigentlich so viele große Autos ins Ausland verkaufen?
Gleichzeitig sagen wir hier, wir haben einen ganz großen Fachkräftemangel in
vielen Berufen, die wir eigentlich mehr brauchen.
Wir brauchen mehr Lehrer, Lehrerinnen, mehr Erzieherinnen, Erzieher.
Also wieso versuchen wir nicht etwas von diesem Geschäftsmodell,
das wie im Tropf hängt, dass wir immer mehr Autos ins Ausland schicken, wegzukommen.
Aber was heißt das? Entschuldigung. Sie schulen die dann um die Leute?
Was machen Sie mit denen?
Nein, ich möchte in den nächsten Generationen mehr Lehrerinnen und Lehrer ausbilden. Nächste Generation?
Das ist langer Atem. Ja, aber die müssen sehr bezahlen.
Die müssen sehr bezahlen. Und das funktioniert gut, weil wenn Sie mehr Lehrerinnen
und Lehrer haben, haben Sie eine höhere Produktivität, mehr Menschen sind besser ausgebildet.
Dann kommen wir genau zu dem Punkt, den Sie vorhin angesprochen haben.
Wie kriegen wir mehr Menschen in Arbeit?
Lehrer, die Geld verdienen, verdienen nicht so viel wie ihre Unternehmenseigentümer,
die ihr Geld aus der Realwirtschaft rausziehen, im Finanzmarkt in Amerika anlegen,
sondern die geben ihr Geld wieder in Deutschland aus, sodass es hier wieder
Nachfrage gibt und es ein sehr viel gesunderer Wirtschaftskreislauf.
Ja, aber die Stärke Deutschlands ist doch, dass wir einen verhältnismäßig hohen
Industrieanteil haben, einen hohen Anteil verarbeitenden Gewerbes.
Sie müssen ja irgendwo Wertschöpfung generieren, bevor sie Staatsbeamte bezahlen,
bevor sie Dienstleistungen ermöglichen.
Also die Grundvoraussetzung, die es gibt. Ja, aber die Grundvoraussetzung für
Ihre Industrie ist überhaupt erst mal die Erzieherin und es ist überhaupt erst mal der Lehrer.
Also die brauchen Sie, die haben wir zu wenig und deswegen können die Leute
da schon nicht arbeiten. Ja, aber das Problem der deutschen Wirtschaft ist nicht,
dass es zu wenig gut ausgebildete Menschen in Deutschland gäbe.
Doch, doch. Also wir haben einen massiven Fachkräftemangel. Da muss ich Ihnen
jetzt einfach geradeaus widersprechen. Ja, natürlich haben wir das.
Ich bin jetzt keine Ökonomin, aber ich glaube, es ist keine Lösung jetzt zu
versuchen, die Industrie auszuspielen gegen die Lehrer.
Wir brauchen beides gleichermaßen. Nein, nein, ich will es nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen. Ich will es in eine gesundere Balance bringen.
Momentan verbrauchen wir den Bestand, weil wir nicht die Kinder in dem Maße
ausbilden. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das die einzige Antwort ist.
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch etwas Zweites machen, das Schweden geschafft hat,
was wir bisher nicht geschafft haben.
Die haben ihre Dienstleistungsindustrie sehr stark modernisiert.
Die haben viel datengetriebene Dienstleistung, ICT-Services.
Ja, stimmt. Und wenn sie die verbinden mit der klassischen Industrie,
wird sie viel produktiver und wettbewerbsfähiger. Und da hinken wir hinterher.
Funktioniert aber auch wieder nur, wenn sie gut ausgebildete Fachkräfte haben.
Es ist richtig, das eine, ohne das andere zu lassen. Aber Schüler sind ja jetzt
nicht die nächsten Fachkräfte.
Aber ich finde, der wichtigere Punkt ist der, den Sie da vorgemacht haben,
finde ich, welches Geschäftsmodell hat die deutsche Wirtschaft auch.
Und das ist ja was, worüber die Ampel sich sehr, sehr grundsätzlich gestritten
hat. Zum Beispiel beim Industriestrompreis.
Ja, Melanie Ammann versteht aber auch nur die Hälfte leider.
Sie versteht gar nichts.
Oder gar nichts. Problem.
Torsten Frey möchte im März eine Bundestagswahl gewinnen. Das ist das Einzige.
Der hat kein anderes Ziel. Er kann vielleicht nochmal, da warte,
lass mich kurz sagen, er kann vielleicht nochmal jetzt Minister werden.
Danach ist er auch altersbedingt aussortiert. Das ist jetzt seine Chance.
Melanie Ammann, für sie interessiert sich einfach nur für den nächsten Tag,
weil sie macht halt Spiegel Online und Torsten Frey ist halt ein Typ,
der gerade Action verspricht, also klebt sie an ihm dran und so weiter.
Da ist kein langfristiges Denken zu erwarten. Das, was wir Ja.
Der Südekum war ja mit mir in Dortmund, hat er auch einen Vortrag gehalten zum
Thema Demografie und so weiter.
Er hat dann einfach die Babyboomer-Blase, die jetzt noch im Arbeitsleben ist,
mal 15 Jahre in die Zukunft, zack, Rentensystem ist einfach aussortiert.
Ist ja soweit bekannt. Und er hat nochmal diesen Punkt gebracht,
die Agentur für Arbeit ist der größte Arbeitgeber staatlicherseits.
Ich will immer noch betonen, ungefähr die Hälfte, fast die Hälfte aller Beamten
sind Lehrer, aber eben nicht bei allem Angestellten, sondern in den Schulen.
Der größte Arbeitgeber für den Staat ist die Bundesagentur für Arbeit.
Dort gehen in den nächsten zehn Jahren 30.000 Menschen in Rente oder Pension, je nachdem.
Diese Leute dürfen wir niemals ersetzen. Hier brauchen wir eine technische Lösung.
Diese Leute schreiben Bescheide, weisen, gucken sich irgendwelche Excel-Tabellen
an, was auch immer, bedienen Computer.
Wenn wir es nicht schaffen, diese Leute durch irgendeine Technologie zu ersetzen
und wir haben jetzt eine KI, die relativ weit mitdenken kann,
zielprogrammiert, einfach Bescheid lesen, verstehen, schreiben und wie auch
immer kann, dann schaffen wir das nicht.
Und so müssen wir auch mit der Autoindustrie umgehen. Nein.
Doch.
Die Autoindustrie hat ihr Produkt gehabt. Sie hat es zehn Jahre zu lang getrieben.
Die anderen haben sie überholt.
Elektroautos sind so einfach zu bauen, dass es nicht mehr zehn Konkurrenten
gibt, sondern einfach 15.000. Jeder baut ein Elektroauto.
Das ist ganz typisch für die Automobilindustrie.
Wenn man sich die ansieht in den 20er Jahren, da gab es unglaublich viele Autohersteller
und dann gibt es irgendwann eine Marktkonsolidierung und dann bleiben nur noch
wenige. Und beim Elektroauto wird das auch so sein, weil das Elektroauto Hightech ist.
Man braucht für diese Motoren nicht so viel Manpower, wie man das benötigt jetzt
für die Verbrenner, aber man braucht in anderer Weise viele Leute,
die dort arbeiten werden.
Dass diese Transformation besonders von den Managements verschlafen wurde und
von der Politik das auch nicht gepusht und unterstützt wurde, stimmt nicht.
Ich hatte jetzt sehr viel zu tun mit Gewerkschaftern, die jetzt gerade sehr
darum bangen, um ihre Arbeitsplätze und die jetzt Kurzarbeitergeld und alles
mögliche bekommen sollen. Das ist ein ganz großes Desaster.
Die deutschen Autos sind nach wie vor sehr gut. Und wenn man in einige E-Autos,
ich nenne jetzt keine Namen, von ausländischen Herstellern reingeht,
hat man eher den Eindruck, man ist auf der Kirmes und fährt nochmal Autoscooter.
Ich will die nicht alle über einen Kamm schweren, jetzt würde ich sagen,
das deutsche Auto ist das allerbeste überhaupt und so, aber die deutsche Autoindustrie
ist schon sehr gut und die Leute, die dort arbeiten, sind hochqualifiziert und motiviert.
Und worum es doch jetzt hier gehen muss, ist, wie kriegt man jetzt dort eine
Transformation schnell auf die Beine und da wird es auch Geld brauchen und zwar
auch staatliche Unterstützung, um eine E-Mobilität auch hier zu fördern.
Deswegen würde ich dieses nicht so sehen, dass man sagt, wir wickeln jetzt die
Autowirtschaft ab, um Lehrer zu haben.
Es stimmt, dass wir mehr in die Bildung investieren müssen und es stimmt auch,
dass wir uns mehr einfallen lassen müssen, als immer weiter nur Autos zu produzieren,
weil tatsächlich die Konkurrenz da auf diesem Markt härter wird.
Aber was wir, glaube ich, hier eher mitnehmen müssen ist, und das ist genau
das Problem an dem Exportweltmeister Deutschland immer gewesen, dass man sagte.
Wir versuchen unsere Ware im Ausland zu verkaufen, uns ist egal,
was hier im Land gekauft wird.
Was man daran auch gut sehen konnte, dass es sehr leicht war,
Lockdowns durchzuführen. Die Industrie funktionierte weiter.
Ob die Leute in Geschäfte gehen oder ins Restaurant, ist eigentlich für die Wirtschaft egal.
Der BIP-Verlust durch diese Lockdowns war relativ gering, wenn man bedenkt,
wie extrem es unser aller Leben betroffen hat.
Was also hier der Vorschlag von Philippa Siegel-Klöckner ist und den will ich
unterstreichen und unterschreiben, ist der, dass wir die Binnenwirtschaft stärken
müssen und das bedeutet zum Beispiel höhere Löhne.
Die Idee des Fordismus war einmal, dass jeder Ford-Arbeiter sich auch einen Ford kaufen kann.
Wir produzieren in Deutschland vorwiegend Autos für Leute, die niemals in der
Autoindustrie arbeiten würden, es sei denn sie sind im Management,
weil sie sonst sich so ein Auto nicht leisten können.
Der normale Arbeiter kann sich diese BMW, Mercedes und so weiter gar nicht kaufen.
Und man muss heute schon wirklich irgendwo in der Range Zahnarztnotar sonst
was sein, um sich ein solches Auto leisten zu können.
Sie will auch sonst niemand mehr kaufen.
Das ist einfach falsch. Und deswegen brauchen wir eine Stärkung der Binnenwirtschaft,
aber wir müssen an dem Industriestandort Deutschland natürlich festhalten,
alles andere wäre katastrophal.
Am Industriestandort ja, aber der Glaube Da gehört.
Auch die Autoindustrie dazu.
Von mir aus, aber der Glaube, dass das E-Auto,
Ein Pfad ist, der beim Verbrennerauto begann, ist falsch.
Ja, das ist eine Zäsur.
Wir brauchen dafür ganz neue Fabriken, ganz neue Logistikketten,
ganz neue Zulieferquellen für ganz andere Materialien aus aller Welt.
Das ist ein Neubau der Autoindustrie, wenn überhaupt, während aber viele gerade
einen Neubau der Autoindustrie machen, die Chinesen auch.
Ja, und hier wird er verhindert, verschleppt und sonst was.
Genau. Und das, was wir bisher hatten, also die Zahlen, ich will nur kurz nennen,
durch die Bank haben wir Gewinneinbrüche um 80 bis 90 Prozent bei VW,
bei BMW, bei Audi, überall.
Ja, ja, ich empfehle das.
Und das geht von heute auf morgen, das geht so schnell. Die deutsche Autoindustrie
hat sehr lange davon profitiert, dass es in Deutschland so eine,
ja, das Auto kostet zwar eigentlich 90.000 Euro, aber wir können es für dich
so für 450 Euro im Monat leasing.
Diese Kette, die vom Herstellungsprozess, als erstes kauft man die Mercedes-Benz
Bank, 90% aller S-Klassen, dann gibt es da Regelungen über Dienstwagenprivilegien,
Benzin wird dann über so eine Karte abgebucht, sie wissen gar nicht,
wie das funktioniert, aber am Ende fahren sie so ein Auto.
Diese ganze Kette ist kaputt gegangen. Es liegt völlig da nieder.
Und in China kauft auch keiner mehr diese Autos. Also es ist wirklich dramatisch.
Und ja, am Industriestandort, finde ich auch, sollten wir unbedingt festhalten.
Aber das einfache Denken, wir müssen nur die Autos ein bisschen verändern,
das ist nicht die Lösung.
Und de facto ist es ja für die Leute, die jetzt in solche Berufe reingehen oder
die jetzt entsprechende Ausbildungen oder Studien machen,
natürlich dann auch klar, dass die sich schon auf was anderes einstellen und
die sind ja nicht an das Auto an sich gebunden, die werden in anderen Bereichen
dann natürlich tätig sein.
Jetzt sind wir schon so weit fortgeschritten in der Zeit, so lang waren wir
noch nie. Jetzt musst du noch ganz kurz was zu deinen Frauen unter 40 bei der
Dings-Partei sagen, das wolltest du noch auswerten.
Ich finde es wirklich beeindruckend, wie auch unsere Buchautoren,
die wir sehr mögen, so langsam bei der Linken einfach auftauchen und demnächst
vielleicht auch wählbar sind.
Also Canzin Köktürk ist jetzt bei den Linken.
Sarah Lee Heinrich wurde plötzlich von Ines Schwertner begrüßt auf der großen Bühne des Parteitags.
Ines Schwertner selbst ist natürlich ein Phänomen.
Heidi Reichenick macht einfach Spaß zuzuschauen. Also sowohl im Bundestag als
auch, ich habe noch den lustigen Tweet, also Herr Merz, wenn Sie was gegen Schwangerschaftsabbrüche
haben, dann lassen Sie doch einfach keiner an sich machen.
Wieso belästigen Sie mich jetzt mit Ihrer Vorliebe für irgendwas und so.
Außerdem Lea Reisner wurde im Landesvorstand der Linken in NRW gewählt.
Das kann man sich ruhig mal auf YouTube anschauen. Sie war ja auch einmal mindestens
im Fernsehpodcast zu Gast oder damals auch beim Aufwachen und so.
Das sind einfach junge Leute, die sagen, also die gehen auf die Bühne und sagen,
ich habe Präkariatserfahrung, bin gelernte Krankenschwester,
habe vier Jahre auf der was auch immer Schiff im Mittelmeer Menschen gerettet
und jetzt habe ich mir gedacht, hier muss sich mal was ändern, ich trete jetzt an.
Das ist doch die Partei, auf die ich immer gewartet habe. Und zwar insbesondere
unter dem Diktum endlich einer Partei, der ist, ja, ich weiß,
Wahlkampf, aber der, wo es mir egal ist, ob sie jetzt im nächsten Bundestag sitzt oder nicht.
Denen wird es nicht egal sein.
Ja genau, aber ich möchte ja nur für mich eine wählbare politische Alternative
zu dem ganzen anderen Schrott, den ich da gerade sehe.
Denn an dem Märzzeitalter führt gerade nichts vorbei. und so wie beim Trump-Zeitalter
denke ich auch, ja, das wird so ein paar Sachen bereinigen.
Oder Olaf macht's doch noch so auf den letzten Metern.
Oder Olaf nochmal, aber Olaf oder Merz ist für mich derselbe Schmerz.
Also ob jetzt Blackrock oder Cum-Ex, ich weiß, die eine haben wir nochmal.
Wir kommen jetzt nicht dazu, aber alles, was man mit Sozialdemokratie verbindet
und von der CDU unterscheidet, ist während der Ampel liegen geblieben.
Man hat nur das absolut Mindeste, Notwendigste gemacht, wo ich mir denke,
das hätte die CDU jetzt auch gemacht.
Das entweder oder gegen das sich Scholz jetzt stellt, hat er die ganze Zeit mitgemacht.
Genau, also ich hoffe auf Bundestagsreden im nächsten Bundestag der Linken und
ansonsten halt vier Jahre später.
Wir werden sehen. Wir weisen nochmal darauf hin, dass wir den Salon dann nächste
Woche veröffentlichen.
Wir sprechen da über Peter Sloterdijk, der Kontinent ohne Eigenschaften.
Damit ist Europa gemeint. Das ist das Europabuch von Sloterdijk.
Darüber werden wir ausführlich diskutieren, denn Quo Vadis Europa.
Diese Frage wird uns jetzt umtreiben, gerade durch diese Wahl von Donald Trump.
Außerdem wird es von mir wieder Musik geben und auch Literatur.
Aber sonst würde ich mir mal noch alles offen halten bis dahin.
Es gibt jedenfalls sehr viele lesenswerte Texte, die in diesem Monat erschienen
sind und die es wert sind, vorgestellt zu werden.
Ich denke nicht vorbei kommen wir an Isabella Weber, die hat sowohl im Jakobin
als auch in der Taz über ihre antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik gesprochen,
die ich, so wie bei der feministischen Außenpolitik, des Begriffs nach jetzt
nicht sehr attraktiv finde, aber die zumindest das Problem dann richtig beschreibt.
Den Rest mal sehen. Es ist ja auch, die Assmanns haben ja ein Buch zum Gemeinsinn.
Vielleicht kriege ich das noch unter. Das wird auf jeden Fall,
wenn, dann nur verschoben.
Den Salon kann man hören über Patreon, wenn man dort schon angemeldet ist,
oder Apple, wenn man es gerne bequem hat. Wir empfehlen allerdings Steady.
Das ist ganz einfach. Man geht auf die Seite neu20er.de.
Dort ist ein goldener Button, da steht Salon. Klickt man darauf,
kann man wählen zwischen den verschiedenen Mitgliedschaften.
Ab drei Euro ist man dabei. Man bekommt aber bei allen Mitgliedschaften auch dieselben Inhalte.
Es gibt da keine Hierarchisierung, das ist nur eine Frage, wie viel will jemand unterstützen.
Und wir weisen auch schon mal darauf hin, man kann dieses Abo auch verschenken,
da gibt es ein Geschenkverhältnis, es ist bald wieder Weihnachten.
Wer also gerne den Salon verschenken möchte, möglicherweise für Leute,
die sich für Politik interessieren oder mal aufgeklärt werden müssen in Sachen Schuldenbremse,
den kann man es also schenken, auch das ist da ganz einfach einzurichten.
Und dann würde ich sagen, gehen wir jetzt zum Schnitzelessen über,
denn heute ist mein Cheat Day.
Ich ernähre mich jetzt auch viel gesünder, aber dazu mal an einem anderen Tag
mehr. Jetzt also Cheat Day mit Schnitzel.
Das schlägt zu.
Ja, bis dann.
Bis dann.